Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Sag mal, der November ist auch schon wieder rum. Was hast du gemacht?
Ich hab selbstverständlich auf die Bundesregierung gehört und habe nichts getan.
So, ja, das war er, der November. Ich hab auch nichts getan, ehrlich gesagt. Es gab auch nichts zu tun. Wir müssen, glaube ich, ein ernstes Wort über diesen November verlieren, was das angeht.
Es war ein sehr eigenartiger Monat. Also ich habe selbstverständlich viel getan, hab sehr viel gelesen, mir sehr viele Filme angesehen, aber im Sinne von tun, etwas in der Öffentlichkeit tun, hinausgehen, all das hab ich überhaupt nicht getan. Und das war doch jetzt sehr, sehr eigenartig. Und ich war auch, glaube ich, noch nie so viel drin, wie in diesem Monat. Wirklich, bis auf kurze Spaziergänge, habe ich mich nur drin aufgehalten. Ich wusste auch beim besten Willen nicht wohin. Sonst fahre ich ja schon mal in die Stadt, aber wenn ich selbst dann dort irgendwo nicht mehr ein Stück Kuchen essen kann, dann ist auch für mich das Shopping-Erlebnis noch mal gemindert. Aber auf Shopping kommen wir noch später.
Ja, dieser November, wir haben ja auch zwischendurch überlegt, bietet es sich an, mal ein Salonspecial zu machen. Liegt irgendwas auf der Straße? Es muss doch irgendein Thema geben. Und es hat sich relativ zügig herausgestellt, nee, es liegt tatsächlich kein Thema einfach so. In jedem Monat vorher gab es immer mal eins, wo man dachte, das hätte man ruhig aus mal ein bisschen aktuell, einfach zeitnah besprechen können. Und diesmal im November gar nichts. Es gibt also auch eine Föhtordelle, der Medias Reis im Deutschlandfunk hat das mal behandelt, wie im Völder gerade nichts zu besprechen da ist. Und man deswegen halt irgendwas aufgreift. Ich hab auch bei mir jetzt gemerkt, wir haben jetzt die letzten Wochen immer Wochenends wirklich einen Kuchen gebacken einfach. Weil man geht ja auch nicht raus oder so. Wir haben also wirklich uns an einer Schwarzwälder Kirschtorte versucht. Die ist uns auch ganz gut gelungen. Ist allerdings so sahnig, dass man sie nicht gern isst, finde ich. Wir haben Donauwelle gebacken. Gestern gab es Käsekuchen und man schleppt sich so durch irgendwie. Man fühlt sich wirklich mitten in der Rentenrepublik.
Ja, wenngleich man ja dann sich doch auch vertiefen kann in Themen. Und das ist auch so ein bisschen das Resultat jetzt bei den Sachen, die ich heute vorstelle, dass ich einfach genügend Zeit hatte, mich zu vertiefen in etwas. Also nochmal zu fragen, wie sieht denn das eigentlich aus, wenn jetzt Biden der neue Präsident ist? Was hat er denn geopolitisch vor? Was möchte der außenpolitisch bewirken? Und da kann man einfach mal tiefer reingehen. Da gibt es dann aktuell gar nicht so viel zu. Aber man kann noch mal schauen, was war da eigentlich 2012 los? Oder jetzt auch mit dem neuen Freihandelsabkommen in Asien. Wie wird sich das alles verändern? Also es sind vielleicht die ganz großen Themen dann doch, die nicht diese tagesaktuelle Hektik bei einem auslösen, die aber dann in fünf oder zehn Jahren ganz entscheidend sind. Und das finde ich eigentlich immer ganz schön, sich da zu vertiefen, wenngleich es ein bisschen mehr Action ruhig hätte sein dürfen.
Genau. Also in deren Sicht würde ich sagen, war es doch ein ertragreicher Monat. Denn ja, es wurden wirklich Pfeiler eingeschlagen. Also dieses große Freihandelsabkommen, das wirklich nur Freihandel bedeutet. Es hat kaum eine politische Dimension. Also Arbeitsrechte, Klima oder so spielt da keine Rolle. Apple hat einen neuen Computer vorgestellt. Wir kommen nachher kurz darauf zu sprechen. Also Leute rasten aus, sind so begeistert von Technik. Ich hab das lange nicht mehr gesehen. Ich dachte, wir kommen jetzt an so eine Schwelle, wo die Technik so langsam in den Alltag und in die Selbstverständlichkeit übergeht. Und man nicht mehr nur, weil man Spaß am Gerät hat, ein Gerät bedient. Ganz falsch. Apple hat jetzt ein Ding vorgelegt, mit dem einfach wirklich mal viele Leute gerne einfach wieder Computersachen machen und richtig auf der Suche sind nach Aufgaben, die man mit einem Computer machen kann, weil es jetzt mal wieder besser geht. Also in der Ansicht, und das wird auch, da kommen nachher auch auf zehn Jahreshorizonte zu sprechen. Aber so kulturell einfach, so Reflektion, gab es wenig. Deswegen bemühen wir uns heute doch noch, Reste aus diesem Monat zusammen zu suchen.
Bevor wir so richtig anfangen, würde ich mal einen Clip abspielen wollen, der in einem ganz anderen Kontext aufgetaucht ist, und zwar bei Christian Eichler in seinem Filmpodcast Cuts. Da warst du ja auch kürzlich zu Gast. Ich bin ja auch wieder da. Ah, hatten die eine Ausgabe zu KOM und ZI. Darum soll es aber jetzt gar nicht gehen, sondern als Gast war dort Tino Hahn. Und dann fiel mir auch auf, ach ja, Tino Hahn, dem folgst du ja bei Twitter. Das ist ja auch so ein Filmexperte, aber du hast lange keinen Tweet mehr von dem gesehen. Was ist denn da los? Wo ist der eigentlich? Und diese Frage stellt auch Christian Eichler. Und da hören wir mal ganz kurz rein. Wir haben ja schon über Zensur, über Free Speech und all das gesprochen. Und jetzt mal hier etwas sehr Kurioses.
Tino, was ist bei dir eigentlich los, mein Junge? Schön, dass wir uns hier mal hören. Du bist von, viele kennen dich, denke ich mal unter anderem auch, von Twitter und du bist da quasi so ein bisschen im Exil, weil du was, weil du Hip-Hop-Lyrics gepostet hast und das als Aufruf zur Gewalt oder so gesehen wurde vom Algorithmus oder irgendwie so. Erklär das noch mal bitte.
Was sehr absurd ist, aber jedenfalls hat jemand geschrieben, dass ich zusammen mit einem Bekannten doch mal zum RTL-Promi-Boxen gehen sollte. Und darauf habe ich als Erwiderung geschrieben. Ich zertrete dich wie Popcorn, verändere deine Kopfform, was aus irgendeinem von diesen Frankfurter Hip-Hop-Songs aus den frühen 90ern ist. Das wurde Twitter gemeldet und jetzt bin ich lebenslang gesperrt wegen Gewaltandrohung.
Verrückt, oder? Ich bekam in diesem Monat auch zwei Meldungen. Also offenbar hat da auch jemand versucht, mich zu sperren, aber wegen eines einfachen Tweets hier interessanter Artikel in der Zeit oder sowas. Also man versucht das wohl offenbar jetzt Leute zu bennen von Twitter. Und das ist natürlich sehr verrückt, dass dann man auch wenig Chancen wohl hat. Das hat er dann noch danach gesagt, dort bei Twitter jemanden zu erreichen und zu sagen, naja, also passt mal auf, man muss hier mal diesen Kontext sehen. Ich kann jedenfalls sagen, Tino ist ein sehr friedliebender Mensch. Ich bin mit ihm schon mal bei den Rocket Beans aufgetreten. Man braucht keine Angst vor ihm zu haben, auch Twitter nicht.
Ja, wir reden ja nachher über Jack Dorseys neue Macht. Die Republikaner haben eine Wahl verloren. Das müssen wir jetzt gar nicht groß thematisieren. Es ist schon wieder auch fast eine antike Geschichte, dass Donald Trump die Wahl verloren hat, auch wenn es lang gedauert hat. Aber die Republikaner haben einen neuen Blick auf Silicon Valley. Es ist doch ganz erstaunlich. Es gab wieder Anhörungen, unter anderem mit Jack Dorsey. Da kommen wir nachher darauf zurück. Ich will an der Stelle noch mal kurz sagen. Ich bin zurück bei Katz am 18. Dezember, wenn wir das Gesamtwerk von Michael Bay besprechen. Oh Gott. Ich hatte ja lange Sorgen, weil ich das Thema kannte, dass er das schon vorgestellt hat. Warum ich nicht gefragt werde, habe dann sogar im klotzenden Vorgespräch zu unserer Borat-Besprechung so eine Anmerkung gemacht, wie du befristest ja bald Michael Bay und so. Und dann kam doch noch per Twitter die Einladung an mich. Und dann habe ich ihn schon so gefragt. Ich dachte schon, du denkst nicht an mich. Aber er hat über Ecken gehört, dass ich wohl Michael Bay Fan bin. Und ich möchte es in der, ich habe jetzt alle Filme noch mal gesehen. Szenationell geil. Außer diese Transformers-Reihe. Ich verstehe es bis heute nicht. Das wird, glaube ich, ein sehr interessantes Gespräch. Das nochmal, weil ich bin mir selber unklar darüber, was Michael Bay da geritten hat. Den schlechtesten Film, den er gemacht hat, zu denken, ich versuche es nochmal. Und dann nochmal und nochmal und nochmal und naja.
Ich sag da jetzt mal gar nichts zum Thema.
Wir warten alle ab. Es wird ein stundenlanger Podcast über Michael Bay und ich bin, ich habe viele Notizen, sag uns mal so. Gut, Michael Bay, da wollen wir diesen Joke mache ich gerne mit. Das Niveau mal ganz unten. Wir beginnen ganz unten mit dem Niveau. Wir haben gesagt, niemand hat sich an Kunst versucht. Es gab auch in den Föhtons nicht zu besprechen. Dann ploppte doch was auf. Die Bundesregierung hat sich gedacht, sie veredelt doch mal in einem kulturellen Versuch, das nichts tun, das wir gerade beschrieben haben. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich bin erschüttert. Ich würde vorschlagen, wir gucken uns mal zum einen diesen Ausgangsklip, den viele im Ohr haben, an und dann spiegeln wir das nochmal mit einem anderen Clip und dann besprechen wir das mal. Also hier die Bundesregierung zum Thema. Wir können doch auch alle mal nichts tun und übers nichts tun Helden werden.
Ich glaube, das war im Winter 2020, als das ganze Land auf uns schaute. Ich war gerade 22 geworden, studierte Maschinenbau in Chemnitz, als die zweite Welle kam. 22. Diesem Alter will man doch feiern. Studieren, jemanden kennenlernen, als sowas oder mit Freunden ein Trinken gehen. Doch das Schicksal hatte andere Pläne mit uns. Eine unsichtbare Gefahr bedrohte alles, woran wir glaubten. Wir taten nichts. Absolut gar nichts. Wir waren faul wie die Waschbären. Tag und Nacht lang blieben wir auf unserem Arsch zu Hause und kämpften gegen die Ausbreitung des Coronavirus. Damals, in diesem Corona-Winter 2020.
Werde auch du zum Helden und bleib zu Hause. Zusammen gegen Corona. Die Bundesregierung signiert dieses Video. Ich finde, man kann solche Videos so machen, denn wir haben diese Sehgewohnheiten, denn wir haben alle mal eine Zeit erlebt, also wir jetzt speziell, wo es noch kein Internet gab, aber noch ganz schön viel Gidoknop im ZDF.
Genau, so sieht das ja aus.
Irgendwie so, genau. Das ist so für die Leute ab 30, die, also bei denen es echten Unterschied macht, ob sie zu Hause bleiben oder nicht, weil die mitten im Leben stehen. Und ich finde, man kann auch so ein Video machen, wenn man es dann irgendwann mal ironisch spricht. Und so ein Satz wie unsere Couch war die Front ist vielleicht auch ein Satz, der das wirklich anbietet, das ironisch zu brechen. Aber dieser Clip kommt mir viel zu ernst drüber und er ist auch ernst gemeint. Und das finde ich nicht gut.
Ja, er ist ungeheuer ernst gemeint und ich glaube, das hat auch Empörung ausgelöst deshalb, da dann viele sagten, na ja, wenn ihr das so ernst meint, dann kann ich das auch mal ernst meinen, nämlich insofern als ich als Student einen Kredit beantragen muss, um irgendwie über die Runden kommen zu kommen, da meine ganzen Nebenjobs weggefallen sind. Alle Menschen, die arbeiten müssen, die sich in Busse und U-Bahnen quetschen müssen, um zur Arbeit zu kommen, die nicht Homeoffice machen dürfen, mal vom ganzen Pflegepersonal abgesehen, auch die gehören ja noch dazu, die noch mal in ganz anderer Weise nicht nichts tun können. Die erzirren so etwas und ich kann das schon sehr verstehen und finde das auch jetzt nicht so übermäßig komisch. Also das ist wirklich so ein Spot, der eigentlich für Boomer ist, aber junge Leute glauben dann, das hat auch was mit ihnen zu tun. Das ist ja von Florida TV gemacht, also der Produktionsfirma von Joko und Klaas. Die haben das ganze Jahr lanciert und dann auch über ihre sozialen Kanäle geteilt. Das war sicherlich Teil des Deals auch, dass das so geschieht. Ich finde auch, ist sowieso rausgeschmissenes Geld. Also diese Botschaft war ja jedem klar. Wen soll dieser Spot jetzt irgendwie, wen soll da umstimmen? Wer sagt da jetzt ach so, dann bleibe ich hier zu Hause.
Genau und in der Hinsicht müssen wir das einer ganz harten Ideologiekritik, also eine Ideenkritik, müssen wir dir anmerken. Zum einen gibt es, glaube ich, produktionstechnisch anzumerken. Ich fand das jedenfalls sehr interessant. Wir hatten gestern im Fernsehpodcast ein Audio-Kommentar von jemandem, der meinte, die Idee für diesen Clip kam in der ersten Welle. Also die ist so von März, April, nämlich zu sagen, es waren Helden gebraucht. Was war die Heldentat? Naja, nichts tun. Das ist ja ziemlich witzig eigentlich. Kann man schon mal so trocken festhalten. Und dann ist die Frage, wie baut man das in einen Clip ein? Und dann hat sich die Idee aber zerschlagen, weil nämlich im April die Zahlen so runterging, dass das Thema Corona einfach nicht mehr präsent war. Also dieser Clip hätte im Mai, Juni, wenn er fertig produziert wäre, irgendwie komisch gewirkt. Auf der anderen Seite würde ich jetzt aber rückblickend sagen, nee, vielleicht wäre das der richtige Zeitpunkt gewesen, den Clip zu machen. So wie die auch die Chinesen, die sich sehr gut, mit so einer Art von kognitiver Propaganda, wo sie wirklich unter die Kopfhaut kriechen, die haben ja angefangen, nachdem die Welle in China, die ja nun nicht besonders groß war, China hat insgesamt 90.000 Fälle oder so, das ist also so viel wie Amerika gerade zwischen 6 und 14 Uhr macht. Das ist die komplette Welle in China gewesen. Und trotzdem haben die Chinesen das verstanden, überall im Land so Museen aufzubauen, wo der heldenhafte Kampf gegen Corona und so weiter, wirklich als hätte man einen Krieg überstanden, wie man das gemacht hat, weil es ein anhaltendes Problem ist bis zur Impfung. Man muss halt weiter Maske, man muss bewusst bleiben und so weiter und so fort. Und in deren Sicht hätte ich diesen Clip, glaube ich, super gut gefunden, wenn man wirklich im Moment der Erlösung, also die Impfung ist da, keine Ahnung, der Sommer kommt wieder, dann zurückblickt und sagt, lasst uns das mal nicht vergessen. Ja, so jetzt kommt dieser Clip aber im November oder Oktober, ja jetzt im November kam er sozusagen mit so einem gewissen Imperativ in die zweite Welle rein, wo man, wir haben uns schon drüber lustig gemacht, dass die Seebrücke irgendwie kam und meinte, ja als die Regierung feststellte, dass im Mittelmeer so viele Menschen starben, hat sie genau das gemacht, was alle wollten, nämlich nichts. So im Sinne von, die Leute wollen ja gar keine Menschen hier, so lassen wir sie lieber im Mittelmeer. Und dieses Nichts, die Bundesregierung macht ja auch gerade nichts, außer an uns zu appellieren, noch mal Kontakte zu mindern. Die organisieren uns keine Schnelltests, keine FFP2-Masken, nichts. Also da liegt einfach jetzt zu viel wirklich schwarzes Humor, Witsepotenzial in diesem Clip verborgen, um diesen Clip tatsächlich so ernsthaft so zu senden. Also in der Ansicht habe ich das halt gar nicht verstanden. Und, und das nervt mich eigentlich am meisten, Corona ist ja so eine Art Fitnesstest für die Gesellschaft, wo wir erstens feststellen, wir sind unglaublich zivilisationskrank. Wenn Jens Spahn so nebenbei sagt, Risikogruppe sind in Deutschland 40%, das führt hier gar nicht mehr zu einem gewissen Schock oder so, sondern Übergewicht Diabetes, das daraus folgt. Und zwar das Zweite, das wird völlig als normal hingenommen irgendwie. Also klar, wir bewegen uns halt nicht, wir sind halt alle krank. Also unsere Zivilisation hat uns wirklich wahnsinnig krank gemacht und das scheint niemandem zu stören. Und in deren Sicht finde ich diese Idealisierung eines eigentlichen Problems, weil es uns jetzt gerade nutzt, einen völlig falschen Ansatz. Und es ist ja nicht der einzige Clip gewesen, sondern es gibt noch einen anderen, nämlich über einsame Gamer. Den hören wir uns auch nochmal an. Und das finde ich, vielleicht bin ich auch ein bisschen zu sensibilisiert, weil ich jetzt so viel Rentenrepublik gemacht habe dieses Jahr. Aber ich finde, das geht einfach gar nicht, was sie hier in diesem Clip gemacht haben.
Dieses Stück Blech wurde mir damals umgehangen im Winter 2020. Kurz vor meinem 21. Ich wurde für meine besonderen Leistungen im Kampf gegen Corona ausgezeichnet. Und plötzlich war ich ein Held. Ein Idol, ein Musterbürger. Zugetraut hätte mir das niemand. Bevor Corona ausbrach, war ich ohne Zweifel die faulste Socke, die je durch dieses Land geschlichen ist. Ich habe meine Wohnung so gut wie nie verlassen, zockte ohne Ehrgeiz und aß kalte Ravioli direkt aus der Dose. Denn ich war zu faul, sie mir warm zu machen. Meine Freunde nannten mich den faulen Tobi. Aber ich war auch zu faul, um mich darüber aufzuregen. Als dann Corona ausbrach, blieb ich der gleiche faule Sack, der ich vorher auch gewesen bin. Aber im Gegensatz zu mir, hatte sich die Welt verändert. Um das Virus einzudämmen, forderte man die Leute auf, zu Hause zu bleiben. Nichts tun, war plötzlich ein Dienst an der Gemeinschaft. Faulheit konnte Leben retten. Und darin war ich Meister. Es waren besondere Zeiten damals, im Winter 2020. Besondere, schwere Zeiten. Aber es war leicht, ein Held zu sein.
Das ist eine Unverschämtheit. Und das finde ich so fahrlässig, das auch in dieser Weise zu tun. Also man kann nicht zum einen da suchtbeauftragte ständig los schicken, die halb Gares zum Thema Gaming loslassen. Denn das muss man ja auch mal sagen, die Kompetenz zum Thema Computerspiel ist so gut wie nicht vorhanden. Bei der Bundesregierung, auch bei den Landesregierungen nicht. Deswegen ist es erstmal meistens falsch, wenn sie Gamer abqualifizieren als vollkommen hohl. Und jetzt nehmen sie ihr Klischee, dass sie eigentlich im Kopf haben und wenden es mal ins Positive und sagt, ja, macht das ruhig mal so. Versifft da in euch selbst und alle anderen Folgen, zum Beispiel Ravioli täglich essen, sind vollkommen egal.
Ganz genau. Wir haben über Einsamkeit hier schon ganz ausführlich gesprochen anhand von Manfred Spitzers Buch. Diese Form der Weltflucht in Computerspiele, in dem Glauben, ich spiele da mit meinen Kumpels, ich bin also nicht allein, das hat auch was mit Sozialität zu tun oder so. Da gibt es einen gar nicht so schmalen Grad zwischen, das kann man eine oder zwei Stunden alle zwei Tage mal machen, und dann ist man auch mittendrin und dann lebt man dort auch eine Sozialität fort, die man ansonsten in der Schule erlebt oder keine Ahnung, im Studium und so. Man ist unter Menschen und spielt halt auch. Und dann gibt es aber dieses ganz große Spektrum mittlerweile und es beginnt dann doch relativ früh von Jugendlichen, die wirklich sich abgemeldet haben aus der Welt. Also die so im japanischen Stile nach Hause gehen, weil sie erstens wissen, da gehe ich kein Risiko ein, der Zurückweisung zum Beispiel. Da ist immer was los. Die Maschine, meine Konsole sucht mir schon Spieler für mich. Die Liste wird dann einfach gefüllt und jetzt spielst du halt gegen die und die und so. Und das darf niemals idealisiert werden. Nicht mal unter Corona-Bedingungen darf dieses Vorzeichen umgedreht werden, dass das ungesundes Verhalten ist, dass dich dein Leben lang unglücklich macht, weil du jetzt nie wieder los wirst, weil du verpasst Sachen zu lernen, die dir später vielleicht mal was nützen.
Und ich will noch ein anderes Beispiel nehmen. Ich habe mich gefragt, denn es gab sehr viele Berichte dann doch jetzt darüber, warum OnlyFans, also diese Erotikplattform, so einen enormen Anstieg erlebt hat. Ganz viele sind nicht nur dort Kunden jetzt, sondern sind dort auch Ausführende, also bieten erotische, pornografische Inhalte an Gegengeld. Und die erste Antwort darauf, die ist sicherlich richtig, die lautet, da sind sehr viele Menschen, die brauchen gerade Geld und die haben ihre Jobs verloren und sagen dann gut, dann mache ich mich mal frei und verdiene da 1000, 1500 Euro im Monat. Vielmehr ist es ja nicht. Also das heißt, das ist ja keine Plattform, mit der jetzt ganz viele Menschen reich werden, sondern nur ganz wenige und der Rest bekommt halt paar hundert Euro. Ich glaube aber, es gibt noch eine zweite Antwort darauf. Ich glaube, es gibt und davon profitieren ja auch diese ganzen Webcam-Sex-Geschichten. Ich glaube, es gibt eine ganz, ganz große Einsamkeit, die durch Corona jetzt aufgetreten ist und diese tägliche Anerkennung, den vielleicht nicht täglichen, aber wöchentlichen Flirt, den Blickkontakt, den man hat, das Kompliment, das man erhält, die Anerkennung, die jetzt nicht da ist und die man sich dann über ein anonymes Publikum dort holt und kann dann zugleich noch ein paar hundert Euro verdienen.
Jeder von uns kennt die kleine Szenerie. Man ist irgendwie einkaufen, keine Ahnung. Und man wird von der Kassiererin angelächelt und man weiß, diesmal war es nicht dieses Flugbegleiter, unhöfliche, wir lächeln einfach alle an, sondern das war irgendwie ernst gemeint oder so. Das kann einen schon mal durch so einen Tag retten. Gerade in so, ja, es ist November. Also November ist eh immer so ein Monat, wo das Sorge-Telefon-Sturm klingelt. So und dass die Bundesregierung das jetzt macht, während sie selber komplett versagt in der Corona-Bekämpfung, also sowieso mit diesem Appell an uns Bürger herantritt, zu sagen, reduziert doch mal eure Kontakte, damit unsere Zahlen besser aussehen. Das scheint ja irgendwie so der Deal zu sein, der gerade versucht wird einzugehen. Und dass sie dann kommen, während sie immer die jungen Menschen übersehen und jetzt diese schlimmen Schicksale der jungen Jüngeren, nämlich einfach vom Computer zu versauern, plötzlich umdrehen, um also dieses Ideal einfach missbrauchen, also zu einem Ideal machen, sagen wir es mal so, dieses schlimme Schicksal, plötzlich zu einem Ideal hoch erklären. Nur weil, und da finde ich, ist einfach der Zweck, Corona-Bekämpfen zu gering, das geht einfach gar nicht. Nicht mal Corona wäre eine Rechtfertigung dafür, diese Art der Einsamkeit plötzlich zu heroisieren und so. Das fällt einem wirklich bösartig. Das ist ganz bösartige Propaganda, würde ich mal sagen.
Ja, man kann ja Werbung in dieser Richtung machen, aber dann muss man eigentlich jetzt den Spot machen, wie, wenn wir diesen Lockdown brauchen, kommen wir denn trotzdem durch die Zeit, ohne dass die Leute am Rad drehen, ohne dass sie nur noch auf der Couch letargeschlagen liegen. Ich finde, es ist eigentlich verantwortungslos, und dass das dann auch als so cool und hip von vielen dargestellt wird. Da waren ja dann auch entsprechende Leute bei Twitter zu erleben. Das finde ich schon sehr erstaunlich. Also ist man dann nur noch in so einer Marketing-Logik gefangen? Und vor allen Dingen, wenn man glaubt, dass dieser Spot eine Wirkung hat. Welche Ansicht hat man denn eigentlich von der Bevölkerung, wenn man meint, sie springt auf so einen Spot an? Das ist ja auch ein Demokratieverständnis, das doch einige Schwächen aufweist.
Ganz genau. Also hier wird Bevölkerung nur noch so als dumme Masse irgendwie angesprochen. So eine völlig falsche Motivation hintergelegt. Du hast es völlig richtig gesagt. Man muss das hier auch mal in einem Kontext jetzt einbetten. Und dieser Kontext kann nur die Realität sein. Und ja, wir schielen gerade alle auf diese Zahlen. Corona, Corona. Jeden Morgen holen wir uns unser persönliches Corona-Update, woher auch immer. Nur man könnte ja auch noch andere Daten erheben. Und das wurde hier mal gemacht. Das sind jetzt, das ist aus den Tagesthemen, also ganz aktuelle Nachrichten. 25.11. fünf Tage her, da wurden hier mal andere Zahlen präsentiert.
Unzufriedener. So fühlen sich laut einer Studie des Soziologen Martin Schröder viele im Vergleich zum Pandemieanfang. Er hat Daten des Universitätsklinikums Hamburg-Ettendorf ausgewertet. 150 Leute wurden seit dem Frühjahr alle zwei Wochen nach ihrer Lebenszufriedenheit befragt.
Und da zeigt sich eben nach dem ersten Lockdown, ging die Zufriedenheit erst mal hoch, so auf sieben und halb ungefähr von zehn Punkten. Und jetzt gab es einen doch recht massiven Absturz, muss man sagen, um fast einen Punkt. Es ist so der Effekt von, wie wenn man arbeitslos wird, sich trennt, sogar einen geliebten Menschen verliert. Also es ist schon ein sehr starker Effekt, muss man sagen.
Ja, die Negativ-Skala ist so ein bisschen schwer zu verstehen. Aber damals 2006, als es hieß, das hat die Leute so glücklich gemacht, eine Fußball-WM in Deutschland zu haben, als hätte man jedem 500 Euro geschenkt. Wir erleben gerade eine Anti-Fußball-Meldmeisterschaft im eigenen Lande, in dem wir vielleicht sogar noch Meister werden. Menschen erleben gerade flächendeckend einen emotionalen Einbruch, als hätten sie ihren Job verloren, als ginge ihre Beziehung kaputt. Und in diesen Momenten kann man nicht, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, selbst Corona reicht dafür nicht aus, kann man nicht die Einsamkeit, diese Weltflucht so idealisieren, sondern man muss ehrlich mit den Leuten kommunizieren und sagen, wir wissen, du bist einsam, Weltflucht ist was, aber wir müssen das jetzt durchstehen. Also das muss so ein Hoffnungshorizont irgendwie mit der Impfung, keine Ahnung, irgendwas, der nächste Sommer kommt wieder. Aber einfach nur das Negative, was hier so krass erlebt wird, von den Menschen, wie du das gerade beschrieben hast, das nochmal zu versuchen, zu idealisieren mit einem Werbeclip. Also ich kann mich nur darüber aufregen.
Ja, das ist auch dann aus der Feder von Menschen, die genau diese Kurve nicht erleben oder die auch offenbar blind sind und nicht erleben, dass andere diese Kurve dadurch machen, die beschrieben wurde. Das kann man wahrscheinlich dann wirklich nur, wenn man alle Tücher im Trockenen hat und wenn man weiterhin große Fernsehshows und alles Mögliche produzieren kann, dann fällt einem das auch nicht auf. Das ist immer so für jemanden, der sehr reich ist. Es ist auch überall auf der Welt sehr schön.
Genau. Und das können wir mal richtig sozusagen operationalisieren. Die Menschen, die diesen Clip gemacht haben, also Joko und Klaas und so die ganzen Leute, das sind Menschen, die sind auch jetzt weiter gefragt. Die kriegen die ganze Zeit diese E-Mails mit, willst du mal hier, willst du mal das, jetzt ist auch so viel Zeit und so weiter. Die erleben vielleicht sogar noch so eine Welt, in der sie jetzt selber Anfragen anstellen und dann immer die Antwort kommt, ja sofort, ich habe gerade eh nichts zu tun, es ist ja Corona. Also die erleben gerade so eine richtige Freiheit. Alle Menschen, mit denen sie zusammenarbeiten wollen, wollen mit ihnen arbeiten, haben die Zeit mit ihnen zu arbeiten, es ist gar nicht wenig zu planen und auf der anderen Seite, auf der Seite des Publikums, sitzen Menschen, die gerade gar keine Anfragen bekommen, die einfach nicht gefragt sind, die sich überflüssig fühlen, wie das Harari sagte, Joval Harari, das Schicksal des Menschen im 21. Jahrhundert ist, zu erkennen, er ist absolut überflüssig in dieser Welt, er wird nicht mal mehr als Konsument noch gebraucht, erst recht nicht als irgendein Produzent. Also die Zeiten sind eh vorbei, es wird alles Maschine oder irgendwer am Osten, jetzt wird man nicht mal mehr als Konsument noch gebraucht. Und da fand ich es sehr gut, sie haben mir bei den Tagesthemen mal wirklich in so ein Eheleben kurz reingeschaut. Das sind so seltene Einblicke, aber da kann man mal so ein bisschen erspüren, wie die Stimmungslage ist.
Weniger Leute sehen, keine Kontrolle über den Alltag zu haben, fordere viele seit Monaten heraus. Das kennt auch das Ehepaar Häusling. 15 Jahre leben sie zusammen, doch so lange am Stück haben sie sich noch nie gesehen. Anfangs ein Vorteil, mehr Zeit für ihre Kinder, mehr Zeit zu zweit, nun aber gelegentlich eine Last.
Klar ist es dann in Teilen konfliktbehaftet, weil wir uns anders abstimmen müssen als vorher. Verantwortlichkeiten verschwimmen oder der eine will sich zurückziehen, aber die Kinder sind auch zu Hause, wird gebraucht. Das ist emotional für alle Beteiligten deutlich anstrengender. Und das merken wir schon in unserem Ehealltag, dass das mehr Kraft kostet insgesamt.
Ich brauche jetzt auch nach dem Dreivierteljahr hier einfach mal einen Break ohne Kinder, ohne Mann. Ich war ganz alleine wandern und das hat mir jetzt persönlich extrem gut getan, um auch wieder ein bisschen aufzutanken.
Am liebsten soll auch hiermit Schluss sein, dem Homeoffice, in dem der Unternehmensberater fast ein halbes Jahr arbeitet.
Also es ist schon wahnsinnig anstrengender, viel anstrengender als vorher. Also es fehlt der Bewegungsrahmen, die Abwechslung, sondern es ist echt schon sehr stumpf einfach von der Arbeitsumgebung.
Ja, also er sitzt im Homeoffice seit einem Dreivierteljahr, macht Unternehmensberatung. Für mich ist es immer noch keine Ahnung, was ein Unternehmensberater macht. Man sieht ihn aber auf seinem Laptop rumtippen und weiß genau, der kriegt hier gar keine Anerkennung, null mehr. Das ist wirklich nur noch, hoffentlich wird die Rechnung rechtzeitig bezahlt oder sowas. Dann geht er rüber ins andere Zimmer, wo seine Frau am Küchentisch sitzt und ihm sagt, tut mir leid, aber ich muss jetzt mal Urlaub ohne dich machen, ich gehe jetzt mal wandern.
Man kann beide so gut verstehen.
Absolut, ja. Man kann beide noch so verstehen und es ist traurig, das so zu sehen. Und wenn die Bundesregierung da meint, sie muss hier mal so reinspringen mit irgendwie... Der Sozial-Logo meint dann noch, das Einzige, was hier gerade ein bisschen Stimmung aufhält, ist tatsächlich die Hoffnung auf Impfung. Ich habe das jetzt auch im Fernsehpodcast häufiger gesagt. Ich bin... also das mit dem Impfungsding, das kam jetzt fünf Tage nachdem Trump abgewählt war. Plötzlich hieß es, das werden wir im Salon jetzt ganz ausführlich besprechen, wie diese mRNA-Technologie funktioniert, mit der diese Impfung da funktioniert. Das ist wirklich unglaublich hoffnungsstiftend, als wäre hier so ein Regisseur aus Hollywood mit einem absolut fantastischen Film über Impftechnologien, er hätte plötzlich die Tür aufgemacht und gesagt, Leute, das ist nicht nur ein Film, das ist Realität. Also wir erleben hier wirklich ganz Erstaunliches. Ich finde, man sollte sich auch unbedingt mit dieser Technologie da mal auseinandersetzen, weil das wirklich hoffnungsstiftend ist. Nicht nur für Corona, sondern so insgesamt. Man kann dann einfach wahrscheinlich mit allen möglichen Kram irgendwie dann doch den Körper dazu bringen, eine eigene Immunantwort zu machen. Es ist eben nicht so dieses, du kriegst dann irgendwas reingeimpft, dann passiert irgendwas, sondern nein, dein Körper wird mit den minimalsten Invasionen provoziert, eine eigene Immunantwort zu finden. Und das ist immer das Beste, wenn der Körper das selber macht. Und genau so eine Technologie haben wir da jetzt sogar. Sie ist zweimal gelungen. Bis November war das noch völlig. Es ist sogar zwei Unternehmen gelungen, das genauso zu machen. In deren Sicht gibt es hier ganz viel Hoffnungspotenzial. Und die Bundesregierung sagt uns ja weiterhin immer, wir machen jetzt mal eine langfristige Strategie. Und das hieß dann aber nur, dass sie von Anfang November gesagt haben, okay, nächste Woche kommt eine langfristige Strategie. Sie reicht dann bis Weihnachten. Dass es dann immer noch drei Monate sind, bis Frühling, bis Impfung, keine Ahnung. Völlig ausgeblendet. Also in deren Sicht ist das hier wirklich ein Disconnect zwischen Publikum und Politik, das sie selten so erlebt in diesem November. Während noch keine kulturelle Reflektion dieses Ganzen überhaupt irgendwo stattfand. Wir sind völlig haltlos gerade, was das angeht. Und deswegen gibt es einen kleinen Ausweg. Und es ist natürlich das Podcast. Serdar Somuncu podcastet mit Florian Schröder. Die stehen beide viel auf der Bühne und quatschen sich irgendwie den Wolf. Und die treffen sich jetzt regelmäßig zusammen und reden einfach so über Sachen.
Und das hörst du?
Das höre ich, weil ich es sehr gut finde. Was? Serdar Somuncu finde ich gerade den Typen.
Hör ich wahnsinnig gern. Hat der nicht jetzt kürzlich so einen Unsinn verzapft in diesem Podcast?
Ja, er hat und ich erzähle es nur nach, aber ich empfehle es wirklich sehr, das nachzuhören. Nach zwei Stunden und zwei Minuten Podcast, in dem die beiden wirklich tiefschürfend über Sachen reden, die mich auch interessieren, wo es haltlos wird, wo es nicht um Inhalte geht, sondern auch mal so eine Gefühlsproduktion und so weiter, hat Florian Schröder versucht noch ein nächstes Thema aufzuwerfen, nämlich Political Correctness und Free Speech und so weiter. Und dann wollte Serdar Somuncu nicht einfach sagen, nö, da brauche ich jetzt keine Lust, sondern er hat genau das gemacht, was man nicht darf, um zu trickern, dass er das nicht will, gleichzeitig damit dieses Thema natürlich angestoßen. Wenn man das einfach rausisoliert, ist es einfach ein Arschloch, der Scheiße erzählt. Das ist klar. Wenn man das in diesem Kontext sieht, macht das absolut Sinn. Und ich möchte an dieser Stelle auch, ich weiß nicht, ob er zuhört, Serdar Somuncu gratulieren für diesen Mut, denn er wusste in diesem Moment, das geht jetzt schief und trotzdem hat er noch einen Satz und noch einen Satz und noch einen Satz nachgelegt und sich überlegt, wie auch der vierte beschissene Satz noch sein könnte und hat dann diese Schoße abgezogen. Und es war für mich eins der größten Podcastmomente 2020, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Ich habe auch erst im Nachhinein gehört, als es dann schon sozusagen die Welle machte.
Ich habe das nur in der Rezeption erfahren.
Ja, ja, na klar, wenn du das einfach so als Tweet nimmst und diese zwei Minuten, aber genau weil es so funktioniert, war es so gut. Es war ja am Ende so, dass Serdar Sabuncu dann auch eingesehen hat schon im Moment, wo er das alles sagte, aus der Summe muss ich jetzt irgendwie wieder raus. Und dann gibt es in der nächsten Ausgabe, die die beiden gemacht haben, so eine ganz süße, also wirklich süß, ich sage jetzt zu Serdar Sabuncu, er hat das ganz süß gemacht. Er hat eigentlich kein gutes Urteil, aber es war wirklich niedlich zu hören, wie er nicht versucht hat, sich kämpfen zu verteidigen, das war ja so und so gemeint und so, sondern er hat einfach die Leute damit allein gelassen. Mich, der ich absolut überzeugt war von diesem ganzen situativen Ausbruch, musste das nicht erklärt werden. Er hat es dann in seinem Rahmen irgendwie erzählt und er hat ganz niedliche Versuche gemacht, den Florian Schröder daraus zu isolieren, aus dieser Tat. Weil er saß ja mit in der Sendung und hat auch darüber gelacht. Und Florian Schröder musste sich dann erklären, warum er da gelacht hat und das falsch fand. Das hat natürlich negativen Auswurf auf Serdar Simuncu gehabt. Und er hat das ganz sportlich weggesteckt. Und das war nicht ein ganz großer Moment zwischen Männern auch. Also in der Ansicht, das ist eine ganz große Szenerie gewesen. Sollte man sich diese insgesamt vier Stunden, die man braucht, um diesen ganzen Kontext mitzunehmen, sich anhören. Wer nicht weiß, wovon wir reden, gerade ist egal. Für alle, die wissen, wovon wir reden, einfach nochmal diese zwei Podcastausgaben nehmen und hören. So, und damit sind wir bei Serdar Somuncu. Ich finde, er ist einer der besten sprechenden Denker gerade, der einfach immer schön am Punkt vorbei und so weiter und so fort. Der auch vorher sagte, er glaube, Trump gewinnt haushoch. In der Ansicht, also er schlägt über die Stränge und hat vielleicht nicht immer unrecht. Und er, wir hören das jetzt mal zwei Minuten 25, spiegelt so ein bisschen, die Bundesregierung hat uns jetzt ein Angebot gemacht, wir könnten ja einfach unser Faulsein idealisieren. Fühlen wir uns da nicht alle besser? Oder, und das wäre Serdar Somuncu's Angebot hier.
Ich glaube, es geht wirklich im Augenblick nicht nur um die Stabilität einer Nation, die sich zusammensetzt aus der Stabilität ihrer Bürger, sondern es geht auch um eine Stabilität unserer Gedanken. Und damit meine ich eben nicht dieses pro forma patente und diesen Selbstbetrug, wenn ich Dinge erkenne und einordne, dann habe ich eine Position, die mir Sicherheit gibt, sondern ich glaube, dass unsere Stabilität im Moment aus der Unsicherheit und aus der Ambivalenz entstehen muss und dass wir diese Unsicherheit und diese Ambivalenz, die Ungewissheit, nicht uns lehnen lassen dürfen, sondern dass wir versuchen müssen, sie auszutarieren und ein neues Gleichgewicht darin zu finden. Und ich komme jetzt noch mal auf die Kirche zu sprechen. Es geht auch um eine Moral. Es geht auch um eine Haltung, die etwas mit einer übergeordneten Erklärung für unser Menschsein in der Krise zu tun hat. Und da fehlt uns gerade tatsächlich auch eine moralische Instanz, die uns durch diesen Weg leitet. Und ich möchte nicht, dass das die Kirche ist. Ich habe das in unserem aller aller aller ersten Podcast mal gesagt. Wo ist eigentlich der Papst gerade? Weil ich mir insgeheim doch wünsche, dass es nicht die Kirche, aber irgendeine Instanz gibt, die das filtert, was gerade so ungefiltert in die Atmosphäre geschossen werden kann. Zum Beispiel, ich sage es mal noch banaler, irgendeine Instanz, die irgendwann sagt, so, jetzt schalten wir Donald Trump mal Twitter ab. Oder so, jetzt wird der Begriff Fake News mal festgelegt. Nein, es ist eben kein Fake News. Oder das, was in Amerika ja gerade auch exemplarisch stattfindet, innerhalb eines demokratischen Rahmens. Dass man sagt, du kannst noch so oft behaupten, dass die Wahl gefälscht war. Nein, sie ist nicht gefälscht. Wir haben die Stimmen noch mal gezählt. Wir haben die Wahl beobachtet. Es gibt internationale Stimmen, die sagen, das ist regelmäßig und jetzt ist Schluss. Also das wünsche ich mir so in meinem Inneren. Aber es gibt keine übergeordnete Instanz, an die ich mich damit richten kann, sondern ich merke, das muss ich für mich selbst entscheiden. Und deswegen ist mein Gefühl gerade, jetzt ist Schluss. Ich lasse mich nicht mehr beeinflussen von den ganzen Nachrichten, den Medien, den Rumors und den Leuten, die meinen, eine Meinung zu haben, sondern ich versuche, ein Gleichgewicht zu finden aus dem, was ich empfinde und dem, was ich wahrnehme. Und das ist im Augenblick, dass ich sehe, okay, es geht an die Grenze. Und wenn die Grenzen überschritten werden, muss ich gucken, wie ich damit besser zurechtkomme.
Also was ich da raushöre, und das erlebe ich an mir auch als großes Desiderat, ich würde gerne, wenn Trump versucht, hier nochmal ein Schnippchen zu schlagen und da nochmal und so, und Trump ist jetzt nur Schiffre, das gibt es jetzt auf ganz vielen Ebenen, dass ich dann einfach sagen kann, ich fühle, ich habe da jetzt keine Lust drauf. Nur weil es der mächtigste Mann der Welt ist, ich habe da keine Lust drauf. Und es fehlt die Instanz, die das mit so einer gewissen kollektiven Gravitation ausstattet, meine Unlust. Sondern wenn ich einfach sage, ich habe keine Lust auf Trump, kann jeder auf Twitter mal kommen und sagen, es ist mir egal, ob du da keine Lust drauf hast. Es ist der wichtigste Mann der Welt. Wir müssen uns jetzt damit befassen, auch wenn du keine Lust hast. Und da habe ich keine Lust drauf.
Aber die Möglichkeit wäre ja dann wieder die Eingliederung in eine solche Institution. Also du kannst ja zum Beispiel sagen, ich trete in die katholische Kirche ein oder bleibe drin, wie auch immer, und akzeptiere die Lehrmeinung dieser Institution. Und die kümmert sich ja auch um alles. Die will ja eigentlich nur, dass ich mich an gewisse Dinge halte. Aber die macht das ja auch, die bricht das ja für mich ja runter. Also ich muss mich mit Fragen des Kathischismus nicht auseinandersetzen. Ich bekomme ihn ja und kann mich daran halten. Und sonst studiere ich halt Theologie, wenn mich das jetzt weiter interessiert. Und das ist ja ein Angebot, das auch eine Ordnung im Leben stiftet. Und mit der kann man ja auch sehr gelassen leben. Und man wird auch sehr alt. Man kann das ja immer sehr schön sehen an diesen Studien, die in Klöstern gemacht werden. Diese Menschen werden in der Regel sehr alt. Und oft sind ihre Hirne befallen von Alzheimer. Aber es bricht gar nicht aus, weil sie in einem so strukturierten Tagesablauf sind, dass das gar nicht die Möglichkeit sich ergibt, dass es dort zu einem Ausbruch von starker Demenz kommen kann.
Das Problem ist nur, wenn du jetzt die Kirche auswählst, musst du daran glauben. Und die Kirche hat sich leider disqualifiziert. Und ich bin auch kein gläubiger Mensch. Und ich suche trotzdem so eine Instanz.
Gut, dann wird es relativ schwierig, würde ich sagen.
Paul Gäbler war auf diesen Querdenker-Demos und hat dort wirklich überzeugte Menschen getroffen. Und ich sehe das so und denke, ich bin neidisch. Ich wäre auch gern so überzeugt von irgendwas. Stattdessen sind wir in dieser haltlosen Welt. Ich habe zum Beispiel jetzt die letzten Monate immer wieder erlebt. Ich sage halt den Leuten, macht euch keine Sorgen, Trump kann diese Wahl nicht gewinnen. Wenn man jetzt wüsste, was der Zustand heute ist, hätte ich da noch dazusagen können. Trump wird diese Wahl nicht gewinnen. Es werden acht Millionen mehr Stimmen für Biden abgegeben als für Trump. Seid euch doch mal sicher, jetzt beginnt mit der Party und so weiter. Aber man ist halt trotzdem immer wieder an diese Realität gefesselt. Die Wahl steht noch aus und die Chancen bestehen eben, dass Trump tatsächlich gewinnt. Und die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist eben nie 100 Prozent. Und diese Corona-Leugner und diese ganzen Querdenker, die rennen halt einfach über die Straße und sagen, ja, der BER wurde gebaut, damit durch ein Tunnelsystem, die Leute aus dem Bundestag evakuiert werden können, bevor ich da mit der Mistgabel ankomme. Und sind absolut überzeugt davon. Und ich denke mir dann immer, ich bin neidisch. Ich wäre auch gern mal von so relevanten Sachen wirklich überzeugt. Aber man kann nicht überzeugt sein. Es ist diese stochastische Gesellschaft, über die wir schon sprachen.
Ja, und es ist der moderne Mensch, der sich nicht mehr der Institution unterwerfen will, der am Ende doch selbst zweifelt, der dann auch zu dem Schluss kommt, den S. Edda Sumuncu da äußert, ja, ich höre jetzt darauf auf mich selbst oder was ich auch fühle und versuche das so auszutarieren. Da muss man natürlich sagen, ja, aber ein Einfluss ist ja da. Also was ich als Medien rezipiere, all das prägt es ja. Also es gibt ja kein unverstelltes Sehen und es gibt auch keine Intuition, die einfach so da ist, sondern es gibt immer auch Beeinflussungen und auch Beeinflussung vom direkten Umfeld und von Lebenslagen, Tageslaune und all dem. Und ich glaube, was doch etwas sehr, sehr anstrengendes ist, und das habe ich jetzt in diesem Monat, glaube ich, so häufig wie noch nie bei Twitter gesehen. Ich kann das jetzt nicht mit einer Statistik belegen, aber ich kann sagen, das war jetzt meine persönliche Erfahrung bei Twitter. Noch nie haben sich so viele dort abgemeldet gerade oder gesagt, ich bin jetzt mal zwei Wochen raus, ich bin jetzt mal auf längere Zeit überhaupt nicht mehr bei Twitter, ich melde mich ganz ab. Also es gibt offenbar sehr viele Menschen, die darunter leiden, dass sie die ganze Zeit dort gesagt bekommen, interessiere dich jetzt für dies. Hier ist wieder ein neuer Trump-Tweet, da hat Rudy Giuliani das und das gemacht. Ich glaube, es ist dann doch auch an einem selbst das zu tun, da hat Somuncu sicherlich recht. Die Frage ist, ob man auch den Einfluss, den man ja in irgendeiner Weise ausgesetzt ist, also man ist auch einem ausgesetzt, wenn man spazieren geht, ob man den nicht verlagert auf Dinge, für die man vielleicht sonst keine Zeit oder Muße hatte. Also hier wäre ich nicht beim Nichtstun, sondern eigentlich bei der Muße und würde fragen, ob jetzt nicht doch vielleicht mal der 1500 Seiten Dostoevsky-Roman auf dem Tisch liegen sollte, dass man den liest. Denn das beruhigt auch, wenn man etwas liest aus dem 19. Jahrhundert und sieht, das ist schon eine Weile her und trotzdem noch unglaublich gut. Und auch da gab es Probleme. Also das, glaube ich, ist eigentlich eine ganz gute Einübung in Modernität, dass man sich auch immer wieder aus dieser hektischen Moderne herausnehmen kann.
Ja, also wir brauchen auf jeden Fall Strategien. Das haben wir jetzt festgestellt im November. Dieses ganze Achtsamkeitszeug ist schon mal ein Anfang. Den kann man entsprechend kritisieren. Aber da geht es schon mal irgendwie dann doch in so eine Richtung, wo man sagen kann, na gut, lass uns vielleicht mal probieren. Keine Ahnung, wir brauchen eine neue Körperlichkeit. Ich empfehle wirklich jedem einmal die Woche, auch wenn es jetzt gerade nicht geht, aber sich vorzunehmen für nächstes Jahr, einfach mal Yoga oder so zu machen. Das ist doch, ich habe es an mir selber jetzt erlebt. Es fehlt mir mittlerweile. Ich mache jetzt im November das erste Mal nach einem Monat keinen Yoga. Und trotzdem fehlt es mir schon. Und dieser Satz, ich habe keine Lust. Er ist einer der mächtigsten überhaupt. Wenn mir jemand zu irgendetwas, und es sind meine eigenen Kinder, ich schlage etwas vor, und die sagen, ich habe aber keine Lust, dann nehme ich das absolut ernst. Also dieser Satz, ich habe keine Lust, der ist nicht nur dahingesagt, sondern ich nehme den absolut ernst. Und dann ist entweder zu ergründen, woran das liegt, oder es ist einfach zu respektieren. Ich habe keine Lust, okay, Thema abgeschlossen. Du hast halt keine Lust. Dieser November erweckt schon so in eine oder andere Richtung.
Mich bringt das noch zu etwas anderem. Diese Frage, kann ich mich da einfach mal rausnehmen. Und als ich zum ersten Mal diesen Spot sah, der Bundesregierung, die diesen ersten mit mir gespielt haben, dachte ich gleich daran, dass man ja in der Philosophie, in der postmodernen Theorie in den letzten 20 Jahren doch sehr intensiv über das Nichtstun debattiert hat. Es gibt auch ein Band Theorien der Passivität von Kathrin Busch heißt sie, glaube ich. Sie hat dann auch nochmal einen sehr guten Essay dazu geschrieben. Und es ist aber auch ein internationales Thema. Alain Badiou, Giorgio Agamben, Slavoj Zizek, alle haben sich mit dem Thema Nichtstun auseinandergesetzt. Vor allem hat man sich an einer Figur einer literarischen aufgehalten, nämlich von Herman Melville Bartleby. Das ist einer, der arbeitet als Schreiber an der Wall Street und muss dort eben Büroarbeiten leisten und bekommt ständig Aufträge vom Vorgesetzten. Und was macht Bartleby? Er nimmt diese Aufträge nicht an. Er gehorcht nicht, sondern sagt, I would prefer not to. Also ich möchte lieber nicht. Und diese Formel, I would prefer not to, das war eine Formel, die wurde sehr wichtig, auch im Zuge der Finanzkrise, wo man sich fragte, wie kann denn eigentlich Protest aussehen? Ganz schnell ist man ja dabei, ja, dann mach doch mal konkrete Vorschläge. Sagt doch mal, wie wir es machen sollen. Und da wurde sehr empfohlen, geht mal in diese Battle-Be-Haltung, sagt mal, I would prefer not to, und schaut mal, welcher Bedeutungshorizont sich da eröffnet, welcher Möglichkeitshorizont und welche Möglichkeit sich dadurch eröffnet, dass man nicht gleich wieder so eingefangen wird. Ach ja, kommt hier mit an den runden Tisch und wir debattieren. Wir haben das ja schon gezeigt am Falle Luisa Neubauer und Greta Thunberg, wie leicht das gehen kann, dass die Mächtigen sagen, ja, kommt mal, wir reden. Und ich will einen Auszug mal gerade abspielen aus dem Buch zu Bartleby von Giorgio Agamben, dass wir ein bisschen eine Vorstellung von dem bekommen, was da so gedacht wurde. Bartleby stellt genau die Frage der Vorherrschaft des Willens über die Potenz neu. Wenn Gott, zumindest de potencia ordinata, wirklich nur das kann, was er will, kann Bartleby einzig ohne zu wollen. Er kann nur de potencia absoluta. Aber seine Potenz ist deshalb nicht wirkungslos, bleibt nicht inaktiv aus Mangel an Wille. Im Gegenteil, sie übertrifft in allem den Willen. Den Ausspruch Karl Valentins umwendend, mögen hätte ich schon wollen, aber dürfen habe ich mich nicht getraut, könnte man von ihm sagen, dass es ihm gelungen sei, zu können, ohne es absolut zu wollen. Daher der unerbittliche Charakter seines Ich möchte lieber nicht. Es geht nicht darum, dass er nicht abschreiben oder dass er das Büro nicht verlassen will. Er zieht es einfach vor, es nicht zu tun. Die Formel, so hartnäckig wiederholt, zerstört jede Möglichkeit, einen Bezug zwischen Können und Wollen herauszustellen. Zwischen Potencia absoluta und Potencia ordinata. Sie ist die Formel der Potenz.
Ja, sehr gut. Man kann da super tief einsteigen. Ein ganz großes Erweckungserlebnis von mir im Soziologie-Studium. Man muss ja irgendwann mal erklären, was studiert man da eigentlich? Und dann sagt man, naja, es ist nicht einfach nur eine Psychologie oder so. Eine aufsummierte Psychologie von irgendwas. Oder, und das ist eben ein ganz großer Punkt, keine Handlungstheorie. Die Soziologie befasst sich nicht damit, was Menschen tun. Weil, und das hat mich jetzt getriggert, weil, und das Luhmann-Argument ist wie folgt, weil das nichts tun, muss man ja irgendwie kategorisch fassen. Geht das denn eigentlich? Ein Handlungstheoretiker, also jemand, der sich vorstellt, die Gesellschaft besteht aus der Summe der Handlung der Menschen, die in dieser Gesellschaft teilnehmen. Und dann schaut man sich halt an, wie sie handeln. Und dann geht man aber als Forschen da mal rein, in so eine Familie, und sieht, der Vater sitzt irgendwie da. Alle trickern ihn mit, macht doch mal die Kinderbett fertig, räumt doch mal den Geschirrspiel aus, saugt doch mal den Boden. Aber er handelt ja gar nicht. Wie kriege ich denn das jetzt in meine Handlungstheorie rein? Soll ich jetzt die Duldung als die eigentlich maßgebliche Handlung in dieser Gesellschaft... Also zuerst sieht man, dass der Mann nicht handelt, und dann hört plötzlich die Frau auch auf zu handeln. Wie kriegt man das denn jetzt soziologisch zusammen? Und da war für mich klar, Handlungstheorie kannst du vergessen. Also damit kommst du einfach nicht weiter. Du brauchst ein anderes Paradigma. Deswegen Systemtheorie, wo es um was ganz anderes geht, nämlich um Kommunikation. Und da trifft dieser Watzlawsch, man kann nicht nicht kommunizieren und so. Das ist dann alles nur noch Deko für irgendwelche Leute, die das so pseudomäßig machen. Das ist nicht ausschlaggebend. Aber in dieser Handlungstheorie, also in dieser ganzen vulgärartigen, vulgärsoziologischen Betrachtung von irgendwas, haben wir jetzt ein Megaproblem, weil wir sehen hier Nichtstun. Und so wie wir das bei Agamben jetzt gehört haben, dieses Nichtstun, wie schon von mir eben zu sagen, also keine Lust ist eine der mächtigsten Sätze, also darum geht es. Es ist ihm nicht zu tun. Jeder kann als Arzt, geht mal raus und sagt, der hat aber super viel Sport gemacht, der ist super gesund, der hat viel getan für sich. Das ist ja schön und gut, aber man will ja dieses Nichtstun jetzt mal fassen. In deren Sicht, Agamben ist ja sowieso ein cooler Typ, aber solche Befassungen mit diesem Thema, die sind normal sehr gut. Jetzt hast du ihn noch als Zweiten. Ich bin ja nicht allzu viel von ihm, aber...
Du hältst nicht auf dich von ihm, aber er holt dich, glaube ich, hier ab. Nämlich, du hast ja gerade gesagt, dass eigentlich willst du dich da mal ausklinken. Du willst jetzt nicht den neuen Trump-Beat besprechen. Und das ist gar nicht so einfach. Und das sagt Slavoj Zizek hier auch. Nicht die Passivität stellt heute die Bedrohung dar. Es ist die Pseudoaktivität, dieser Drang, aktiv zu sein, teilzunehmen, mitzuhelfen, dass nichts all dessen, was vorgeht, zu maskieren. Die Leute intervenieren die ganze Zeit, tun was. Akademiker partizipieren an bedeutungslosen Debatten usw. Wirklich schwierig ist es, herauszutreten, sich zurückzuziehen. Diejenigen, die sich an der Macht befinden, bevorzugen oft die kritische Teilnahme, den Dialog und nicht das Schweigen. Man braucht uns nur in den Dialog einzubinden und sicherzustellen, dass unsere verdächtige Passivität gebrochen wird. Die Enthaltung der Wähler ist folglich ein wahrhaftiger Akt. Nachdrücklich rückt uns die Lehre der heutigen Demokratien vor Augen. Manchmal ist nichts zu tun, die äußerste Gewalt.
Also da muss ich jetzt an die alte Lehre der CSU denken. Wir wissen, die CSU ist ein großer politischer Ausbildungsbetrieb. Da muss man früh einsteigen, viel mitmachen, und dann darf man irgendwann mal irgendwo ein Büro leiten oder so. Und gerade für Frauen galt immer die Lehre, geh zu allen Ortstreffen hin, geh als letzter nach Hause und melde dich bei jedem Thema zu Wort, egal was ist. Also Pseudoaktivität, wie er das jetzt beschrieben hat. Und das gibt es ja recht viel, auch so in der Arbeitswelt. Der Idiot, der sich immer aufmeldet, die ganze Zeit, der immer Beiträge liefert, obwohl es schon keiner mehr hören kann, weil er einfach nur diesen tollen Moment mit dem Chef abfangen will oder so. So, und jetzt haben wir ja diese Szenerie, der Unternehmensbader sitzt zu Hause an seinem Laptop. Er ist vielleicht mal in einer Besprechung drin. Und da fällt es dann auf, wie nervig es ist. Wenn immer wieder sich irgendwer zum Mord meldet und die Videokonferenz noch mal ein bisschen länger zieht. Und ja, da fällt es dann richtig auf.
Die Kamera sieht ja auch alles. Das ist ja das Schlimme. Das wissen Leute nicht, die in der Regel nicht von einer Kamera sitzen. Die Kamera ist so unerbittlich. Sie filmt hier alles. Sie guckt einen ja nicht an, wie ein Mensch einen anguckt. Wenn ich vor dir stehe, dann blicke ich nicht die ganze Zeit so, dass ich unbestechlich bin, sondern ich konzentriere mich auf irgendwas und merke gar nicht, dass dir aber schon die Mundwinkel hängen. Die Kamera merkt alles.
Genau. Und man weiß nie, wer zuschaut in dem Moment gerade. Wo kommt man eigentlich gerade hin? Also in der Ansicht haben wir es, glaube ich, jetzt Aktivität, Pseudoaktivität, keine Aktivität. Und dann noch mal gedoppelt mit, hat man eigentlich Lust auf das, was man da tut oder nicht tut. Also da gibt es noch einiges neu zu justieren. Das haben wir, glaube ich, im November festgestellt, während wir, wie nochmal betont, keine Möglichkeiten haben, uns irgendwie abzulenken, außer mit Netflix oder sowas. Aber es gibt jetzt keine großen sozialen, komm, gehen wir mal dahin und lassen uns was erleben oder so. Viel alles aus deren Sicht ein ganz trauriger Monat, wo die Bundesregierung einfach noch mal ein trauriges I-Tüpfelchen draufgesetzt hat.
Wir widmen uns einem anderen Thema. Wir schauen über den großen Teich, gucken, was sich in Amerika tun könnte. Also wie würde die Außenpolitik von Joe Biden denn aussehen? Da wird selbstverständlich viel spekuliert und das können wir ja zunächst auch mal nur tun. Aber wir versuchen mal, das ein bisschen einzufangen. Wie wird das aussehen? Vor allem möchte ich jetzt den Fokus legen auf China, denn da ist das Verhältnis doch ganz interessant. Zumal es auch schon mal ein Treffen gab zwischen Biden und Xi im Jahr 2012. Aber wir hören jetzt noch einmal, weil es so schön ist, wir werden ihn ja dann bald nicht mehr so häufig hören, nochmal kurz Trump, ganz kurz, dass ich das noch einfügen darf. Was ich ein bisschen schade finde, dass ich Rudy Giuliani erst so spät für mich entdeckt habe. Also rein aus Entertainment-Gründen natürlich.
Aber der ist auch erst jetzt so geworden, wie er ist.
Jaja, jaja, also sehr interessant. Also da würde ich mir natürlich noch ein paar schöne Auftritte wünschen.
Leider alles mit Ablaufdatum versehen.
Ja, ja, aber jetzt nochmal ganz kurz Trump bei einem Wahlkampfauftritt.
China will own our country if he gets elected.
And you've seen the intelligence reports.
China very much wants Joe Biden to win.
Ja, so wie Usama Bin Laden auch.
Genau. Wie er darauf kommt, weiß ich nicht so genau, denn tatsächlich scheint es nicht so zu sein, dass China so unglaublich erpicht darauf ist, dass Joe Biden gewinnt, denn man weiß erst mal nicht so recht, wie mit einem neuen umzugehen ist. Bei Trump hat man ja das Poltern auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite, aber auch jemanden, der, du hast das ja auch im Salon mehrmals erzählt, wenn du die Bücher gelesen hast über Trump, sich für Menschenrechte oder so nicht groß interessiert und die dadurch auch gar nicht in die Bredouille bringt. Insofern ist es auch ein ganz angenehmer Partner wiederum. Klar, da gibt es immer Gefahren und Trump hat ja auch, das darf man nicht vergessen, mit Taiwan andere Kontakte gepflegt. Also es gab ja da gleich, als er gewählt wurde, diesen Anruf aus Taiwan, was ungewöhnlich ist, dass es so eine direkte Leitung mal gibt. Denn das gehört ja schon immer dazu. Also seit Nixon und Mao sich da verständigt haben, in der Öffnung, dass jetzt die USA nicht sagt, ja Taiwan ist eigenständig, hat mit euch gar nichts zu tun. Das heißt, diese Autonomie darf von den USA nicht zu stark forciert werden. Das ist quasi das Agreement, auf das man sich geeinigt hatte. Aber davon mal abgesehen, war man eigentlich mit Trump ganz zufrieden. Gut, wie wird das jetzt mit beiden sein? Hören wir erstmal Angela Merkel, die gratuliert Biden zur Wahl. Und hat da doch etwas sehr Erstaunliches schon zu sagen, wo sie doch eigentlich nur gratulieren will.
Wir Deutschen und wir Europäer wissen, dass wir in dieser Partnerschaft im 21. Jahrhundert mehr eigene Verantwortung übernehmen müssen. Amerika ist und bleibt unser wichtigster Verbündeter. Aber es erwartet von uns und zu Recht stärkere eigene Anstrengungen, um für unsere Sicherheit zu sorgen und für unsere Überzeugungen in der Welt einzutreten.
Ungewöhnlich, wenn man noch daran denkt. Gut, das war auch sehr ungewöhnlich, wie sie Trump damals gratuliert hat. Da hat sie ihm ja erst mal so einen kleinen Kurs gegeben, wie funktioniert Demokratie, was sind Menschenrechte und so weiter. Jetzt ist es aber schon sehr erstaunlich, dass sie so klar macht, also mehr Verantwortung. Das heißt ja, Mr. Biden, wir werden uns schon darum kümmern, dass wir zu dem 2-Prozent-Ziel der NATO kommen. Wir werden uns schon darum kümmern, dass wir ein bisschen mehr mitintervenieren, wenn es denn sein muss.
Ist aber auch so ein bisschen ambivalent, weil sie hätte auch Andeutung machen können im Sinne von mit der europäischen Verteidigungsgemeinschaft, das kriegen wir jetzt mal hin, denn wir wissen, diesen Auftrag hatten wir auch schon vorher, also mehr für die NATO zu bezahlen. Aber die Amerikaner haben ja auch Angst davor, dass zum Beispiel so eine Idee von Eurasien, das nähere Zusammenarbeit mit Russland und so weiter. In der Ansicht kann man glaube ich da immer gut teasen, wenn man aus europäischer Sicht sagt, ja ja, wir werden uns mehr um unsere Verteidigung kümmern, aber nicht nur finanziell, sondern auch organisationell. Also die OSZE oder wie heißt die, damals zum Kosovo-Krieg hat man ja dann doch versucht, auch mal so ein paar europäische Ideen, wo eben nicht die NATO und eben nicht Amerika am Drücker war, und man trotzdem eine Verteidigungsgemeinschaft von 500 Millionen Menschen hatte. Und da haben die Amerikaner Angst vor, weshalb dann plötzlich die NATO wieder so eine Konjunktur hatte. Und in deren Sicht wird sie es nicht so gemeint haben, aber da ist Potenzial, um Amerika auch ein bisschen zu verschrecken.
Sie versteht sich ja gut mit Macron. Allerdings in diesem Punkt sind sie sich ja sehr uneinig. Macron ist ja jemand, der schon seit eigentlich Amtsantritt möchte, dass die NATO weniger Einfluss hat und dass man etwas eigenständiges Europäisches aufbaut. Und er hat es jetzt auch noch mal pünktlich zu Bidens Wahlen, noch mal in Interviews mit Zeitungen und auch mit Sendern ganz deutlich gemacht, dass er das möchte. Und hier hat dann AKK, die ja Verteidigungsministerin noch immer ist, sich dann doch ganz deutlich gegen Macron positioniert.
Die Idee einer strategischen Autonomie Europas geht zu weit, wenn sie die Illusion nähert, wir könnten Sicherheit, Stabilität und Wohlstand in Europa ohne die NATO und ohne die USA gewährleisten. Und der wichtigste Verbündete in der Sicherheits- und Verteidigungspolitik waren und sind nach wie vor die Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika.
Sie hat da ganz konkret auf Macron geantwortet, der allerdings auch jetzt den November nutzt, um beispielsweise die ersten Steuerbescheide, hinsichtlich Digitalsteuer gegen Silicon-Valley-Unternehmen und so zuzustellen. Also die Trump hat da doch einiges eingerissen, was das französisch-amerikanische Verhältnis angeht.
Ja, vielleicht wird man am Ende doch sagen, aber das wird man erst, wenn zu spät sagen können, dass man doch diesem Macron-Idee ein bisschen stärker hätte auch in Deutschland diskutieren müssen, zumindest. Also ich bin ja bekanntermaßen kein Macron-Fan aufgrund seiner neoliberalen Reformen im Land, aber jetzt außenpolitisch betrachtet ist es vielleicht gar nicht dumm. Was ihm ja auch sehr angekreidet wird dann von deutscher Seite ist, dass er doch irgendwie versucht, weiterhin auf einen Dialog mit Putin zu bauen, weil er sagt, die sind halt ganz nah an uns dran, da können wir jetzt nicht eine harte Feindschaft zu aufbauen. Wir werden sehen. Es gab jedenfalls jetzt doch ein bisschen was dann zu Biden und seiner möglichen Militärpolitik und zwar in einem Beitrag von Monitor, der dann auch gleich sofort kritisiert wurde, das ist ja ja furchtbar anti-amerikanisch. Und ich habe erst die Kritik nur wahrgenommen, habe mir dann den Beitrag angesehen und dachte, naja, wenn das jetzt schon wieder als Anti-Amerikanismus dargestellt wird, dann ist das schon sehr eigenartig. Zumal man, glaube ich, mal etwas sagen muss, was Josef Früchtl, das ist ein Kulturtheoretiker, der hat sehr schöne Bücher über Filme geschrieben, einmal deutlich machte. Na ja, dieses Argument Anti-Amerikanismus, sagt er, ist immer so ein bisschen albern, denn wir sind quasi auch alle Amerikaner. Das heißt, wir sind auch alle jetzt der Westen. Das heißt, diese Kritik, die dann geübt wird an völkerrechtswidrigen Einsätzen und so weiter, ist auch immer eine Form der Selbstkritik. Wir können uns ja nicht vollkommen rausnehmen. Deswegen sollte man mal ein bisschen vorsichtig sein, dass man immer so tut, als gäbe es da nie eine wirkliche Vermischung. Aber die hat ja längst stattgefunden und wir sind in unseren Lebensstilen amerikanisiert. Er bezieht das dann auch auf Filmen. Wenn er die Ideologie in amerikanischen Filmen kritisiert, dann kritisiert er auch unsere Ideologie, weil wir die auch seit 70 Jahren sehen und übernommen haben. Aber wir hören mal in diesen Beitrag von Monitor rein, da werden mal ein bisschen die Verflechtungen aufgezeigt zwischen Biden und der Waffenlobby.
Und das sind einige von Bidens außenpolitischen Beratern, die demnächst hohe Positionen bekleiden könnten. Michelle Flournoy zum Beispiel. Ehemals hochrangige Mitarbeiterin des US-Verteidigungsministeriums unter Obama. Sie kritisierte den US-Truppenabzug in Afghanistan und forderte deutlich höhere Militärausgaben. Flournoy arbeitet heute für verschiedene Unternehmensberatungen, die offenbar über beste Kontakte zur Rüstungsindustrie verfügen. Unter anderem für Boos Alan Hamilton, die Militärs in Sachen neuer Technologien beraten. Flournoy ist außer der Mitbegründerin der Beratungsfirma WestExec Advisors gemeinsam mit Antony Blinken. Blinken ist der engste außenpolitische Berater von Joe Biden. Er war stellvertretender nationaler Sicherheitsberater unter Obama und befürwortete zum Beispiel die US-Unterstützung für die saudische Intervention im Jemen, einem Krieg, den die UN als größte humanitäre Krise unserer Zeit bezeichneten. Und 2017 schrieb er in der New York Times, es ist Zeit, die Ukraine zu bewaffnen. Die Kunden von Blinkens Beratungsfirma sind geheim, aber es gibt offenbar enge Kontakte zur Rüstungsindustrie. So ist Robert Work, ehemaliger stellvertretender Verteidigungsminister unter Obama, gleichzeitig im Vorstand von Raytheon, eine der größten Rüstungsfirmen der USA. Oder Nicholas Burns, seit letztem Jahr Berater von Joe Biden. Er war NATO-Botschafter und Unterstaatssekretär im Außenministerium unter George W. Bush und Befürworter des Irakkrieges. 2016 plädierte er für eine härtere Gangart in Syrien, denn Obama war viel zu vorsichtig und nicht bereit, den US-Führungsanspruch in Syrien zu beanspruchen, schrieb er. Burns arbeitet als leitender Berater für die Cohen Group, die sich ihrer Erfolge für Kunden im Rüstungsbereich rühmt. Oder Avril Haines. Sie ist laut US-Medienberichten seit Juni Beraterin von Joe Biden. Unter Obama war sie unter anderem stellvertretende CIA-Chefin. Sie gilt als eine der Architektinnen des Drohnenprogramms. Auch sie arbeitete nach ihrem Ausscheiden als Beraterin für WestExecAdvisors, der Firma von den anderen beiden Vertrauten.
Die Mannschaft wird wieder zusammengestellt.
Wie das, was du mit der Agrarlobby aufgezeigt hast. Da waren dann auch solche lustigen Verbindungen.
Das war ja auch so eine Diskussion 2016. Wenn Clinton gewählt wird, geht alles weiter wie bisher. Und wenn Trump, dann wird es ein bisschen anders. Und weiter wie bisher hieße eben, und da schließt man jetzt wahrscheinlich wieder an, im Frühjahr verkauft man so und so viele Tonnen Munitionen an Südkorea. Und dann macht man im Herbst das große Manöver und verballert das alles. Und dann wird im Frühjahr wieder gekauft für Milliarden und Milliarden. Das ist ja so diese Verteidigungsstrategie von Südkorea. Genau das Gleiche ist ja mit Skandinavien oben. Diese riesigen Manöver, die es ja mit der NATO in Polen gab und so weiter, sind ja alles diese Material schlachten, damit man da immer schön wieder Nachschub kaufen kann und so. Aber nachdem ich eine Frage auf Twitter bekam von einem Hörer, weil ich das letzte Mal wieder sagte, Trump bombardiert ja dreimal mehr in Afghanistan als Obama. Und Obama hat ja schon relativ viel Drogenkrieg gemacht. Habe ich nochmal nachgeschaut nach diesem Text und ich habe einen aktuelleren gefunden. Und der Faktor ist jetzt nicht mehr drei, sondern wenn man die Jahre 2015, also letztes Jahr Obama, mit 2016, letztes Jahr Obama mit 2020, letztes Jahr Trump, vergleicht hat Trump achtmal mehr Bomben in Afghanistan abwerfen lassen oder es geduldet, dass die Militärs meinten, wir müssten hier mal achtmal mehr. Faktor acht. Also es war eine riesige finanzielle Geldwäschemaschine da am Start, um den Amerikanern, also den Rüstungsindustrieen dort Steuergeld zuzuschieben, weil diese Munition muss ja halt gekauft werden und alles. Also in der Sicht, vielleicht ändert sich dann materiell gar nicht so viel, auch wenn man jetzt ein neues Personal da drin hat.
Ja, die Frage ist, wie wird sich das geostrategisch verändern? Wir hören ganz kurz in einen Vortrag rein von John P. Nielsen, der sich mit der Außenpolitik beschäftigt und einen Vortrag gehalten hat bei der Rosa-Luxemburg-Stiftung und aus einem ja anti-imperialen Impetus herausstricht.
Ob America First, wie Trump, der nur überall der Erste sein will, oder Biden, nämlich auf Französisch kann man das gut spielen. America First heißt avant, also sie sind die Ersten in der Reihe. Während Biden devant, sie wollen überall vorneweg der Führer sein beziehungsweise die Führungsmacht sein, dass wir hier es egal, wer an die Macht kommt, es mit einer Eskalation, der Konfrontation mit der Volksrepublik zu tun haben. Im Kontext einer nicht zuletzt durch die USA in einer generellen Militarisierung und Nationalismus ausartende internationale Situation geraten sind, wobei auch nicht zu vergessen ist, ich hatte auf Japan verwiesen, dass auch die NATO mit ihrem 2-Prozent-Ziel sicher in diese Kategorie gehört.
Man muss dazu sagen, auch China rüstet auf, selbstverständlich auf viel geringerem Niveau. Also man kann generell, egal mit welchem Konflikt, mit welchem Land man sich beschäftigt, nur von Aufrüstung lesen. Es fällt mir zumindest nichts ein und es gibt ja noch sehr viele Konfliktherde, die noch gar nicht so richtig zum Greifen da sind, aber die schon thematisiert werden. Zum Beispiel die Arktis wird ein sehr wichtiges Thema werden. Das hatte die Trump-Administration schon erkannt. China hat ja da auch angemeldet, ja wir sind ja so fast Nachbarn, so ungefähr haben die sich ausgedrückt. Da haben dann die Trump-Leute gesagt, ja was soll denn das sein? Entweder ist man Nachbar oder nicht, aber nur weil man tausend Kilometer nur weg ist, ist man nicht fast Nachbar. Also das wird generell zu beobachten sein. Also hier wird nochmal gesagt, naja das könnte so eine Eskalation gehen. Und da dachte ich mir, gehen wir doch einfach mal nochmal zurück ins Jahr 2012. Vizepräsident Xi damals noch, also er war noch nicht Präsident, ist in Washington zu Gast. Es gibt einen Empfang. Clinton spricht zuerst Hillary Clinton. Und dann ist Biden als Vizepräsident da. Und der macht dann auch erst einmal ein paar Witzchen, lockert das unglaublich auf. Und sagt dann auch noch, weil Henry Kissinger im Publikum sitzt, denn sie merken, das ist so meine Art von Diplomatie und alle lachen. Und dann kommt aber Biden auf den Wettbewerb zu sprechen mit China.
Und wie die Amerikaner, wir erinnern uns an die Wettbewerbe.
Und man weiß, mit dem möchte man jetzt nicht lange rumdiskutieren.
Hör mal zu, jetzt gehen wir gleich raus auf die Bühne, da machen wir eine tolle Show. Aber hier sagen wir uns ganz klar, die Augen jetzt, wir finden beide nicht, dass wir fair miteinander umgehen und deswegen, ja, Zwinker, Zwinker. Das so auf der Bühne zu sagen, ist natürlich schon mal ein Statement für Jahre, wenn nicht Jahrzehnte. Weil da steht man sich auch ein, da kann man jetzt erstmal wenig wieder hinbiegen. Wenn dann so ein Trumpel wie Trump ins Amt kommt, der kriegt es erst recht nicht hin. Und der geht dann halt mit offenem Visier da irgendwie rein und versucht da irgendwie durch Stürmerei oder so noch was hin zu biegen, was ihm natürlich nicht gelingt. Aber ja, die Stimmung war schlecht.
Jetzt, Thema Menschenrechte wird noch besser. Ja, das wird mal ganz klar gesagt. Und man sieht dann auch, dass sie immer noch lächelt. Aber die Stimmung ist wirklich dann auf dem Tiefpunkt angelangt. Und das ist so interessant, denn das ist so ein Empfang, bei dem dann immer ein Toast ausgesprochen wird. Dann wird wieder ein Glas Champagner gereicht. Also das ist eigentlich eine recht heitere Atmosphäre, die da aufkommen soll. Und man kann da auch noch erleben, wie Biden ganz anders agiert. Also das ist acht Jahre früher. Und acht Jahre sind doch viel Zeit. Der wirkt dort wesentlich jünger, ist sehr locker auch, in dem er das zum Teil vorträgt, also das Scherzhafte, aber auch dann sehr, sehr klar und bestimmend in den kritischen Punkten. Eigentlich recht beeindruckend, wie er das da macht. Und da ist er noch nicht geliftet.
Ja, also er ist super alt geworden jetzt. Ich habe mir auch nochmal Clips aus dem Clinton-Unterstützer-Wahlkampf, wo er noch viel Clinton-Wahlkampf gemacht hat, wo er noch auf der Bühne stand und rumgeschrien hat. Und wir und hier und wir hatten alle zusammen. Jetzt ist er wirklich Sleepy Joe. Und es ist auch eine gewisse Kraftanstrengung, solche Statements wie eben zu den Menschenrechten. Weil entweder hat man eine etwas weisere Weste als derjenige, dem man das gegenüber sagt. Oder man muss es halt so darstellen. Also es kostet dann noch Kraft. Und jetzt so nach Trump mit, was weiß ich, was alles an der Grenze gemacht wurde und die Kinder einsperren und Quantanamo ist immer noch offen und so weiter. Wird es so langsam auch für Amerika schwer, das darzustellen, dass man halt, also mit so einem Sleepy Joe wird es schwer.
Ja, jetzt macht er noch einen Witz, der es aber vielleicht auch in sich hat.
Land am wenigsten wichtig war, als ich das letzte Jahr in meinem Land war.
Ja, er hat das Buch von Henry Kissinger gelesen und naja, das war dann vielleicht doch auch genauso wichtig oder so wie sein Schott nach China. Und das Buch ist tatsächlich eines, das extrem einflussreich ist. Also dieses China Buch, ich habe das auch gelesen, wird sowohl von Anti-Imperialisten wie Imperialisten sehr gerne geschätzt. Denn was man sagen muss, also Kissinger stellt die Entwicklung Chinas sehr, sehr fair dar. Er stellt auch sehr fair dar, wie die Führung mit Widerständen umgegangen ist und so. Also man kann da nicht sagen, das ist jetzt ein durch und durch tendenziöses Buch, aber doch interessant ist, wie das Buch endet, das hier nochmal deutlich gemacht wird. Ja, wir müssen mal schauen, wie wir das jetzt so auf Dauer regeln. Sicherlich sieht er ein gutes Vorbild darin, wie dieses transatlantische Bündnis nach 45 entstanden ist. Das sei etwas, was anzustreben ist, was Kissinger aber dann nicht anspricht, aber was natürlich deutlich ist, das transatlantische Bündnis ist selbstverständlich so, dass dominierend das von der USA geführt wird und dass es nicht so ist, dass dort alle sich auf Augenhöhe begegnen. Und da lässt aber auch Kissinger eigentlich keinen Zweifel dran. Man wird nicht auf Augenhöhe mit China beziehungsweise wird nicht dulden, dass China über einem steht. Und da ist nochmal so ganz versteckt hier von beiden auch. Ich habe das Buch gelesen und ich weiß, dass ihr das auch gelesen hat. Denn Kissinger ist in China unglaublich populär und selbstverständlich haben alle Diplomaten das in China rezipiert. Um nochmal so deutlich zu machen, naja, der zeigt ja hier so am Ende ein paar Wege auf. Aber wir sind schon weiterhin hier die, die was ganz Wichtiges dazu beitragen.
Und dann müsst ihr mal gucken. 45, da wird auch ganz klaun erschienen zwischen Siegermacht und sozusagen. Und da sieht sich Amerika nicht nur in der Assistentenrolle, weil sie dann irgendwann nach Polarm eingegriffen haben, sondern da war ja dieses die Asymmetrie sozusagen geklärt.
Wir hören noch kurz rein in die Antwort von Xi.
Wir werden in der Lichtung des chinesischen Nationalkonditions konkrete und effektive Maßnahmen und Maßnahmen zu nehmen, um Soziale Gerechtigkeit, Gerechtigkeit und Harmonie zu erzielen und China's Grund für die Menschenrechte voranzukommen.
Ja, während sie gleichzeitig die Uiguren, die ersten Pläne für die Endlösung dort zusammengeschmiedet haben.
Sie sind bereit, in Dialog über die Menschenrechte zu treten, aber schon andeutend auf Augenhöhe, also auch zu sagen, was macht ihr da eigentlich? Du hast es gesagt, es ist dann nicht leichter jetzt unbedingt nach Trump dort wieder auch so eine moralische Instanz zu sein. Und die Lage der Uiguren, wir wissen auch einfach sehr wenig darüber, was dort eigentlich so genau vor sich geht. Also sicherlich gibt es ja auch ein Terrorismusproblem. Es gibt auch ein Problem generell mit einem Vielvölkerstaat, mit extremen widerstreitenden Interessen und auch einer wachsenden Ungleichheit, dass dadurch selbstverständlich die KP enorm unter Druck geraten ist. Also man wird sehen, wie sich das weiter zuspitzt oder was da eigentlich genau passiert. Also ob das nochmal das große außenpolitische Thema wird, die Uiguren, ob man es da schafft, auch nochmal ganz anderer Weise Informationen zu gewinnen, die man sicherlich braucht, um dort auch mehr Druck ausüben zu können. Das ist eigentlich noch sehr, sehr offen.
Oh, das ist halt einfach wirklich auch ein großes Experiment. Wie gehen eine Million Menschen damit um, wenn sie inhaftiert sind und interniert sind, und zwar ohne jetzt irgendwie Horizonte, die irgendwie sagen, dann ist es vorbei oder so, sondern es geht ja erstmal so alles als lebenslang. Und wie geht die internationale Gemeinschaft damit um? Und bisher hat ja der Westen da noch nicht irgendwie sein Unternehmen zurückgezogen oder so. Auch wenn jetzt die Ansage kam von Biden, alle amerikanischen Unternehmen sollen sich die Zulieferer aus China haben, nach Alternativen umsehen, also eine ganz pauschale Ansage, um dann auch sozusagen nach Indien oder so ausweichen zu können perspektivisch. Aber auch wenn wir nicht genau wissen, was da passiert, die Dimensionen sind klar. Also die Lager sind fotografiert, die sind abgemessen, wie viele Menschen da ungefähr drin sitzen, dass es in Millionen gemessen wird und so. Und so ein bisschen, wie das so funktioniert, dass die Wärter selbst, und das erinnert halt wirklich dann sehr an den Holocaust, wie die Wärter selbst rein motiviert werden, den Job, den sie da haben, ordentlich zu erfüllen.
Also der Unterschied ist natürlich, wir müssen hier schon mal klar rausarbeiten.
Es ist keine Vernichtungslager.
Keine industrielle Vernichtung.
Es ist keine Vernichtung von Menschen. Aber es ist eben diese Internierung, die absolut perspektivlos ist.
Etwas, was Agamben wieder stark machen würde, also dass das so ein Paradigma unserer Zeit ist, also die Lager, das Lager. Also er hat sich sehr mit Lagern beschäftigt. Er hat sich natürlich auch mit Auschwitz beschäftigt. Er hat da sehr interessante Essays drüber geschrieben, aber sagt generell diese Lager, dass man Menschen interniert, ob das jetzt durch in Formen der modernen Sklaverei ist, der Sweatshops, oder auch solche Formen der politischen Internierung, in denen Menschen quasi auf das nackte Leben reduziert sind. Und das hat immer so eine doppelte Bedeutung bei Agamben. Das ist eigentlich etwas, ich glaube, das ist so ein Paradigma, mit dem man ganz gut kommen kann. Denn ich glaube, es ist falsch, solche Vergleiche zu ziehen. Die leuchten natürlich als erste ein. Aber ich glaube, mit dieser Idee des Lagers und was das eigentlich bedeutet, und experimentierfällt es, glaube ich, sehr gut, dass man da sehr gut überlegen kann, was bedeutet das eigentlich dann auch für eine gesamte Gesellschaft, wenn solche Experimente durchgeführt werden, denn das ist ja auch wieder ein Spiegel der großen Gesellschaft, die draußen ist, die noch nicht involviert ist, die aber quasi gewisse Paradigmen dann übernehmen könnte. Es ist ja nicht da draußen sind die Freien und da sind die Eingesperrten. Also es wird dann auch irgendwann semipermeabel, was dann dort stattfindet. Das ist, also das bleibt sehr spannend, und wie man sich auch dazu dann verhalten soll, nicht nur, weil man industrielle Interessen hat, weiterhin in China präsent zu sein, sondern sicherlich auch, weil ein Konflikt äußerst ungemütlich wird. Wir haben es hier ja nicht mit einem Land zu tun wie Afghanistan, wo man sagen kann, gut, dann gehen wir jetzt mal da rein. Und das kriegt man irgendwie auch noch mal in den Griff. Das hat ja schon nicht so richtig geklappt, muss man sagen. Hier kann man sich ja vorstellen, was dann passiert. Deswegen habe ich mich gefragt, warum eigentlich so wenig jetzt, als man darüber spekulierte, wie wird dann das mit Biden aussehen, einfach sich mal angesehen hat, was Biden in, ich glaube, Foreign Policy veröffentlicht hat in der Zeitschrift für Geopolitik quasi der USA. Dort hat Biden ja einen Aufsatz geschrieben im März und hat dort gesagt, wie er die Außenpolitik doch auslegen möchte. Und ich habe einfach mal Passagen eingelesen und die erste hören wir jetzt mal an. Es ist der Zeitpunkt, die Stärke und die Kühnheit anzuzapfen, die uns in zwei Weltkriegen zum Sieg geführt hat und den eisernen Vorhang zum Einsturz gebracht hat. Der Triumph von Demokratie und Liberalismus über Faschismus und Autokratie hat die freie Welt geschaffen. Aber dieser Wettbewerb definiert nicht nur unsere Vergangenheit, er wird auch unsere Zukunft definieren.
Erinnert ein bisschen an die Poesie von Qi, die wir gerade gehört haben.
Ein bisschen, ja. Foreign Affairs heißt die Zeitung. Also hier auch nochmal diesen Rückbezug. Nach 45 wir als Weltmacht haben sehr viel geschafft. Wir haben erst einmal den Faschismus besiegt, dann haben wir mit 89 auch das Ende der kommunistischen Herrschaft. Wie geht es jetzt also weiter? Hören wir mal rein. Die Länder werden mit oder ohne die Vereinigten Staaten Handel treiben. Die Frage ist, wer schreibt die Regeln, die den Handel regeln? Wer wird dafür sorgen, dass sie die Arbeitnehmer, die Umwelt, die Transparenz und die Löhne der Mittelklasse schützen? Die Vereinigten Staaten, nicht China, sollten diese Bemühungen anführen. Als Präsident werde ich keine neuen Handelsabkommen abschließen, bevor wir nicht in die Amerikaner investiert und sie für den Erfolg in der Weltwirtschaft gerüstet haben. China stellt eine besondere Herausforderung dar. Ich habe viele Stunden mit seinen Führern verbracht und ich verstehe, womit wir es zu tun haben. China spielt das lange Spiel, in dem es seine globale Reichweite ausweitet, sein eigenes politisches Modell fördert und in die Technologien der Zukunft investiert.
Und das Defizit der Amerikaner ist so groß, wenn er jetzt klingt, als würde er ans Bildungssystem denken. Ja, also die Amerikaner.
Er spricht das auch an, also das ist so eine Idee, dass er sagt, gut, wir haben jetzt auch mal viel um eigene Land zu tun. Er beklagt sich am Anfang des Artikels ausführlich darüber, dass Trump eigentlich alles kaputt gemacht hat. Und jetzt muss man mal sehen. Und außerdem brauchen wir dringend mehr Bildung. Wir brauchen auch mehr Vertrauen wieder in die Demokratie. Da sei eben ganz, ganz viel verloren gegangen. Und auch ein Zusammenhalt, all das beschreibt er. Aber dann kommt dieser Blick nach außen. Und es ist natürlich sehr fraglich, wie viel man dann auch in der Kürze der Zeit schaffen kann. Was ich erstaunlich finde, ist, dass er hier nochmal sagt, wir werden hier kein neues Handelsabkommen machen, eh nicht wir hier als Amerikaner. Also da geht jetzt schon eine Weile das America First erst mal weiter. Also da wird es jetzt nicht gleich so sein, dass man wieder dort aufhört, dort anfängt, wo man mit Obama aufgehört hat. Und er verschärft aber nochmal seinen Blick hier auf China.
Ja, aber es ist halt wirklich kompliziert für Amerika. Das haben wir in Deutschland ja auch, so dieses ganze Ständige. Die einzige Ressource, die wir haben, ist unser Nachwuchs und sowas. Land der Ideen, Wissensgesellschaft, keine Ahnung. Und die Amerikaner haben sich ja nun wirklich darauf ausgeruht, dass die Exzellenz der amerikanischen Unis davon lebt, dass da Menschen aus Asien einfach kommen oder aus Indien. Ja und mittlerweile der Google-Chef ist ein Inder, der Microsoft-Chef ist ein Inder und weit und breit kein amerikanischer Nachwuchs. Man hat dann mal so Koryphäen irgendwie wie Elon Musk oder so, wo man aber auch sieht, naja, das kann man jetzt nicht über mehr Bildung reproduzieren, dieser Art, wie er das macht, sondern das ist schon irgendwie so eine eigene Klasse für sich. Und da ist man schon ganz schön aufgeschmissen, wenn man so wie Biden jetzt so eine Idee hat und zwar auch dann als 78-jähriger Präsident zu sagen, ja, dann gehen wir jetzt mal, investieren wir mal in was denn eigentlich. Also es ist wirklich, wirklich schwierig, diese Lage, die sie sich da gebracht haben.
Die Vereinigten Staaten müssen gegenüber China hart durchgreifen. Wenn es nach China geht, wird es die Vereinigten Staaten und amerikanische Unternehmen weiterhin ihrer Technologie und ihres geistigen Eigentums berauben. Es wird auch weiterhin Subventionen einsetzen, um seinen staatlichen Unternehmen einen unfairen Vorteil zu verschaffen. Und ihnen dabei helfen, die Technologien und Industrien der Zukunft zu dominieren. Der wirksamste Weg, dieser Herausforderung zu begegnen, besteht darin, eine geschlossene Front von Verbündeten und Partnern der USA aufzubauen, um Chinas missbräuchlichem Verhalten und Menschenrechtsverletzungen entgegenzutreten. Deutliche Worte. Das ist schon ziemlich drastisch formuliert, finde ich. Für jemanden, der jetzt weiß, ich werde bald Präsident, aber ich sage das schon mal so als gemeinsame Front, holt damit natürlich auch die Leute ins Boot, hier aus Europa, also vielleicht auch da, muss man dann noch mal die Rede in dem Kontext von sehen, diese Begrüßungsrede von Merkel.
Ich meine, ich habe mir das jetzt auch mal so, wenn man sich so überlegt, klar, man hat jetzt so auf vier Jahre Trump geschaut und fand, das war ein ganz schöner Idiot und der hat auch ganz schön viel Blödsinn gemacht. Nur, wenn man sich jetzt wirklich mal entscheiden müsste zwischen China und Amerika, nimmt man doch trotzdem weiter Amerika. Unabhängig davon, wie idiotisch dort Politik ist. So, und in deren Sicht haben die da schon noch so was auf, dass sie aufbauen können. Man weiß ja immer nicht so genau, wie ist das gemeint in Amerika. Also, wollen sie jetzt Verbündete oder nicht? Ja, auf die ganze Zeit sind sie auch der Suche nach Verbündeten, aber dann heißt es immer, ihr müsst schon irgendwie selber machen und so. Aber ich glaube, es besteht durchaus die Chance für ein anti-chinesisches, neues transatlantisches Bündnis irgendwie. Neujustiert, aber doch irgendwie jetzt nicht mal so sehr auf Zweiter Weltkrieg und Folgende, sondern dadurch, dass China halt so eine Gefahr ist, so eine autokratische Gefahr, die auch so ausstrahlt in der Welt, dass das so eine Gegenbewegung gibt, die dann dann doch wieder die Welt in Erste Welt, Zweite Welt, Dritte Welt einteilt.
Nur glaube ich halt, wird das nicht auf Dauer so gehen, dass man sich so auf Augenhöhe begegnet, aber in abgeschlossenen Märkten agiert und diese Vernetzung, die ist schon so stark. Guck doch, wie Europa gerade zerfällt. Wir haben ja nicht nur jetzt deutsche Industrie dort in China und die haben Interesse, aber Ungarn zum Beispiel, die sich ja auch gerade sehr widerspenstig zeigen in der EU. Ungarn hat großes Interesse, noch enger mit China zusammenzuarbeiten. Orban hat ja gesagt, ja, denn die sagen uns wenigstens nicht, was wir in unserem Land zu tun haben, wie wir mit unseren Minderheiten umgehen. Da mischen wir uns bei denen nicht ein und das machen wir auch hier nicht. Also etwas, was Xi in seinen Reden immer wieder deutlich macht. Also es ist eine anti-universalistische Politik, die dort verfahren wird, während sich Biden hier für einen Universalismus ausspricht. Wir können ihn jetzt als moralisch nicht besonders integer vielleicht hinstellen. Wir können sagen, da schwingt etwas Bigottes mit, denn eigentlich haben die ja auch und Guantanamo und und und. Aber man bezieht sich erst einmal auf diesen Universalismus und man kann ja erst einmal an diese universalistische Idee glauben oder daran festhalten. Das heißt ja nicht gleich, dass die Ausführenden auch gut sind. Ja, also wir können ja auch sagen, die christlichen Werte sind wichtig, aber die katholische Kirche hat da viel schief gemacht. Aber das macht nicht unbedingt die Werte falsch. Genau so ginge das auch beim Universalismus. Ich glaube, diese Universalismus, Anti-Universalismus-Diskussion, da kommen wir bestimmt noch mal zu. Wir hören mal noch was, was Biden noch mal so als kleine Aussicht uns bietet in seinem Text. Damit endet er nämlich. Putin will sich selbst und allen anderen, denen er es vorgaukeln kann, sagen, dass die liberale Idee veraltet sei. Aber er tut dies, weil er Angst vor ihrer Macht hat. Keine Armee auf der Erde kann es mit der Art und Weise aufnehmen, wie die elektrisierende Idee der Freiheit von Mensch zu Mensch ungehindert wandert, Grenzen übersprengt, Sprachen und Kulturen transcendiert und Gemeinschaften von ungewöhnlichen Bürgern zu Aktivisten und Organisationen und Change-Agents auflädt. Wir müssen uns diese Macht einmal mehr zunutze machen und die freie Welt mobilisieren, um die Herausforderung der heutigen Welt zu meistern. Es obliegt den Vereinigten Staaten, den Weg zu weisen. Keine andere Nation hat diese Fähigkeit. Keine andere Nation ist auf dieser Idee aufgebaut. Wir müssen für Freiheit und Demokratie eintreten, unsere Glaubwürdigkeit zurückgewinnen und mit unerbittlichem Optimismus und mit Entschlossenheit unserer Zukunft entgegensehen.
Ja, also es wird in den Zwanzigern, glaube ich, noch eine ganz tolle Propagandaschlacht. Ich sehe schon die ganzen Thinktanks, wie sie da sitzen und auf der Folie China so ein Gegenszenario entwickeln. Bisher hat sich nur Friedrich Merz mit irgendwelchen Lobhudeleien des Kapitalismus wieder in die Öffentlichkeit gewagt, aber ich glaube, da wird noch einiges kommen aus vielen Richtungen.
Ja, und wir haben hier diese Idee der Softpower noch mal ganz deutlich beschrieben. Also er sagt jetzt nicht, wir haben aber eine noch stärkere Armee. Das würde man ja eigentlich erwarten. Also Putin ist da und China und die haben alle Armeen. Und wir haben aber die stärkste Armee. Er sagt, nee, eure Armeen sind niemals so stark wie der Gedanke der Freiheit, der sich dann, und dann kommt das sehr blumig ausgedrückt, überall verteilt. Und das ist immer noch diese Hoffnung, die man ja hatte von 89 an. Die Menschen werden den Liberalismus wollen, weil er das Beste ist. Wir würden das wahrscheinlich auch jederzeit so unterschreiben. Zumindest würden wir nicht sagen, dass uns gerade irgendwo in irgendeinem Land eine Alternative als besser erscheint. Aber offenbar gibt es, und das ist sehr schwierig auszuhalten, finde ich auch, auch so kognitiv schwierig auszuhalten, Menschen, die offenbar diesen Liberalismus nicht als etwas ansehen, was unbedingt erstrebenswert ist, was sicherlich auch an materiellen Situationen liegen kann. Wer erst einmal sehen muss, dass überhaupt was verdient, denkt noch gar nicht über Freiheiten nach, über die wir nachdenken. Ich habe dann mal gehört in den Podcast von The Diplomat, das ist auch ein wichtiges Magazin zum Thema Außenpolitik, auch mit einem starken Fokus auf China. Und dort ist die Chefredakteurin Shannon Tietzi im Interview und die äußert sich mal dazu, wie das mit Biden weitergehen könnte.
Es ist unglaublich, unglaublich schwierig, für die USA eine Politik zu machen, die China verändern wird, wie es in den USA und Hongkong ansteht.
Die Herausforderung ist aber auch wahnsinnig, denn ich hab mich jetzt auch mal so gefragt, wenn jetzt im südchinesischen Meer und wir nennen es schon wieder südchinesisches Meer in diesem Wasser da, um Taiwan und so weiter da im Süden, wenn da irgendwas passiert, was könnte die Reaktion sein? Also jetzt so ein Krimm-Move irgendwie, nehmt sich da irgendwie eine Insel, keine Ahnung. Was soll denn die Antwort sein, dass dann irgendwie so ein Flugzeugträger von Amerika da hinfährt und wir so solidarisch irgendwie im Beifall spenden für diesen Moment? Oder es ist mir völlig schleierhaft, weil bei Hongkong sieht man ja, dass man im Grunde gar nichts machen kann. Außer appellieren irgendwie. Das Schlimmste, also Norbert Röttgen hat irgendwie angedroht, wir werden dann China isolieren, wenn das mit Hongkong so weitergeht.
Da möchte ich mal die deutsche Autoindustrie erleben. Oder was weiß ich, wer noch alles dran hängt, also doch so tun, als könnte man diese Märkte voneinander abschließen. Man könnte andererseits auch sagen, diese enge Verflechtung der Märkte ist wiederum gut, weil sie friedenssichernd sind. Solange ich noch geschäftliche Interessen habe, ist das immer besser. Dann bist du nicht der absolute Feind für mich. Und da, also da, das muss man jetzt auch so sehen, dass man da eigentlich vielleicht über diesen Weg keinen kulturellen Wandel hervor herbeiführt, wie man das ja oft glaubte, aber dass man zumindest eine Friedenssicherung so herstellt, weil es einen allgemeinen Wohlstand schafft, der vielleicht dann auch wieder zu anderem führen könnte. Ich finde das ganz gut, dass sie das hier anspricht, dass es diese beiden Seiten gibt. Einmal des Idealisten quasi, der sagt, hier damals 1989 auf dem Platz des himmlischen Friedens, was da geschehen ist, hat ja Dengen und hat die KP, ja dann das Militärbeauftragte einzuschreiten. Da gab es ja hunderte, tausende Tote bei den Protesten, bei den studentischen, dass er das verurteilt hat. Reagan war da ja schon sehr viel pragmatischer. Der hat gesagt, ja, irgendwie schlimm, wir müssen erst mal rausziehen. Aber eigentlich war er schon wieder zarte Bande am Knüpfen. Das beschreibt Kissinger auch so in seinem Buch. Und man hat halt das Geschäftsinteresse weiterhin im Auge gehabt. Dass man aber auf der anderen Seite auch den Pragmatiker hat, der natürlich weiß, dass das sehr, sehr schwierig ist. Und dass es auch ja darum geht, nicht die eigene Volkswirtschaft vor die Wand zu fahren. Denn das ist ja gar nicht möglich. Jetzt auch für Amerika, sich einfach mal von China los zu sagen, auch dass wir für sie volkswirtschaftlich ein Desaster, zumal wir ja nicht vergessen dürften, dass wir eigentlich so eine Nachfragestagnation haben. Wir kommen ja noch zum Thema Konsum. Seit den 70er Jahren, wenn Asien nicht wäre und der Aufstieg Asiens, dann wären unsere Börsenkurse und wäre unser Allgemeines wohl befinden, wo ganz anders. Ja, noch mal, Shenan Tizi, sie äußert sich jetzt zu Chinas Strategie, die sich jetzt durch Covid ein bisschen verändert hat. Und dass China schon sehr genau weiß, naja, wenn Biden da so eine Front bilden kann, da müssen wir doch mal zeigen, dass wir auch eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht sind.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, ob diese Form der Astrologie nämlich, wo fährt Bidens Team eigentlich zuerst hin und wen schicken sie wohin und so, was man da wieder rauslesen kann. Wann kommt der erste Besuch in Frankreich, in Deutschland und in England? Gibt es überhaupt einen in Russland?
Diese Wolf Warrior Strategie, vielleicht haben die manche noch nicht gehört, Wolf Warrior Diplomatie. Das bezieht sich ja auf chinesische Blockbuster. Hast du die gesehen? Du kennst so 80er Jahre Actionfilme, Red Dawn oder so. Die Russen kommen und die Amerikaner müssen jetzt auf dem eigenen Land sich verteidigen. So in diesem Hurra-Patriotismus sind auch die Wolf Warrior-Filme angelegt. Ich glaube, man kann sogar einen auf Netflix sehen. Oder man konnte ihn mal sehen. Bei Netflix gibt es ein paar Blockbuster. Ich kann das jedem empfehlen, mal da reinzuschauen. Das sind keine guten Filme, aber man bekommt dadurch auch einen ganz guten Eindruck darüber, wie Chinas Selbstverständnis sich verändert hat oder wie groß das Selbstbewusstsein ist. Auch in Bezug auf Taiwan. Damit würde ich diesen außenpolitischen Blog abschließen. Taiwan hat selbstverständlich auch Befürchtungen. Wird das durch Biden vielleicht sogar schlechter für Taiwan werden? Trump hatte ja, wie schon angedeutet, ganz gute Kontakte. Ich habe den Taiwan-Cast gehört von Mariano Glas und Klaus Badenhagen. Die hatten Reinhard Biedermann, einen Politologen zu Gast, der auch in Taiwan lebt. Der sagt jetzt noch mal was dazu, wie sich die militärische Kooperation zwischen den USA und Taiwan verändert hat. Das ist sehr erhellend, wie überhaupt die ganze Folge sehr erhellend ist.
Klaus war großer Aufwachung-Fan und hat jetzt auch Fernsehpodcast. Diesen Podcast, vielleicht sogar diesen Clip habe ich auch schon gespielt. Also diese Ausschnitte, wie Trump überraschenderweise mit Taiwan durch Glück oder wie auch immer können, dafür so ein paar Lächeln dort gesorgt hat. Also in deren Sicht auf jeden Fall eine Podcast-Empfehlung.
Militärpolitisch, sicherheitspolitisch glaube ich, wird er auch weiterhin mit Waffenexporten Taiwan sozusagen die Stange halten.
Die Waffenexporte nach Taiwan, da ist ja jetzt in den letzten ein, zwei Jahren das passiert, dass man eine Normalisierung nennt. Also vorher, auch unter Obama, auch zu Anfang der Trump-Administration war es noch Usos, dass man ganz lange nicht entschieden hat über diese Wunschliste, die Taiwan immer vorgelegt hat. Und dann irgendwann hat man das, was bis dahin so aufgelaufen war, so zu einem großen Paket gebündelt. Und dann hat man so alle zwei Jahre oder so einen großen Waffenverkauf angekündigt. Und das war natürlich immer eine super Gelegenheit für Peking, sich dann darüber aufzuregen und ein großes Thema daraus zu machen. Und jetzt ist man, was lange gefordert wurde auch, ist man dazu übergegangen zu so einer Case-by-Case-Entscheidung, dass also so Stückchenweise immer und immer wieder Teillieferungen von Waffensystemen bewilligt werden, dass man sich daran gewöhnt sozusagen. Und wenn China dann jedes Mal protestiert, dass einfach auch deutlich wird, was das für ein Ritual von Seiten Chinas ist und dass da eigentlich nichts Besonderes ist, was jetzt irgendwie den Status Quo verändert.
Was die Waffenlieferungen angeht, ja, unter Obama war das ja so, dass da glaube ich vor allem Ersatzteile und so weiter geliefert wurden, also Kleinteile. Dazu muss man natürlich auch wissen, dass der chinesische Militärhaushalt sich zwischen 2010 und 2018 um circa 80 Prozent gesteigert hat. Also das ist schon massiv. Und es ist nicht nur eine quantitative Erweiterung, sondern auch qualitativ. Also die Waffensysteme der Chinesen sind natürlich mittlerweile auch wesentlich besser. Das heißt, die Amerikaner unter Donald Trump, die haben jetzt die Strategie geändert und haben auch richtig hochwertige Waffensysteme Taiwan versprochen. Zum Beispiel die F-16 Fighter. Das ist die in der vierten Generation. Die werden nur ganz wenigen Ländern außerhalb der NATO zur Verfügung gestellt. Die können gleichzeitig zwei Ziele ansteuern zum Beispiel. Oder die neue Abraham Tanks. Die werden speziell für Taiwan gefertigt. Auch mobile Raketwerfer, Raketeneinheiten, die auch bis zu acht Kilometer weit schießen können. Auch gleichzeitig Ziele ansteuern können. Also wenn eine Invasion kommt von China, dann können die gleichzeitig auf die Truppen schießen. Aber auch Flugzeuge, wenn sie tief fliegen, gleichzeitig abschießen. Also das sind schon Waffensysteme, die glaube ich den Chinesen wirklich Probleme bereiten können.
Speziell Maßfertigung für die Inselverteidigung. Das ist dann natürlich nicht schlecht.
Ja, aber wir sehen auch, wie sehr dann dieser Konflikt auch schon zugespitzt ist, wenn sowas dann schon angeschafft wird. Also interessant das zu hören. Auch von Taiwan habe ich was erfahren, das mich dann auch nochmal sehr, sehr erschüttert hat. Das erzählt dann auch der Podcast Gast, dass in Taiwan man wieviel Tage Urlaub hat. Ja, man drückt das gar nicht in Tagen aus, sondern in Stunden. 26 Stunden.
Brutal, aber man will ja die wach bleiben. Vielleicht kann man diese Beziehung, die Amerika jetzt gerade mit China hat, und die gilt auch ein bisschen für Europa und Deutschland mit China, das ist schon Wirtschaftskrieg eigentlich, der da stattfindet. Da kommen schon viele Kriterien, also werden da positiv sozusagen, angehakt, wenn man mal so eine Liste durchgeht, was da eigentlich passiert. Und da Trump das nur ein bisschen auf die Vorderbühne gezerrt. Und die Ansagen, man möge doch seine Zulieferer in Indien suchen, die war ja schon recht deutlich. Und TikTok und so weiter, das hat auch bei Biden keinen guten Stand. Also da geht es in vielen Richtungen so weiter, wie es jetzt von Trump angeleiert wurde. Als kleinen Brückenschlag breibe ich auch noch mal kurz bei Amerika, denn mir fiel nur ein Clip auf, wo ich dachte, das ist ja schon unerhört so insgesamt. Am 13.11. war Maggie Haberman von der New York Times. Sie ist ja diejenige, die Trump am meisten auf den Sack gegangen ist mit ihrer Berichterstattung über das Weiße Haus. Also wann Trump sich darüber beschwerte, dass irgendwelche Leaks auftauchten und da wieder irgendwas rausgeplaudert wurde, steckt das eigentlich immer in Texten von Maggie Haberman. Deshalb wurde sie dann auch auf Twitter sehr gemobbt von dieser ganzen Base, die Trump da aufgebaut hat. Und sie hat jetzt am 13. eigentlich das Killer-Argument gebracht, warum Trump, also was unerhört ist, dass Trump diese Amtsübergabe nicht ordentlich eingefädelt hat und warum das so lang dauert. Naja, es ist eigentlich das Argument, was spätestens dann auch die Republikaner so ein bisschen zum Nachdenken brachte. Ich spiel's mal so ein bisschen kalt ab.
Michael, es gibt definitiv echte Sorgen, insbesondere in der Nationalsecurity-Bereichung, dass die Verlagerung in dieser Transition einen Impakt haben könnte. September 2001 verletzten Terroristen-Attacken erhielten. Und das ist der Art Lager, den Menschen hier beschäftigt sind. Diese Momente in Transitionen von einer Administration zu einer nächsten sind die zahlreichen Momente in der Geschichte des Landes, wo Verbrecher auf die Wege des Landes schützen. National Security-Fraktionen haben oft das gesagt. Das ist eine der Sorgen jetzt. Joe Biden hat selbst Konzerne ausgedrückt, aber es ist wahr, dass es unmöglich ist, was vermisst wird und was der potenzielle Preis für das Land ist.
Ja, also der 11. September 2001 ist passiert, weil neun Monate vorher die Wahl in Florida, ne doch elf Monate vorher, also im November und dann bis September, nicht ordentlich ausgezählt wurde und es einen Monat dauerte, bis das Supreme Court dann irgendwie mal sagt, ja jetzt haben wir hier mal einen Wahlsieger, jetzt sind die Zuständigkeiten geklärt und die Transition kann jetzt beginnen. Und das ist natürlich ein super hartes Argument, weil 11. September ist ja nun immer noch das Zugpferd in so allen möglichen Argumentationen. Wenn man irgendwann einmal als letzten Akt ins Geschichtsbuch einschreibt, und das können wir auch noch auf Trump zurückführen. Die Anschläge, was weiß ich, im März 2021 oder so gehen zurück auf die Unsicherheit. Da haben wir hier eine Chance genutzt.
Das ist etwas, was man nicht bedenkt. Wie wichtig diese Übergabe ist, dass eben nicht eine See des Vakants entsteht. Denn das ist immer eine Sicherheitslücke. Wir wissen ja immer nicht, was abgewehrt wurde. Also wir wissen ja ganz selten, erfahren wir davon, dieser Terroranschlag wurde gerade so abgewendet. Wir wissen nicht, was nicht stattfinden konnte, weil die Sicherheitslücken geschlossen wurden. Und das wirft nochmal einen sehr anderen Blick darauf. Und das zeigt sich dann auch, was da wohl im Hintergrund so gerade alles läuft. Also mit welchen Kämpfen da zu rechnen ist. Das ist ja jetzt nicht einfach nur Rudi Giuliani schimpft auf die Frankfurter Schule und glaubt, die haben die Wahl hier in die Wege geleitet. Das ist ja dieses Kultur-Maxismus-Argument. Und das ist nicht einfach nur so ein bisschen gescharrer um Posten und irgendwelche Abfindungen, sondern da geht es um ganz, ganz existenzielle nationale Interessen.
Ja, spätestens wenn sowas plötzlich in der New York Times publiziert wird, hast du dann drei Tage später Senatoren, der Republikaner, die dann auch schon mal den Journalisten sagen, ja, wenn Trump die Information nicht weitergeben will, ich bin ja in dem Ausschuss, dann mache ich das halt. Bevor die Trump-Administration da selber formal eine Transition einleitet. Da hat man dann schon gemerkt, dass es dann doch irgendwie bröckelt, weil das sind so Argumente, da kommt man nicht drum rum. Auch aus dieser Trump-Abwahl-Nachlese kann man sich ja fragen, wer hat jetzt eigentlich gewonnen? Joe Biden. Ok, was heißt das? Joe Biden ist jetzt nicht so ein progressiver junger Typ, den man ja, was weiß ich, in New York, AOC oder so. Es gibt ja so ein paar Kaliber, die jetzt doch mal ein bisschen frischen Wind reingebracht haben. Dazu gehört er nicht. Aber wie verhält er sich denn zu denen jetzt? Denn wir wissen ja, Amerika ist keine Rentnerrepublik. Also in Deutschland kann man das einfach unterdrücken. Wenn ihr irgendeine News oder irgendeine Idee habt, ja egal, muss man überhaupt nicht darauf reagieren. Das ist ja ein bisschen anders, wenn man für Wahlkämpfe Zugpferde braucht. Die Republikaner stehen unter Druck, weil sie gesehen haben, mit Trump mobilisieren wir vielleicht nicht mehr als die Gegenseite, aber immerhin 72 Millionen Wähler. Das ist ja schon mal viel. Mehr, als wir jedem anderen aus unseren Reihen zutrauen würden, weshalb wir uns Trump eigentlich warmhalten müssen. So und die Demokraten sehen halt auch, wer mobilisiert ihr eigentlich? Sind es die jungen Villen, sind es die alten Hasen? Und dann sieht man ja so ein bisschen, also beiden aus eigener Kraft hätte man das jetzt vielleicht nicht so getraut. So und da wurde AOC angerufen von The Daily am 16.11. Und ich war ein bisschen erschrocken, ehrlich gesagt, das zu hören. Wir machen es mal in drei Hopsern. Zum einen sie verteidigt hier nochmal den Kurs, nämlich auch mit einer etwas expliziten, progressiven Haltung in so einem Wahlkampf zu gehen, auch wenn das bedeutet, dass dann irgendwelche Amerikaner wirklich denken, die wollen die Polizei abschaffen oder sowas.
Jeder Kandidat, der mit Medicare for All in einem Zwingschachtal sitzte, war immer noch in der Green New Deal-Politik.
Ja, also ein bisschen schlecht zu verstehen, aber sie sagt, progressive politische Plattform zu schaffen ist gut für die Demokratische Partei. Sie hat die Wähler nicht verschreckt. Sie führt es dann später aus. Das Mobilisierungsdefizit, das man teilweise gesehen hat, geht auch darauf zurück, dass und dann zählt es richtig auf. Dieser und jener Kandidat hat nur so und so viel 1000 Dollar bei Facebook in Werbung investiert, statt 10.000 oder 100.000 oder so. Also sie sagt hier ganz klar, es gab ein Wahlkampfdefizit, aber es liegt nicht an den Inhalten. So und das ist jetzt für die Rentnerberblick entscheidend. Wie kann man das? Also kann man das aufschlüsseln? Es ist ein bisschen wie bei Corona. In welchen Altersklassen wirken denn progressive Inhalte und in welchen nicht? Und da gibt es hier eine ganz klare Linie, die sie da zieht.
Was wir in der demokratischen Primärität gesehen haben, war ein Wahlkandidat, der die Leute über diese Dinge wollen. Wenn du unter 45 Jahren bist, dann hast du die Zukunft der demokratischen Partie, die sie glaubt, ist, dass sie nicht der Wahlkandidat, der Biden-Nominiertum gemacht hat, sondern der Präsidenten, der Joe Biden, als Teil der Wahlkandidaten ist. Was sie zu Kollegen in der Haustunde, dem Senate und der Biden-Administration sagt, ist, dass man nicht nur über eine Seite des Korns denken kann sondern auch über eine Seite der Politik.
So, also progressive Politik, Studenten, Studentenkredite abschaffen, einfach mal pauschal, Polizei reformieren, funktioniert nur bei U45. Um aber eine Präsidentenzahl zu gewinnen, braucht man U45. Und da sieht man, wie zerrissen sie sind. Also da kann man einfach, da weiß man auch nicht so genau, da kann man nur sagen, aus deutscher Sicht Luxusprobleme in Amerika, weil sie haben noch so ein U45-Potenzial. Das fehlt ja in Deutschland komplett. Hier zählt nur, was U45 denkt. In deren Sicht ist der Wahlkampf ein bisschen einfacher. Allerdings fehlt das dann auch dazu, dass Olaf Scholz gegen Friedrich Merz Wahlkampf macht. Man weiß nicht genau, was gewinnt man jetzt, je nachdem. AOC kommt dann auch zum Ende mal zu sprechen auf den innerdemokratischen Kampf. Und das fand ich ehrlich gesagt erschreckend.
Ich weiß es nicht. Ich weiß es nicht, weil ich denke, dass viele dieser Entscheidungen aufgrund der hohen Partie des Progressiv-Lefts sind. Aber intern, in Bezug auf die interne Politik des Parteis, war es extrem hoffnungsvoll, gegen alles, was sogar progressive riecht. Die initiale Reaktion war mehr Hostilität. Es ist nicht gesund. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich in Politik sein will. In den ersten sechs Monaten von 2018 wusste ich nicht, ob ich dieses Jahr für die Rehlection gehen werde.
Sie wollte aufgeben.
Das ist Wahnsinn. Und du weißt, wer das ja schon geschrieben hat, was da eigentlich passiert ist. Es gab doch die, ich weiß nicht mehr den Namen. Diesen sehr konservativen, stockkonservativen New York Times Kolumnist, den hatte ich im Salon besprochen und der den eigentlich sagte ja, send das AOC, ihr habt verloren und und ihr werdet sicherlich sagen, dass es jetzt so ein alter Boomer, der das schreibt, wenn ihr das lest, der der irgendwie an einer alt-linken Fantasie dann noch festhält, obwohl er selbst auf der ganz anderen Seite steht. Aber wenn man sich diesen Text, glaube ich, noch mal vergegenwärtigt, wird man das hier deutlich sehen. Also wir können uns da jetzt ein bisschen ausmalen, wie katastrophal offenbar die Lage bei den Demokraten ist, wenn jemand wie AOC überlegt hat, aufzugeben. Ernsthaft.
Ich meine, AOC hat damals in New York völlig überraschend diese Vorwahlen gewonnen, danach war so ein bisschen klar, sie wird jetzt die Kongressabgeordnete. Und damit ist man eigentlich durch soweit. Das kann man dann sein Leben lang bleiben, wenn man will. Denn so ein jemand, der dich da aus dem Amt schmeißen will, der muss erstmal in einem Wahlkampf so viel Aufmerksamkeit erringen und AOC steht nun wirklich mitten in der Medienwelt.
So.
Und wenn selbst sie sagt, und wir wissen nicht, wie instrumentell das hier ist, von ihr gemeint, ne, also klar, das wirkt jetzt auch sozusagen entsprechend, wie sie es so sagt, aber es muss ja trotzdem im Kern dabei sein, sonst würde sie es nicht so sagen. Und das gibt einen schon zu denken und das ist auch in deutschen Parteien so. Also wenn die Jusos ihren Kongress machen und sich da mit Olaf Scholz rumschlagen müssen, klar, da sitzt dann der Kühner auch in den Abendnachrichten und sagt, ja ja, das ist doch hier ganz toll, wir haben jetzt endlich einen Kandidaten und so, aber da kocht dann auch intern die Suppe so ein bisschen über, wenn man sich das mal so anhört. Na ja, gruselig, gruselig, gruselig. Ich wollte jetzt als nächstes kurz was zur Schule sagen und dann ganz viel zum Silicon Valley. Willst du zwischendurch noch? Gut, wir hatten ja Corona hier kurz thematisiert unter der Maxime. Beim letzten Mal war noch so ein bisschen hypothetisch, zugegebenermaßen, aber mit der Schulöffnung nach den Herbstferien wurde eigentlich eingedämmt, was in den Herbstferien durch das Reise, durch die deutsche Reisetätigkeit ausgelöst wurde. Ich hatte ja kurz die Merkel, die war ja da sehr restriktiv, die hat ja von dem Beherbergungsverbot, also war ja ihre Idee und sie war ja ganz unglücklich nach dieser ersten Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz, weil sie dieses Beherbergungsverbot nicht weiter durchdrücken konnte. Da hat sich also die Rentnerpublik durchgesetzt, die dann doch noch mal nach Sylt fahren wollte und so weiter und so fort. So und meine These war ja dann, naja zum Glück sind die Schulen dann offen, weil dann hat man die Kinder im kontrollierten Rahmen und ich habe im Fernsehpodcast mit Thomas auch noch mal drüber gesprochen, unserem Lehrer, der da auch noch mal meinte, wenn man Schüler vormittags im kontrollierten Corona-Umfeld hat, nachmittags sind die platt, da lernt die noch mal für ihr Skram, aber da ist dann nichts groß mit Party und so weiter. Das sollte man denen mal gar nicht unterstellen und stellt sich raus, hier im Deutschlandfunk Politikpodcast, also nicht im Radio, hat man wie folgt kurz über so eine große Studie zum Thema Schulen gesprochen.
Das Problem ist so ein bisschen, dass das ja ein bewegliches Ziel ist. Die meisten Studien, die es zu dem Thema gibt, die sind im Grunde in der ersten Jahreshälfte gelaufen, international auch und da waren die Schulen meistens zu. Das heißt, die Daten lassen sich nur sehr begrenzt auf die aktuelle Situation beziehen. Es gibt einige kleinere Studien hier. Aus Deutschland haben zum Beispiel Ökonomen sich angeschaut, wie war es denn mit dem Ende der Sommerferien, das ist ja bei den verschiedenen Bundesländern zu unterschiedlichen Zeitpunkten gewesen, ist dann danach jeweils die Infektionswelle weitergelaufen? Ne, das hat sich gezeigt, die Öffnung der Schulen hatte also keinen Einfluss auf das allgemeine Infektionsgeschehen. Das passt auch ganz gut zu einer internationalen Studie, die haben 191 Länder verglichen und auch da keinen Zusammenhang zwischen der Epidemie und dem Schließen und Wiederöffnen von Schulen gesehen.
War es nicht sogar so, dass die Schulen, das Ende der Ferien, also die Öffnungen der Schulen, das Infektionsgeschehen sogar eher etwas verlangsamt haben in dieser Studie?
Ja, das habe ich jetzt unter den Tisch fallen lassen. Das stimmt. Das war in dieser Studie tatsächlich so, dass mit dem Öffnen der Schulen das ein bisschen zurückging, aber der Effekt war jetzt nicht so groß, dass man wirklich sagen kann, okay, das ist jetzt statistisch so gesichert, da wollen wir unser Vertrauen reinsetzen.
Ja, er wollte es unter den Tisch fallen lassen, aber ich finde es doch eine ganz relevante Information, oder? 191 Länder, man guckt sich die ganzen Schulsituationen mal an. Man vermutet eigentlich, wie bei Grippe, jetzt geht die große Welle los, da werden die leichten Grippe-Viren-Erkrankungen durchgeschleppt und dann bei den alten schlagen sich nieder, stellt sich raus. Nö, man könnte sogar argumentieren, wenn auch nicht jetzt mit super Ausprägung in den Skalen, aber dass tatsächlich die Schulöffnung, also der kontrollierte Rahmen, dazu führt, dass es zu weniger Corona-Infektionen insgesamt kommt.
Was ja vollkommen klar ist, wenn man bedenkt, dass in den meisten Schulen man ein zwar nicht ausgearbeitetes Sicherheitskonzept hat, insofern als man eben keine Luftreiniger gekauft hat, das wäre ja sinnvoll gewesen, aber dennoch mit Masken, mit Abstand und sogenanntem Hybridunterricht dafür sorgt, dass man das zumindest nicht in den Klassenräumen entstehen lässt. Es gibt ja dann auch doch einige Kommunen, die extra Busse zur Verfügung gestellt haben, dass die nicht so dicht auf dicht dort alle zusammen sind. Und dann ist ja klar, dass in der Freizeit man sich nochmal anders verhält, auch da die Psychologie nochmal eine andere ist, dass man sagt, naja, wir kennen uns ja, da kann ja eigentlich nichts sein. Das erlebt man auch immer so bei Nachbarn, die sich dann doch sehr dicht unterhalten und sagen, naja, die kennen uns ja schon so lang, als hätte das irgendeinen Interesse für das Virus oder als wäre das Virus daran, würde dann sagen, ach so, die kennen sich ja, da komme ich jetzt aber nicht hin. Aber das ist doch sehr, sehr erstaunlich. Und jetzt hat man ja eigentlich, wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe, doch die Weihnachtsferien sogar noch etwas vorgezogen. Also man hat mehr Ferien. Ja, man hat noch ein paar mehr Ferien. Und danach wird das eben sehr stark explodieren. Davon ist ja fest auszugehen.
Ja, Weihnachten wird eine Katastrophe. Ich weiß nicht genau, warum die Politiker schon wieder das nicht ordentlich antizipieren können, sondern jetzt so im Hintergrund dieses Weihnachten ist so wichtig und so weiter. Weil was soll das werden im Januar? Wenn allen jetzt gesagt wird, dann könnt ihr ruhig rumreißen bei einer Grundinzidenz von 200 in Deutschland. Also ich verstehe das auch nicht. Da müsste man jetzt wirklich mal hart sein und sagen, Weihnachten bitte zu Hause. Ja, wir schenken jedem eine Webcam, dann könnte das irgendwie am Fernseher euch begegnen. Aber jetzt Weihnachtsbesuche, wo gerade zu Weihnachten so viel intergenerationaler Kontakte ansonsten nicht stattfindet. Ich frage mich auch, was das ist.
Gestern telefonierte ich mit einem Freund, der es offenbar auch noch nicht begriffen hat. Vielleicht hört er jetzt zu, dann kriegt er das hier nochmal erklärt. Mit dem telefonierte ich und er sagte, ja, Weihnachten machen wir recht wenig. Wir gehen dann zur Mutter und zum Stiefvater. Und so wurde das ein bisschen geschildert, heilig Abend. Aber dann am ersten Weihnachtstag geht man zum Onkel. Der Onkel ist 78 und ist so froh, dass die Zehn-Personen-Regel ja nicht für Kinder gilt. Und so könnten sie ja dann mit 16 Leuten dort feiern, weil die Kinder seien alle unter 14. Und wo ich denke, naja, ich mach das ja nicht vielleicht, um die Bundesregierung froh zu machen, sondern aus Vernunftsgründen. Vermutlich wird die Polizei nicht kommen, wenn ich mich mit elf Leuten treffen würde. Aber sinnvoll ist es nicht.
Ja, also der Erfolg in den Schulen, das wird dann für das Private nicht gelten. Der Erfolg in den Schulen sind die Masken im Unterricht und überall. In den weiterführenden Schulen seit den Sommerferien. Meine Tochter, neu in der fünften Klasse, die hat ihre Lehrerin erst zweimal für eine halbe Minute ohne Maske gesehen. In diesen Monaten. So streng ist das da, immer Masken auf. In der Grundschule gab es jetzt ein Corona-Fall bei uns in der Klasse, zweite Klasse, was hieß zuerst, am Mittwoch ist eigentlich ganz witzig, am Mittwoch wurde die Cluster-Strategie letzte Woche entschieden bei der Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und die heißt, wenn ein positiver Fall ist, kommt die ganze Klasse sofort in Quarantäne, wird dann fünf Tage später freigetestet. Es ist Donnerstag, wir hören, 23 Uhr kommt die Mail, WhatsApp und so weiter. Corona-Fall, positiv in der Klasse, alle ganz schockiert und so. Was heißt das jetzt, Klasse-Strategie, Kinder für zwei Wochen zu Hause? Kind war einen Tag zu Hause, dann schon wieder in der Schule. Also Mittwochabend haben wir es bekommen, Donnerstag waren die zu Hause alle, am Freitag waren die schon wieder in der Schule, allerdings in der Grundschule mit Maskenpflicht. Stellt sich raus, selbst die engsten Freunde, mit denen das Kind noch privat Zeit verbringt, negativ getestet. Die haben also nicht auf das Screening warten müssen, fünf Tage, sondern die wurden gleich mal getestet. Negativ getestet. Wer hat sich infiziert? Die Eltern der beiden Kinder. Also wirklich, wie man es erwartet hat, nach dem, was man über Corona jetzt gehört hat, die Kinder spielen zusammen, haben Unterricht zusammen, haben in der zweiten Klasse bisher keine Masken aufgehabt, keine Infektionen weitergegeben. Die Eltern, die sich das Kind im Sinne von, ich hole es dann 18 Uhr ab, und diese zehn Minuten reichen dann für so eine ordentliche Infektion in Untererwachsenen. Also in deren Sicht hat Corona hier jetzt auch mal im Nahfeld uns gezeigt, was es so bedeutet. Und die Grundschüler, die zweiten Klassen, tragen jetzt Masken. Und man fragt die Kinder, ob sie das stört, und sie sagen nein. Wir hatten heute den ersten Tag mal so richtig Frost, als meine Tochter gleich mit der Maske aus dem Haus gegangen, weil das auch wärmt.
Ist ja schön warm, ja.
Genau, also in der Ansicht keine Angst vor Masken, einfach Maske auf, fertig. Es sind aber die Masken, und wenn der Großvater dann mit seinen elf Enkeln zusammensitzt, da werden die keine Masken aufhaben. Hoffen wir, dass Corona...
Denn wir kennen uns ja.
Genau, wir kennen uns ja. Wir können uns hier nicht mit Masken suchen. Hoffen wir, dass das Corona gut meint und die Kleinen tatsächlich nur immer so wenig ausatmen und wie auch immer, dass das irgendwie hinhaut. Die atmen ja dann noch nur auf Bauchhöhe und nicht, außer wenn sie mit am Tisch sitzen. In deren Sicht viel Glück, alle zusammen zu Weihnachten. Wir machen solche Späße nicht in der Familie. Also wir sind da ganz... Unglaublich ist das alles. Naja. Silicon-Valley, wir machen einen kleinen Themenabriss, denn es hat sich einiges aufgesammelt hier im November. Da war ganz schön was los, beispielsweise weil man festgestellt hat, Scheiße, wir dachten wir, aber nee, wir haben die Wahl gewonnen. Wir Republikaner müssen jetzt auch anders mit dem Silicon-Valley umgehen, zum Einstieg allerdings. Ein kleines Thema, denn Apple, ich guck grad mal nach, ist derzeit, also jetzt wo wir das aufnehmen, hier am 30. November 1, 98 Billionen Dollar wert. Sie sind also, sie haben diesen Höchstwert damals da erreicht vor einem Monat oder so, oder zweien, und sind da jetzt einfach, neben September, und sind da jetzt einfach auf diesem Niveau geblieben. Und wir wissen noch, 2007 war Apple auch schon so eine heiße Marke, hatte seine Fans, haben sie das iPhone vorgestellt, und plötzlich ist das Unternehmen um den Faktor 10 explodiert, hat nur noch iPhones hergestellt. Und damals wurde ein Grundstein gelegt, nämlich ein Gerät so in sich selbst integriert zu schaffen, so selber zu bauen, dass man fast nicht mehr abhängig ist von außen, außer man sagt jetzt so beim Display oder so, kauft man zu, könnte man aber auch selbst. Display ist jetzt nicht die Raketentechnologie, der Chip aber schon. Und das war Apple ganz wichtig, dass man von Anfang an diesen eigenen Chip entwickelt. Apple hat also jetzt 14 Jahre Erfahrung mit eigenen Computerchips, die tatsächlich das ganze Gerät antreiben und nicht nur so nebenbei nochmal irgendwas machen. Und diesen Erfolgsweg haben sie jetzt auf den eigenen Computer, auf ihrem MacBook umgelegt. Sie haben also jetzt die allererste Mal einen eigenen Chip, einen eigenen Mikroprozessor hergestellt, designt ins MacBook, reingepflanzt. Ich würde jetzt nicht alle sagen, dass M1 der erste Chip ist, aber es beruht eben auf dieser 14-jährigen Erfahrung mit iPhones und iPads und so. Und wir müssen keine Clips dazu hören, denn sie waren außer sich die Rezensenten dieser Technologie. Ich habe das selten so erlebt. Ich habe gedacht, das hat sich jetzt mal so ein bisschen entspannt und die Technik wird, es geht so in den Alltag ein, verschwindet vielleicht sogar so ein bisschen und wir reden nur noch mit unserer Tapete und so weiter und die Antworten dann, aber nein, Menschen haben wieder echt einen Spaß am Gerät. Tim Britlove hat das als, wie er das genannt hat, keine Verzögerung mehr, als hätte es er mit einer Maschine vor sich zu tun. Also mit maschinellen, manuellen, man hebt den Stift hoch und ist halt oben und nicht verzögert irgendwie und so. Man schreibt irgendwas und das Zeug taucht tatsächlich auf und er ist jetzt total glücklich mit seinem Computer. Tim Britlove ist nie zu glücklich mit seinem Computer. Seit 15 Jahren ranken sich Legenden darum, wie unzufrieden Tim Britlove mit seinen Computern ist, aber diesmal ist er das erste Mal zufrieden. Und so geht das durch die Bank. Die Leute sind hin und weg von diesem allerersten und es ist noch das billige Modell. In den teuren Modellen sind dann wieder die Intel-Chips drin. Da hat sich Apple noch nicht ganz getraut.
Aber was heißt denn billiges Modell?
Tausend Euro weniger vielleicht sogar oder so ungefähr tausend Euro.
Also es gibt ja auch Laptops für 500 Euro, die günstige.
Genau, also für ein Apple Laptop Einstiegs. Da haben wir jetzt diesen eigenen Chip drin. Und nach der iPhone Geschichte würde ich sagen, Apple startet jetzt gerade nochmal neu. Die haben jetzt den Mac Mini als allen möglichen Varianten, als Server, als Schreibtisch, irgendwie Gerät und so weiter. Den eigenen Laptop, der Mac Pro, der also der richtige Pro Computer, mit dem man dann auch die großen Filme entwickelt und so. Das wird dann auch alles noch auf diesen Chip. Das ist sozusagen erstmal die Testphase und trotzdem sind alle schon so aus dem Häuschen.
Aber sind da nur aus dem Häuschen die, die jetzt so wie Tim Pritloff ein ganz spezielles Verhältnis zur Technik haben und da auch sagen, das muss jetzt doch eigentlich schneller gehen und jetzt geht es endlich so schnell. Wird das sich auch übertragen auf die normale Bevölkerung, die sofort sehen kann, wow, so ein iPhone, was das alles kann. Aber wenn man jetzt sagt, ja, da ist so ein Computer, der ist unglaublich schnell, dann sagen die auch, ja, meiner ist auch ganz schnell.
Aber genau, genau, also genau das meine ich mit diesem Vergleich der Rezeptionsgeschichte des iPhone. Das iPhone ist heute in Amerika trotz des immensen Preises, von dem Apple nie abrückte bis jetzt. Jetzt haben sie dieses iPhone SE, das so ein bisschen billiger ist, haben sie es geschafft, so auf 40 Prozent Durchseuchung mit iPhones zu kommen. Obwohl Android so billige Alternativen schafft und so weiter. Und selbst du hast jetzt schon so ein schädliches Gerät.
Ich habe ein Huawei gekauft, aber jetzt nicht, damit Menschen glauben, ich sei vom Glauben abgefallen. Und ich würde jetzt auch zu den Smartphonebesitzern gehören. Das ist nicht so ganz korrekt. Ich habe ihn, das Smartphone wirklich nur angeschlossen am Laptop, um damit Instagram bedienen zu können. Denn Instagram kann man nicht am Laptop bedienen, zumindest nicht so, wie man es will. Eine Story hochladen, das ist einfach nicht möglich. Warum ist das nicht möglich? Könnte man ja einfach machen. Mit Facebook kann ich das ja auch, weil ich ja dann zum Beispiel einen Adblocker installieren könnte und könnte alle Werbung wegdrücken. Und Instagram lebt aber extrem davon, dass man das nicht kann. Und wenn man dort durch ein paar Storys so fährt, dann merkt man ja nach jeder Story, fast nach jeder Story, bekommt man Werbung von irgendwas. Und selbst, obwohl ich so wenig bei Instagram mache, aber wahrscheinlich sind die auch mit Facebook ja dann gut vernetzt, ist diese Werbung schon relativ zielgenau. Also sie adressiert mich als den jungen, modischen Mann, der ich bin.
Man kann es aber auch ein bisschen steuern. Ich habe zum Beispiel immer Uhren angeklickt und seitdem werden mir nur noch Uhren angezeigt und dadurch weiß ich, uhren kann ich überblättern. Es ist ja jedes vierte Bild. Es ist ja inzwischen Werbung im Feed und die Stories sind auch voll. Ja, so, also selbst du bist jetzt in den Topf gefallen und hast ein Smartphone.
Aber man erreicht mich weiter über mein Nokia. Also ich verwende es nur, nur für Instagram.
Aber wenn du dein Nokia in der Hand hast und jemand legt daneben so ein aktuelles iPhone, den Unterschied kannst du schon sehen. Also diese hohe Attraktivität von so einem iPhone. Und Apple hat es eben wirklich geschafft, über dieses funktioniert anders das Telefon und es funktioniert so und so. Diese Attraktivität ist so teuer, sich zu verpreisen, dass sie dieses mächtige Unternehmen geworden sind. Und diese Idee von ich mache meinen Computer auf und er ist dann wirklich an. Und zwar nicht nur im Sinne von der Bildschirm leuchtet schon mal und der Rest lädt so nach. Nee, da ist dann einfach wirklich an und du kannst auf, wie das auf dem iPad schon funktioniert, auf dem billigsten MacBook, das du kaufen kannst, einfach mal einen ordentlichen 4K-Film durchrendern, ohne dass das drei Tage dauert. Das sind so Erfahrungen, die schleifen sich dann schon ein, spätestens, wenn man die Erfahrung irgendwo anders gemacht hat, bei einem Kumpel oder so, und dann geht man wieder zurück zu seiner eigenen Maschine und denkt sich, ach du Scheiße, was ist denn hier los, wieso dauert das alles so lange. Also diese Gravitation, diese Technik ist auf jeden Fall da, da kann sich Apple drauf verlassen, weshalb ich jetzt auch die Vermutungen hier äußere, noch in diesen zwanziger Jahren wird Apple mit 10 Billionen Dollar das Wertvollste unternehmen. Also diese mindestens Faktor 5 ist jetzt einfach drin, nachdem bei dem iPhone Faktor 10 drin war. Man denkt so ein bisschen, das ist viel zu krass, das ist alles überbewertet, aber wenn die Welt nicht untergeht, an Apple wird es nicht scheitern, dass hier 10 Billionen Dollar Markenkapitalisierung wirklich sind. Also wir haben es mit dem neuen Jahrzehnt zu tun und ich will ausdrücklich sagen Jahrzehnt, denn darauf läuft der zweite Clip, den ich gleich spiele, hinaus. Aber erstmal, wir müssen Apple jetzt neu beobachten. Apple ist nicht einfach nur ein Computerhersteller, der sich auf dem Markt wie so ein Autohersteller was zusammensammelt und dann näht da nochmal einer das und dann hat man einen tollen Sitz und das Holz kommt von da und so, sondern dadurch, dass Apple das alles so selber macht, haben wir es jetzt wirklich mit einer neuen Blackbox zu tun, wie Leo Laporte hier ganz richtig beschreibt in seinem This Week in Tech Podcast.
Die Erinnerung ist auf dem Chip.
Ja, sehr viele Leute wollen das. Dass sie nämlich ein Gerät haben, von dem sie wissen, das ist kaputt. Da kann ich eh nichts machen und mein Kumpel Peter auch nicht. Also bringe ich es zurück und lasse mir ein neues schicken. Apple steuert dieses Gerät und zwar von vorne bis hinten. Wir können es zwar auch nutzen, aber Apple steuert es. So und jetzt in diesem Gespräch, wo die darüber reden, kommt die Frage auf, was machen denn jetzt die anderen Hersteller? Wie sieht denn eine Strategie dagegen auf? Was sollte denn Microsoft jetzt in der Hardware Welt irgendwie anleiern, damit mal irgendwas passiert und man da vielleicht was dagegenhalten kann? Und hier kommt der 10 Jahre Horizont her.
Ich kann mich nicht von einer anderen Firma anregen, die in der Position ist.
Apple ist, mit der Exzeption, vielleicht...
Es braucht zwei Jahre, um es zu organisieren. Und das ist verdächtig.
So November 2020 ist als der PC-Markt tatsächlich vielleicht so langsam den Untergang, weil entweder man macht jetzt auch so eine integrierte Lösung, also technisch integriert, so dass die Komponenten so gut miteinander umgehen, dass wirklich alles aus einem Rutsch funktioniert oder man hat es weiter mit diesen ganzen Trade-offs zu tun. Man braucht irgendwie einen Treiber, damit dieser Hersteller RAM mit diesem Hersteller Prozessor gut zusammenarbeitet und der ganze Kram. Und da stößt man so langsam ans Ende der Straße, weil Intel weist sowieso nicht weiter. Man kann jetzt nicht von 5 Nanometer auf 3 Nanometer oder was auch immer. Also diese Fortschritte sind einfach nicht da. Man hat so Technik-Fortschritte von 5 Prozent Geschwindigkeit pro Entwicklungszyklus, also pro Jahr. Und Apple macht ja irgendwie jedes Jahr 30 Prozent schneller. Also wenn sich das so weiterentwickelt, wie das jetzt beim iPhone schon geklappt hat. Und iPhone heißt halt kleiner Raum, wenig Energie. Jetzt reden wir über Computer. Da ist immer ein Stromkabel angeschlossen und da ist auch viel Platz im Gehäuse. Da kann man mit so einem Prozessor nochmal ganz anders und auch ein bisschen verschwenderischer umgehen von Apple-Seite aus. Also da ist enormes Potenzial dafür, jetzt wirklich die Welt zu übernehmen. Und da fragt man sich so ein bisschen, was heißt jetzt Welt übernehmen? Und da switchen wir jetzt von der Hardware so ein bisschen zur Software, nämlich dem Silicon-Valley als Herstellungsort der Social-Media-Sachen. Und da gab es zwei Sachen, die ich jetzt versuche zu integrieren. Und wir überprüfen jetzt alle, ob mir das gelingt oder nicht. Es war jedenfalls mein Wunsch, das zu integrieren. Nämlich zum einen, nach der Wahl fanden sich Mark Zuckerberg, also Facebook-Chef und Jack Dorsey, der Twitter-Chef, vorm Kongress ein, dem Senat, nicht dem Repräsentat, und mussten dort Rede und Antwort stehen zu verschiedenen Fragen. Die hören wir gleich. Und Tristan Harris, den wir hier auch schon ein paar Mal genannt haben, der damals bei Google an der Ethik-Front mitgearbeitet hat, um die eine oder andere Design-Entwicklung zu treffen, und der ja dann jetzt mit so eigenen NGOs und so weiter, so ein bisschen an der Aufklärung, wie funktioniert das mit Silicon Valley, der auch mitverantwortlich ist für das Social Dilemma, diesen Film von Netflix, den ich noch nicht gesehen habe, aber der soll wohl solide, wenn auch nicht sehr tiefgehend gewesen sein.
Er ist solide, also sagen wir mal, das hat man jetzt, wenn man sich so eine Kongress-Anhörung mal zu Gemüte fährt, führt dann doch besser oder einfach mal ein Aufsatz oder ein Interview von Zuboff gelesen, dann ist es halt wie oft diese Netflix-Docos.
Also ich habe es mir nicht angesehen, weil Netflix noch keine doppelte Geschwindigkeit für mich drin hat.
Ja, die könnte man dort tatsächlich mal brauchen. Also ich bin ja sehr dagegen, dass man Filme doppelt in doppelter Geschwindigkeit streamt, aber diese Doku bietet halt sehr wenig und das ist halt auch in so einem Geklimper dann darunter gelegt und dann soll diese Stimmung und ja, but maybe we can change the world und dann wird das dann doch wieder alles so ein positives am Ende und jetzt ist es aber an der Zeit. Es sieht ja alles immer aus wie so ein Image-Video, es ist ja am Ende dann auch nie ein Dokumentarfilm.
Da sitzen immer die Werbefilmer da, die dann solche Filme produzieren, dann sieht es immer so gleich aus. Gut, also wir integrieren das jedenfalls. Wir beginnen bei Harris und dann kommen wir zu den Hearing, dann kommen wir wieder zu Harris und den Hearing und so weiter, und versuchen, das thematisch so ein bisschen zusammenzubinden.
Du machst jetzt hier den Eisenstein der Podcast. Ja, ist ja, der Eisenstein und überhaupt die russischen Formalisten, die bringen ja die Gegensätze zusammen und sagen, das ist eigentlich die Kunst des Films, zusammenzuschneiden, ja, und da Dialektik auftreten zu lassen und das jetzt als Podcast.
Okay, wir versuchen jetzt eisensteinische Dialektik ohne Bild. Also, was geht los mit Tristan Harris, der beschreibt mal das Smartphone als was eigentlich? Was zeichnet dieses Gerät aus?
Mein Grundstück war als Design-Ethesist bei Google. Dann, ein Jahr nach dem Start-up, habe ich eine Präsentation gemacht, die sich um die Frage stellt, wie technologisch die menschliche Psychologie in den Händen hält. Das wird die primäre Widerstandsmachine für die Welt.
Das Smartphone ist die Sinnmaschine der Welt. Der Generator für Bedeutung. Man schaut drauf und in einer gewissen Co-Evolution entsteht etwas auf dem Bildschirm und im Kopf. Das befruchtet sich gegenseitig und man scrollt weiter. Das Bewusstsein bestimmt das Sein in der Hand und umgedreht. Eine schöne Befruchtungsmaschine, die da entsteht. Jetzt wird Lindsay Graham, als Republikaner, im Senat und fragt die beiden nicht Anwesenden, sondern Zugeschalteten. Wie haltet ihr es eigentlich aus mit Gesundheitsrisiken?
Also die erste Sache, die ich hier nennen möchte, ist der Gesundheitsdruck mit sozialen Medien.
Also, hätte man von so einem Republikaner, nachdem wir die letzte Anhörung gehabt haben, nicht gedacht, dass er auf Risiko, Gesundheitsrisiken, hinsichtlich Social Media kommt, und er formuliert die Frage noch mal aus.
We design the product to be as useful and meaningful as possible. We want people to use them because they are meaningful.
Blablabla, meaningful, ja. Es soll von Bedeutung sein, aber nicht süchtig machen. Also eine gewisse Attraktivität soll schon sein, aber wir haben noch keine Studien dazu, ob es wirklich süchtig macht. Was sagt Tristan Harris dazu? Nach welchen Prinzipien ist das da alles entwickelt?
So mein Hintergrund war als Kind, ich war ein Magier, wir können das erkennen. Und dann später studierte ich Behavioral Economics und wie die Geistung ein bisschen beeinflusst. Und dann bin ich an Google gekommen, durch diese Lenz von, du weißt, Technologie ist nicht wirklich nur das Ding, das in unseren Händen ist.
Ja, also wenn Mark Zuckerberg sagt, die Studies sind noch nicht conclusive, ob wir jetzt eine Suchtmaschine entwickelt haben, dann meint er, wir haben es noch nicht herausgefunden, ob wir Erfolg hatten, den wir uns gewünscht haben oder nicht. Aber wir haben es schon mal so angelegt.
Und es ist so verlogen, wenn man sich ein bisschen die Geschichte des Silicon Valley oder generell der Computertechnik vergegenwärtigt, dann ist man sehr nah zum Beispiel bei den Macy-Konferenzen. Die Macy-Konferenzen haben Verhaltensforschung zusammengebracht und Kybernetik. Das heißt, man hat natürlich solche Mechanismen analysiert, wie entstehen Süchte, wie entstehen autoritäre Modelle, denen Menschen folgen. Das war ein ganz großes Thema. Das war ein großes Thema in den USA. Dann vor allem nach 45 bei diesen Macy-Konferenzen. Und selbstverständlich kann man aus diesen auch Lehren ziehen, die man dann zur Manipulation einsetzt. Das heißt, das ist in gewisser Weise auch ein Teil der DNA des Silicon Valley und hier wird jetzt so getan, als wollte man einfach mal ganz nützliche Produkte machen, die auch meaningful sind, was immer das bedeutet. Und das andere spielt keine Rolle. Wir haben es, glaube ich, auch kurz angesprochen im Salon, als wir diese Instagram Biografie besprochen haben. Ja, natürlich denkt man sich was dabei, dass man diesen Kringel da macht, der aufleuchtet, wenn ich dort ein Profil anklicke und das sage, oh, da gibt es wieder was Neues, da klicke ich drauf. Da ist ja Verhaltensforschung drin. Jeder Supermarkt ist so angelegt. Und da sind wir noch auf einem ganz rudimentären Level. Hier sind wir in ganz anderen Höhen. Aber wir können ja hier schon mal einen ganz kurzen Verweis machen auf den Salon. Wir sprechen über ein sensationelles Buch, kann man glaube ich sagen.
Mega, mega, Art und Dau, geliefert hat er.
Weil ein tolles Buch, der Titel schon, Was das Silicon-Valley-Denken nennt. Ja, also nicht, was das Silicon-Valley denkt, sondern Denken nennt und es ist eine Ideen-Geschichte. Also welche Ideen sind da und wo tauchen die mal so ganz beiläufig aus? Aber wie prägend sind sie eigentlich? Und ich war ja immer der Auffassung, Ideen-Geschichte ist in gewisser Weise auch Ideologie-Kritik, denn es wird dann historisiert, woher es kommt und was eigentlich dahinter steht. Und das betreibt er da. Also wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr viel Neues erfährt man dort, selbst wenn man sich schon ausführlich mit all diesen Silicon-Valley-Fragen beschäftigt.
Genau, und Adrian Daub ist ja auch ganz wichtig. Klar ist Literaturprofessor in Stanford, aber diese Verknüpfung von Stanford und Silicon Valley und die ist ja Tristan Harris hier auch so wichtig. Die lernen in Stanford, wie das mit Kulten funktioniert und wie Überzeugungs, also dieses Persuasion und so wie das alles funktioniert. Und wenden das dann da eben an. Und wenn dann Mark Zuckerberg hier sagt, also es könnte sein, dass wir als nebenfolge Suchtmaschine entwickelt haben, aber wir müssen das mal noch überprüfen, ist wirklich zu 100 Prozent gelogen. Genau das Gegenteil. Es war zwar von Anfang an das Ziel und man hat das auch so verfolgt. Lindsey Graham führt hier noch ein bisschen aus, wie er auf seine psychischen Fragestellungen da angesprochen.
Eine andere Studie von 12.013 bis 16-Jährigen in England fand, dass diejenigen, die mehr als drei Stunden am Tag mit sozialen Medien verwendet haben, eine höhere Risik von mentalen Geistproblemen hatten.
Also, wir können mal festhalten, nachdem die Demokraten schon festgestellt haben, die zerstören unseren Markt, stellt er jetzt fest, die zerstören unsere Gehirne. Und es mangelt nicht an Wissen. Es hat jetzt hier ein ganz gutes Studienwissen vorgestellt. Kann man ja kurz kalkulieren. Ein typischer Teenager in Amerika checkt 170 mal am Tag sein Telefon. Das hieße bei zehn Stunden, die man mal so als wach und vielleicht nicht abgelenkt von Schule oder Schlaf, wenn man es runter bricht, immer noch. Also alle zwei Minuten. Also wir sind ja wirklich dauerbeschallt von diesen Geräten. Und da erübrigt sich eigentlich die Frage sind wir süchtig danach? Also was machen wir denn sonst alle zwei Minuten noch in dieser Welt?
Bewusst?
Es ist ja mittlerweile wirklich wie Atmen, ja so eingegangen in so eine Körperfunktion, dass man da so eine Prothese nutzt. Also Thema Engagement, was kann Tristan Harris dazu sagen?
Denn Facebook, wiederum, ist auf die Gruppe, wenn du mitnehmen würdest, würde es dir die meisten Zeit verbringen. Okay, also wenn du mitnehmen würdest, dann läuft das gleich wieder. Also jetzt schau mal auf Facebook, es sagt, hey, ich hab diese Voodoo-Dolls, ich hab so 100 Millionen Voodoo-Dolls, und sie alle, sie haben nur mitgenommen, dass ich in diesen Antivaccine-Moms-Gruppen teilnehm. Flat Earth, absolut. Ja. Und YouTube hat es empfohlen, also, ich gehe interchanglich von YouTube zu Facebook, weil es die gleiche Dynamik ist.
Also macht es süchtig und verbaut es dein Gehirn? Ja, würde man jetzt, wenn man Tristan Harris folgt, sagen. Lindsey Graham traut sich hier mal eine ganz witzige Frage zu an Biden.
Have you seen the movie Social Dilemma?
Das ist eine ganz versteckte Drohung, wenn wir mit dem Social-Media-Gram genauso umgehen wie mit Tabakko, dann wissen wir, das heißt jetzt 30 Jahre Krieg. Also da ist es dann wirklich, in der Hinsicht, nicht schlecht, Prinz C.
Aber wie sehr mich das doch erstaunt, denn wir haben ja die Republikaner bei einer Anhörung erlebt, das war ja kläglich.
Das war noch vor der Wahl vielleicht.
Ja, ja, sie wollten wissen, können wir weiterhin Fake News verbreiten? Ja, wird da zensiert. Und sonst haben sie ja nur Unsinn von sich gegeben.
Ja, in der Hinsicht, es ist halt doch eine neue Welt, in der man aufwacht, wenn man also klar vor der Wahl haben sie vielleicht wirklich das Social Media noch gebraucht, so im Sinne von, wollten sich mit denen nicht anlegen. Und jetzt haben sie aber gesehen, nee, wir haben verloren. Also wir kommen nachher noch mal auf die Wahl, kurz zu sprechen. Gibt es auch noch ein paar Fragen, aber es ist ein bisschen neu hier, muss man so sagen. Tristan Harris, der hat ja eben schon von der Voodoo-Puppe gesprochen. Vorher im Gespräch hat er das Bild mal vorgestellt und ich finde es eine Sensation, denn wir haben von Frank Schörmacher die Nummer zwei in Ego beschrieben bekommen, also dieses digitale Duplikat von uns. Die Yvonne Hofstetter sprach ja von digitalen Zombies, also schon so entleerte, nicht mehr ganz lebendige, aber noch funktionstüchtige, die dann irgendwie nur noch so in den Trieb gesteuert ihre Handys benutzen. Und Joachim Gauck als Bundespräsident hat damals vom digitalen Zwilling gesprochen. Also wir sehen immer wieder dieses gleiche Bild. Da wird also ein Duplikat von uns angefasst und mit dem wird dann spieltheoretisch ausgebeutet. Und Tristan Harris nimmt genau dieses Bild und nennt das aber eine Voodoo-Puppe. Und ich finde, er macht das ziemlich clever. Voodoo-Puppe ist vielleicht gar nicht so falsch. Er beschreibt das hier immer.
Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du das so gut wie möglich aussehen kannst. Es geht um die Frage, wie man sich an die Voodoo-Puppe befindet.
Die Voodoo-Puppe wird so nach und nach zusammengebaut, dass sie dir immer ähnlicher wird. Aber die Verbindung zu dir ist tatsächlich nur dieses, wenn ich da piekse, führt das bei dir zu einer Reaktion und du weißt nicht genau woher. Das ist wirklich ein ganz super Bild.
Es ist ein sehr gutes Bild und ist auch wieder ein Teil der Schauer-Romantik, wie das ja auch bei Schirmacher der Fall ist. Er bezieht sich auf Frankenstein. Also diese ganzen Ideen sind eigentlich welche, die im 19. Jahrhundert entstehen, obwohl diese Texte die Industrialisierung gar nicht verhandeln, also sie fast ausblenden, Schauer-Romantische Topheu entstehen lassen, sagen sie doch schon sehr viel darüber aus, wie die Technik uns in Zukunft manipulieren könnte. Und sie machen das nur innerhalb eines Genres. Und deswegen ist es sehr interessant, dass es hier fast so einen intuitiven Rückgriff gibt auf solche Schauer-Romantischen Motive.
Das stimmt, die wurden dann schon mal literarisch eingeführt. Und der Sinn kam dann erst später, als man sie wirklich gebraucht hat, wie so ein Gebrauchsgegenstand. Und so wie er die Voodoo-Pupille vorstellt, das finde ich auch super. Und er macht jetzt auch, klar, er blickt zurück 10 Jahre, aber wir wissen, das Experiment geht ja weiter.
Wenn du auf einen Auto-Krash siehst, und alle, die auf dem Stadion fahren, schauen auf den Auto-Krash, wie es bei Facebook und Google so ist, die ganze Welt will Auto-Krashes. Wir füllen sie einfach nach Auto-Krash, nach Auto-Krash, nach Auto-Krash. Und was die Algorithmen tun, wie Guillaume Chazelot in dem Film sagt, der YouTube-Wisselblower vom YouTube-Recommendationssystem, ist, dass sie den perfekten kleinen Kugelkugel für dich finden, den sie wissen, dass sie dich dort für fünf Stunden halten.
So, was ja wirklich ein bisschen übel ist, ein Tic Tac. Kannst du es dir dann auch mal installieren? Du hast ja jetzt einen Bildschirm dafür.
Um Gottes Willen nein, aber Ola hat es mir vorgeführt.
Man scrollt das so durch und irgendwann ist man in dem Modus, dass man denkt, ich bin gespannt, wie der jetzt stirbt. Oder du siehst so eine Autobahn und du fragst dich so, auf welches Auto muss ich jetzt gucken? Welches überschlägt sich hier gleich? Also du erwartest nur noch das Allerschlimmste, weil dir nur noch das angezeigt wird die ganze Zeit. Das ist so eine Erwartungshaltung, die sich da aufbaut. Und das ist wirklich gruselig, wenn man das so... Also da kann man es erleben bei TikTok, wie Erwartungshaltung so ausgebeutet ist, wie auf der anderen Seite des Bildschirms der Supercomputer, die Voodoo Doll, so malträtiert, dass du dann irgendwann wirklich nur noch solche Unfälle erwartest.
Und bei TikTok ist es ja ohnehin so, dass dort die algorithmische Gewalt noch mal größer eigentlich ist als bei YouTube. Also bei YouTube haben wir ja oben ein Suchfeld und ich kann was eingeben und ja, wenn ich ein Verschwörungsvideo gesehen habe, komme ich zum nächsten. Das ist definitiv so. Aber es ist doch noch mehr ein auch von mir selbst ausgelöster Prozess oder ich habe auch wieder bessere Möglichkeiten, mich aus diesem Rabbit Hole zu begeben. Das ist ja bei TikTok kaum möglich. Also ich habe zwar auch so eine mir selbst kuratierte Seite, die mir zur Verfügung steht und mit der ich dann arbeiten kann. Aber eigentlich ist ja diese Seite, die der Algorithmus für mich zusammenstellt, also immer mir das gerade anzeigt, was er glaubt, was ich sehen will. Und damit ist ja wahrscheinlich sehr treffend. Das ist ja etwas, was mich dann immer weiter hineinbringt. Und dort gibt es eben viel weniger Möglichkeiten, rauszugehen, als das jetzt bei YouTube noch der Fall ist. Also es ist eine ganz fatale Falle.
Algorithmische Gewalt ist genau der richtige Begriff dafür. Ist das eine Schöpfung von dir oder ist das irgendwie so?
Das ist eine Schöpfung von mir. Soll ich vielleicht dieses Buchtitel anmelden?
Da musst du auf jeden Fall ein Instagram-Bild draus machen, Algorithmische Gewalt. Also wir wissen ja bei YouTube, 80 Prozent wird dann auch über Algorithmus gesteuert, weil das erste Video in der Empfehlungsleiste läuft automatisch und nur jeder fünfte Video-Start geht dann wirklich auf den Klick zurück. Bei TikTok, wie du sagst, 100 Prozent, da kannst du zwar zum nächsten Video scrollen, aber das nächste Video ist festgelegt. Also da kannst du nicht viel wechseln, außer neben zu dem selbst zusammenkugelatierten, aber da ist ein bisschen genauso ausgeliefert.
Und die haben das ja aus der Nachrichten-App heraus entwickelt. Also es gab ja diese Tabau und Taubo, ich weiß gerade den Titel, also von Baitens auch, also gehört auch zu Baitens. Und da ging es ja darum, dass man sich einen Newsfeed zusammenstellt, der dann nur noch aus den Nachrichten entsteht, die einen auch wirklich interessieren. Und das funktionierte eigentlich wie TikTok. Und das gibt es auch wohl immer noch. Und das war der Anfang, da dachte man ja, man könnte das ja eigentlich mit Videos machen, das sei ja noch interessanter. Und das ist im Prinzip jetzt das, was wir erleben mit den ganzen Verschwörungstheoretikern, dass sie sich dann auch nur noch mit diesen Fake-News beschäftigen. Und da hat man das eigentlich auch gemacht. Natürlich mal vielleicht sogar der Absicht, dass man sagt, gut, der Algorithmus erkennt, was du willst. Und du interessierst dich eben für das Silicon-Valley oder für China und dann bekommst du das angezeigt. Und das war eine erfolgreiche App. Und dann hat man TikTok daraus entwickelt, beziehungsweise Musical.ly. Aber eigentlich ist diese algorithmische Machtgewalt, die ist das, was eigentlich den Grundstein erstmal gelegt hat dafür.
Ja, und warum algorithmische Gewalt nicht der falsche Begriff ist, wird hier nochmal kurz erklärt, wenn Tristan Harris uns das Phänomen Thinspo erklärt. Hast du schon mal davon gehört? Das kann auch jeder hören. Kurz überlegen, Thinspo, was könnte das sein?
Du hast 100 Millionen andere Voodoo-Dolls von 13-jährigen Mädchen. Sie schauen alle diese anderen Videos. Ich weiß nur, dass sie das Wort Thinspo, oder Thinspiration, das ist das Name für es. Aber wenn du die Maschine blinden lässt, ist das alles, was du machst, um etwas zu fangen, das engagiert.
Warum haben sie nicht die Maschine blinden lassen, wenn sie nur ein Ding haben, wie Anorexie?
So thin, dünn, spiration, thinnspiration, gott, thinnspo. Junge Mädchen wollen dünner werden, informieren sich über Ernährung bei YouTube und drei empfohlenen Videos später gucken sie sich Videos über Magersüchtige und so weiter an und orientieren sich da dran. Also kann man mal, ne? Und dafür gibt es dann so Begriffe, also es ist wirklich gruselig was hier. Und da kann man nun wirklich die Lindsey Graham Frage, ja, macht ihr Produkt süchtig? Keine Ahnung. Die Studien sind noch nicht aussagekräftig genug. Naja, zweiter großer Themenblock, der hier behandelt wurde, das ist nicht ganz uninteressant. John Kennedy, irgend so ein Republikaner, macht hier mal so einen Halbsatz. So, sie sind so mächtig, ich rede gar nicht mit ihnen als Unternehmenschef, sondern sie sind hier als Staatschefs zu uns gekommen. Und ehrlich gesagt, da hat man eine ganze große rote Linie in diesem Hearing drin gehabt. Ich war ganz überrascht. Tristan Harris stellt hier kurz im Gespräch mit Joe Rogan da. Jaja, die waren selber ein bisschen überrascht von ihrer Macht.
Ich glaube, es ist wichtig, die Zeit für die Menschen zurückzuwenden, weil es einfach ist, zu denken, dass wir hier landen, und dass sie wissen, dass sie die globalen Psychologie haben. Aber ich denke, wir sollten die Zuschauer in die Richtung der Produkte verändern.
So und haben sie es gemacht? Ja, man hat halt einfach mal Produkte entwickelt und plötzlich hat man die Welt regiert. Ja und diese Fragen, die Mark Zuckerberg da heute so gestellt werden, wie gehen, wie schützen sie denn unsere Wahl? Ja wieso sollt ihr jetzt plötzlich in 35er überhaupt über nachdenken? Aber ja, er hat das alles in Gefahr gebracht und deswegen ist völlig zurecht, er hat ihnen jetzt die Frage gestellt, wie schützen sie jetzt eigentlich diese Wahl? Und in diesem Hearing, Lindsay Graham, hat es auch aufgegriffen, dass man hier eigentlich mit Staaten zu tun hat.
Aber wenn man Unternehmen hat, die die Macht der Regierung haben, haben sie viel mehr Macht als traditionelle Medienoutlets, dann muss man etwas geben.
Und so weiter und so fort, also neue Verantwortlichkeiten für diese Unternehmen, die sich da nicht als Plattform einfach rausnehmen können aus dem inhaltlichen Theater.
Du entsinnst dich, wir hatten ja im Salon vor ein paar Monaten dieses Buch von Brad Smith, dem Anwalt von Microsoft Tools and Weapons und das war ja auch interessant, wie das formuliert war. Das war ja jetzt nicht so, dass er einfach mal die Unternehmensphilosophie dort offen gelegt hat oder sagte, wohin sich das entwickeln soll, sondern er macht eigentlich jetzt so ein Angebot an die Vereinigten Staaten. Also der Staat Microsoft macht ein Angebot an die Vereinigten Staaten. Wir können doch hier zusammen kooperieren. Also wie man so ein Handelsabkommen vielleicht macht oder einen Friedensvertrag aushandelt oder die NATO gebildet hat, so schlägt er ja auch vor, wir können da zusammenarbeiten, wir machen da ein Bündnis, aber die sehen sich schon so als Staat an. Das würde er natürlich so nie schreiben, um immer zu sagen, wir sind ja eigentlich nur ein Unternehmen aus der Garage entstanden und groß geworden. Aber das ist eigentlich ein sehr, sehr guter Punkt. Und dann kommt man auch in ganz andere Richtungen bei der Verhandlung.
Ja, das Außenministerium von Clinton unter Obama hat ja auch sich bei Google mit außenpolitischer Kompetenz ausgestattet. Also da ist ja Eric Schmidt für die nach Nordkorea geflogen und so und hat da ein bisschen rumverhandelt und so, weil da einfach andere Druckmittel noch da sind, wenn da Google kommt, als wenn da irgendwie Washington eine Idee vortragen möchte oder so. Also in der Ansicht, die Verschränkungen sind groß und Tristan Harris beschreibt es mal hier. Apple als Plattformanbieter ist so mächtig, dass man eigentlich von der Regierung spricht.
Und auch die Leute reden über die Regierung, die diese Plattformen reguliert, aber Apple ist die Regierung, die die Anerkennungskonzerne reguliert. Das bedeutet, dass sie einen Carbon-Tax machen, aber auf der Verwundung, sie machen einen sozialen Medienverwundungsgericht, die 30% anvertragen, aber sie können mehr tun als das. Sie haben eine 30-70-Tax-Split, die App-Developer bekommen 70% der Revenu, wenn man was kauft und Apple 30% behält.
Also diese Gebühren, die App-Hersteller an Apple zahlen, um auf iOS präsent zu sein, funktionieren wie Steuern. Darüber kann man auch inhaltlich steuern. Das Ganze, die ganze digitale Welt in die und die Richtung irgendwie bringen und so. Und machen wir mal einen ganz kleinen Exkurs. Nur Yuval Harari war ja in diesem stundenlangen Podcast von der Zeit, alles gesagt heißt er, und er spekuliert hier auch mal über ein künftiges Geschäft, das Modell des Silicon Valley.
Ich spring mal ein bisschen vor.
Up here ist es glaube ich so interessant.
But that's the thing, I mean, their business model of all these guys is really ridiculous. They are making peanuts compared to what they could make. I mean, we are talking about people who first of all politically could control countries. And you can make a lot more money from controlling countries than from selling stupid advertisements. I mean, how much money they make out of selling advertisements? A couple of hundred billion? That's not a lot of money in today's... Especially when the central banks are constantly creating more money out of nothing. So you make a hundred billion dollars and the Federal Reserve just create a trillion dollars out of nothing. That's more impressive. Now, I mean, even if you forget about controlling countries, you want advertisements, okay. They have the power to completely destroy the advertisement industry and replace it. Because, you know, advertisements...
Ja, ich fasse mal zusammen, was er dann sagt. Üblicherweise ist ja so, dass wir, wenn wir uns, er nimmt das Beispiel, ein Auto kaufen wollen, dann haben wir einen unglaublich großen Markt an Möglichkeiten, ein Auto uns zu kaufen. Also gehen wir rum ins Internet und kriegen dort sehr viel Werbung angezeigt. So, stattdessen könnten wir einfach Google fragen, welches Auto soll ich mir kaufen? Google kennt mich ja. Die kennen mein Budget, die kennen meine Vorlieben, meine Lieblingsfarbe, will ich auch mal schnell fahren und so weiter. Und dann sagen die mir einfach, welches Auto ich kaufen muss. Warum dieses ganze Werbeding, um mir vorzugehauen, ich hätte die Entscheidung noch getroffen oder was? Das ist ja totaler Quatsch. Und auch was hat man denn für eine Entscheidung getroffen? Hat man alle irrelevanten Informationen einbezogen? Das kann auch Google alles viel besser. Also warum fragen wir nicht einfach Google, welches Auto soll ich mir kaufen? Lassen das mit dem Werbeding links liegen und die Unternehmer gehen einfach nur zu Google und füttern Google halt mit den Informationen, die relevant sind für. Und dann muss man halt und so. Und da geht er halt in die Richtung. Und das andere, was er vorher meinte, man kann die Staaten ja auch direkt regieren, statt einfach nur Wahlkampf mit ihnen mitzumachen. Und er hat dieses Beispiel Cambridge Analytica. Cambridge Analytica ist eine ganz kleine App in einer ganz kleinen Ecke von Facebook gewesen, die das versucht hat. Das könnte auch ganz Facebook einfach versuchen. Da kommen wir auch nachher noch mal drauf zurück. Sie können ja einfach ganz Facebook sagen, wir wollen jetzt, dass der an der Präsident wird. Und das können die dann auch umsetzen. Die haben ja die Aufmerksamkeit, die verteilen ja die Aufmerksamkeit und die Stimmung, je nachdem, welchen Präsidenten sie brauchen. Da verspricht sich allerdings Mark Zuckerberg nachher so schön, dass wir das uns dann noch mal im Detail anhören.
Und das ist eine schöne Überlegung jetzt von Yuval Noah Harari zu sagen, naja, die machen ja momentan noch Peanuts. Also wir sagen immer meine Güte, was da an Milliarden umgesetzt werden. Und dann sind die Kurse oben und wir blicken erstaunt ins Handelsblatt wie nochmal nach oben. Und er sagt jetzt gerade Peanuts. Und das ist eine sehr schöne Überlegung zu sagen, ja, im Vergleich mit einer Zentralbank, die Geld schöpfen kann, ist das auch nicht so viel. Und was wäre denn eigentlich, wenn das neue Starten sind? Und das klingt vollkommen absurd. Aber ich glaube, worauf Harari hier noch anspielt, ist ja, dass es gewisse libertäre Ideen gibt. Warum nicht eigentlich gesamte Städte oder sogar Staaten privatisieren? Warum sollte man die nicht eigentlich zu Unternehmen machen? Und wäre das nicht viel effizienter, hätten wir dann nicht diesen bürokratischen Apparat. Und wählen kann dann eben, wer in der Firmenhierarchie nach oben steigt und und und. Da gibt es verschiedene ganz obskure Modelle, die auch sich einer gewissen Beliebtheit erfreuen in so libertären Kreisen. Man findet dann immer so abstruse YouTube-Kanäle, auf denen das alles vorgestellt wird. Aber das ist auch Teil einer Denkweise, wie wir sie im Silicon Valley immer wieder finden. Deswegen sollte uns das alles gar nicht so überraschen. Und ich finde, er verbindet hier ganz gut die Punkte, dass wir ein bisschen langfristig denken und planen. Denn wir haben lange Zeit geglaubt, naja, das sind halt Unternehmen, die verdienen ein bisschen Geld mit Apps und technischem Schnickschnack. Aber jetzt hat man gesehen, welche Macht die haben. Das heißt aber nicht, dass die Macht nicht auch ein exponentielles Wachstum noch erleben kann in den nächsten 10, 15 Jahren.
Genau, also wir können ja durchgehen. Google ist großer Gesundheitsdienstleister. Die haben sich jetzt Fitbit geholt, machen diese ganzen Studien mit Diabetes im Auge und so weiter, Insulin da messen und der ganze Kram. Details egal. Facebook ist ein großer Organisator von Identität. Eines der wichtigsten Anliegen, das Starten zu haben. Passagiere ohne Papiere. Ohne Papiere ist man niemand, Person. Wir haben mobile Adressen, die wir mit uns führen. Das machen alle Handy-Anbieter. Amazon versorgt uns. Das ist eigentlich auch ein großer staatlicher Auftrag, der da dahin steckt zur Grundversorgung. Und so weiter und so fort. Und es bricht aber noch nicht aus ihnen heraus, obwohl sie jetzt alle schon Banklizenzen haben und so, um Google und Amazon und Apple Pay zu machen. Es bricht noch nicht so richtig aus ihnen. Sie sind noch in diesem Werbebusiness drin. Und Tristan Harris beschreibt das als die letzten Auszüge der Chunk Attention, also Müllaufmerksamkeitsökonomie. Und er beschreibt hier, welche Früchte es noch trägt. Aber irgendwann stellen wir alle fest, dass es eigentlich sehr nuss ist.
Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass ihr hier mit uns seid.
Also, Second Screen, ja, wir verdoppeln das nochmal, indem wir dir noch ein Telefon neben dich halten und dann hoffen, dass du da nochmal Werbung guckst. Aber noch ist das halt das Hauptbusiness-Modell, ne? Also Google macht ja zu 98% nur Werbeeinnahmen, der Rest ist ja nicht nennenswert. Auch wenn sie ein paar Produkte verkaufen.
Es ist ein Statement, das du gemacht hast.
Sie unterstellt ihm hier gerade, er hätte das mal gesagt. Jetzt versucht er sich da gleich auszurücken. So was wäre eigentlich das Szenario? Irgendwer in Nordkorea, im Iran oder so wird sanktioniert. Keine Konten mehr in Amerika. Keine Business Beziehung. Kein Facebook Account. Ja, also dieses kein Facebook Account. Könnte man das Facebook einfach sagen? Also dem erlaubst du jetzt kein Facebook Account mehr? Und man denkt sich so als Zuhörer, was stellt Stefan gerade für eine komische hypothetische Frage? Die klingt ja auch ziemlich albern, stellt sich raus, längst Realität.
Wir werden immer mit der Arbeit arbeiten, um die Verlust der Schäden zu minimieren.
So wird eine Stadt nie alle Gr So, also er vergleicht seine Facebook-Community mit einer Stadt, in der er für Sicherheit sorgen muss, weshalb er sich das Recht nimmt, um andere Facebook-Accounts zu verbieten. Und ganz konkret geht es hier um generelle der Armee in Myanmar, die muslimische Minderheiten jagt. Also wenn das kein staatliches Handeln ist, wirklich hoheitliches Handeln im Sinne einer amerikanischen Außenpolitik, da muss man sich, also das ist wirklich mittlerweile verschränkt ohne Ende. Und in deren Sicht hat das ja auch mal gut dargestellt.
Es scheint ja auch ähnliche Probleme zu geben für Leute, die sich für Kurden einsetzen. Also das gibt es auch immer wieder, dass dort Accounts gesperrt werden, gelöscht werden, die keine Möglichkeit haben, sich mal über diese IP dort anzumelden. Also auch da wird dann im Prinzip geopolitisch interveniert. Was soll das sonst sein?
Tristan Harris fragt hier. Klar, das Digitale kriegen wir nicht mal raus aus der Welt, aber schaffen wir es vielleicht, die digitalen Autokratien mit digitalen Demokratien irgendwie was entgegenzuhalten?
Und wir müssen ein Welt, wo die digitale Demokratie den digitalen Autorität ausübt, das ist das China-Model.
Ja, und da fragt man sich behind, warum? Weil es immer noch alles so auf Facebook beruht und nicht auf irgendwelchen anderen Technologien oder wie auch immer. Der Ausweg ist jedenfalls nicht, keine Technologie. Das ist anders als bei der Friedensbewegung oder so vor 40 Jahren, die einfach sagen konnte, keine Technik. Da sind wir weit entfernt. In dieser Anhörung wird Mark Zuckerberg hier nochmal gefragt und wie unterstützt du uns hier an unserer Demokratie? Und die Art und Weise ist wirklich auch viel. Ich hätte ja gedacht, auch in Amerika kommt die Wahlinfrastruktur, die man dann am Ende braucht, tatsächlich schon staatlicher Seite. Aber dass er sich ja noch als der große Sponsor von Officials, die die Wahl durchführen, geriert und da Geld spendet mit seiner Frau, das ist schon hart, finde ich. Also das ist diese Verschränkung geht mir einfach ein bisschen zu tief. Dritter kleiner Block Kommunikation als Waffe. Man braucht mehr Kommunikation, damit das da funktioniert. Gleichzeitig muss man sie dann wieder einschränken, damit es nicht zu so auswüchsen kommt und so weiter. Das ist ja auch so ein kleines Paradox, dass man da eben nicht rauskommt und sagen kann, ja, dann stellen wir uns einfach alles ein und so. Tristan Harris beschreibt hier mal das Problem mit dieser kostenlosen Kultur, die da im Silicon Valley um sich gegriffen hat.
Denn das lässt sie sich in die Welt und sie können die Gespräche gegen sich selbst weppen. Ich sehe keinen Weg aus dieser Sache, Tristan. Das ist das größte psychologische Experiment, das wir jemals gesucht haben.
Also nochmal kurz beschrieben, weil das wird gleich ganz wichtig bei dem Mark Zuckerberg Argument. Sie brauchen diese Kommunikation und sie müssen sie kostenlos lassen, für alle zugänglich, damit sie diese Section 230 und so weiter Freiheiten bekommen. Wir sind ja nur eine Plattform. Wir steuern hier nicht, wir redigieren hier nicht, wir sind einfach nur und so weiter. Sie brauchen viel Kommunikation, um dann auf dem Plattformen die Kommunikation gegeneinander zu richten, damit die Engagement-Spirale hochgetrieben wird. Also sie brauchen die Demokraten und die Republikaner vor so einem Wahlkampf. Ja, wenn da ein neues Star Wars-Film kommt, muss auch die Star Trek-Community getriggert werden, damit das da ordentlich zur Sache geht und so. So, das brauchen sie also. Und jetzt fragt man sich so ein bisschen, wie klappt sowas denn? Geht das nicht immer aus dem Ruder? Cory Booker hat hier mal interessante Zahlen aus dem Wahlkampf. Das ist ja der eine Senator, der auch mit auf der Debattenbühne stand, als es darum ging, die Demokraten herauszufinden, welcher Demokrat eigentlich Präsidentschaftskandidat wird.
Und also, wir müssen uns auf das Klaren sein, was passiert ist.
Donald Trumps schuldige und schuldige Läden, die an der Wahlkampfwahl und dem Ergebnis dieser Wahl die meisten engagierten Kontakte auf der sozialen Medien in den Tagen nach der Wahl, in einer Woche nach der Wahl, hat seine Post auf Facebook alle, die zehn engagierten Posts in den USA und 22 von 25 der engagierten Posts in unserem Land, alle aufgeteilt. Und dieser Nummer-1-Post, der Top-of-them-all, war eine falsche Wahlkampfwahl.
So, und hier sieht man jetzt, wie tief sich diese Facebook-Logik schon reingeschlichen hat. Ein demokratischer Senator wirft Facebook vor, dass dort die zehn meisten Nutzerreaktionen hervorrufenden Texte, alle von Donald Trump kamen, also aus der republikanischen Ecke, dem Gegenpol seiner Politik. Jetzt kommt Mike Lee, republikanischer Abgeordneter, der Kommunikation als Waffe zurückschießt. Also die Nutzer sind alle auf republikanischer Seite, was Engagement angeht. Die Hersteller dieser Technologie sind alle auf demokratischer Seite, jedenfalls sponsern sie da so viel. Und beide haben jetzt Argumente vorgebracht, wo sagen muss, ja, dann diskutiert das mal aus, bitte. Ihr habt jetzt was weiß ich wie viel Zeit. Also was für eine Zeitverschwendung auch so insgesamt für den politischen Prozess, dass sie sich jetzt mit so was befassen müssen.
Aber ist das nicht im Kleinen exakt so zu beobachten, wenn wir jetzt mal auf Deutschland klicken? Ich würde mal sagen, die Vogue-Twitter-Leute, so darf ich sie mal nennen. Ich will jetzt nicht gleich Snowflakes sagen, obwohl es mir fast auf der Zunge liegt. Die würden, wenn es hier so was richtig gäbe, mit Wahlkampfspenden oder so was, würden sie sicherlich Rot-Rot-Grün unterstützen. Ich würde sogar sagen, mehrheitlich Grün mit Finanzen unterstützen. Zugleich sind diese es aber, die jeden Tweet eines Ulf Poschert oder sonst, sonst eines solchen merkwürdigen Typen kommentieren, retweeten, irgendwie sich darüber lustig machen. Das heißt, die Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie liegt immer bei diesen Leuten, bei den Provokateuren. Sie arbeiten sich tagtäglich daran ab. Es ist auch nicht so, dass sie zwischendurch mal was Sinnvolles posten. Sie könnten ja auch einfach mal sagen, hier sind drei interessante Texte zu lesen, oder hier ist ein Podcast empfehllich, oder lest doch mal ein Buch. Das kommt alles nicht. Es ist ein tägliches Abarbeiten daran. Und man kann das dann schön beobachten. Man muss sich das einfach mal in so einen Zettel machen, von diesen fünf Figuren, auch gerne dann AfD und Maaßen und und und. Dann schreibt man sich mal auf, wie hoch die Follower sind, und dann prüft man das in acht Wochen nochmal. Dann wird man sehen, bei denen, die da die ganze Zeit angegriffen werden, steigen die Followerzahlen immens. Und dann auch bei denen noch, die angreifen. Und wenn dann auch Poschert noch vielleicht interagiert oder so, steigen die Followerzahlen auch. Das heißt, die spielen sich das zu. Und zum einen würden sie immer eine Partei unterstützen, die SUVs verbietet. Aber jeder SUV-Tweet oder jeder rechtsradikale Tweet muss auch geteilt werden, muss reproduziert werden. Ich finde das ja auch interessant, dass man wirklich es auch immer wieder schafft, bei jeder Corona-Demo fünf, sechs Videos zu Dauerhits zu machen, die dann fünf, sechs Tage permanent in die Timeline gespült werden. Und das bedeutet aber jedes Mal, dass es für andere Sachen keinen Platz mehr gibt. Man muss sich das wirklich vorstellen wie ein Fernsehsender. Die ARD kann 24 Stunden senden. Und jetzt müsste man sich den Algorithmus und müsste sich die Vogue-Twitter-Leute als gemeinsame Intendanz vorstellen. Und die machen das Programm. Und dann hast du 23 Stunden nur diesen Unsinn und irgendwo gibt es dann auch mal dazwischen noch einen wichtigen Beitrag. Aber der ist schon fast versteckt.
Genau. Und das beschreibt Tristan Harris hier. Es ist die Ausgangslage, das erfolgreichste mediale Produkt, schaffst du dann, wenn du so ein Kult-Phänomen da reinbringst. Also diesen Katalysator dieser Kult-Prinzipien.
Ich denke, was ich aber auch machen möchte, ist, dass viele Leute die Gruppe manipulieren, die in diesen Echocamber passieren. Und Facebook hat gerade auch just recently gesagt, dass sie mehr Facebook-Gruppen in die Fäden verboten werden, was bedeutet, dass sie es einfacher machen werden.
Ich würde sie trotzdem so ein bisschen reinsteuern, weil wenn es der eine Kult übertreibt im Umgang mit dem anderen, beispielsweise durch Lügen und so weiter, dann ist das ja unfair. Also wird da jetzt eingegriffen und der Mike Lee, Republikanischer, den ihr eben schon gehört, der beschreibt... Ich werde das mal hier kurz.
Ich habe vorhin etwas über die Wahl auf Facebook gepostet. Und mein Facebook-Post wurde fast sofort mit dem Folgendem getaggert. Sie haben verstanden, dass das Voting in der Mail in Bezug auf die Votingrules der Staaten gestaltet wurde. Die Nachfrage ist sehr unbekannte, aber es ist ein sehr interessanter Punkt. Die Nachfrage ist ein sehr unbekannte, aber es ist ein sehr unbekannte, aber es ist ein sehr unbekannte, aber es ist ein sehr unbekannte, aber es ist ein sehr unbekannte, aber es ist ein sehr unbekannte, aber es ist ein sehr unbekannte, aber es ist ein sehr unbekannte, aber es ist ein sehr unbekannte, aber es ist ein sehr unbekannte, aber es ist ein sehr unbekannte, aber es ist ein sehr unbekannte, aber es ist ein sehr unbekannte, aber es ist ein sehr unbekannte, aber es ist ein sehr unbekannte, aber es ist ein sehr unbekannte, aber es ist ein sehr unbekannte, aber es ist ein sehr unbekannte, aber es ist ein sehr unbekannte, aber es ist ein sehr unbekannte, aber es ist ein sehr unbekannte, aber es ist ein sehr unbekannte, aber es ist ein sehr unbekannte, aber es ist ein sehr unbekannte, Also Facebook stört sich selber sehr damit, Ich bin mit, dass sie jetzt in diesen selbst geschaffenen Katalysatorstrudel der Kommunikation als Waffe, wo sich alle gegenseitig und so, dass sie da jetzt eingreifen müssen, weil es den Vorwurf gibt, die betreiben es aber die ein oder anderen, weil sie sich dann plötzlich zu erkennen geben auf ihrer eigenen Plattform als nicht nur Plattformanbieter, sondern auch.
Und dann kommt da Mike Lee und sagt hier im Sinne von vorhin, das sieht aber schon aus wie so ein statisches Label, was sie hier drunter kleben. Das hat schon so etwas Hoheitliches. Wir sind doch hier auf ihrem Gebiet, das sagen sie doch damit auch. Achtung, Achtung, Sie sind ja auf Mark Zuckerbergs Grundstück und so weiter. Hier gelten seine Regeln. Und da hat dann Ted Cruz, den wir ja kennen, für raffinierte Argumentation der Texaner da, hat auch nachgelegt. Er knüpft sich allerdings Jack Dorsey vor.
Du bist ein Publisher, wenn du das machst.
Also wenn Jack Dorsey da so ein Label dranhängt, ist das die Meinung der Demokraten, die er damit unterstützt, aus seiner Sicht. Und da muss man sich jetzt schon mal die Frage stellen, ehrlich gesagt. Also wenn es diesen neutralen Boden, den die Silicon Valley da für sich reklamiert, nicht gibt, und zwar nicht aus objektiver Sicht, sondern allein, weil einer der Seiten sagt, das ist kein objektiver Boden, sondern ihr schlagt euch hier auf die Seite der Demokraten und das muss irgendwie geregelt werden, dann wird es doch knifflig.
Aber weißt du, was da doch der historische Augenblick wäre? Wir haben, als wir über diese Anhörung sprachen im Sommer, gesehen, wie die Republikaner eigentlich nur ihren Wahlkampf machen wollen über Social Media, deshalb dort nichts einschränken wollen. Sie wollen absolut Free Speech haben und jetzt sehen sie gut, diese Wahl haben wir verloren. Damals waren die Demokraten diejenigen, die sagten, da müssen wir regulieren, da müssen wir das und das machen, und die machten denen Angst. Jetzt haben sie gesehen, okay, jetzt verlieren wir auch, jetzt haben die auch noch größtenteils für die Demokraten gespendet, was jetzt natürlich bedeutet, dass die Demokraten wieder an der Macht weniger Interesse haben könnten, dort zu regulieren, weil sie auch Gelder gesehen haben. Der Austausch zwischen Washington und Silicon Valley war ja auch zu Obamas Zeiten sehr, sehr eng, haben wir auch schon drüber gesprochen. Eigentlich müsste, und das wäre aber jetzt eine Person wie AOC, die das erkennen würde, die anderen wollen das nicht sehen, der historische Augenblick, in dem die Republikaner und die Demokraten gemeinsam ein Interesse formulieren könnten und auch ein Vorgehen, ein ganz klares Vorgehen anstreben könnten gegen die Silicon-Valley-Konzerne, denn eigentlich sind sie so dicht wie noch nie. Es ist jetzt nur ein paar Monate verschoben. Nur ich befürchte jetzt, dass die Republikaner Silicon-Valley kritischer werden. Also das ist ja ja ganz, ganz eindeutig, in welche Richtung das geht. Und dass es aber dann die Demokraten sein werden, die sagen, naja, gut, so klar, wir müssen da mal gucken. Aber eigentlich haben die doch auch jetzt so viel richtig gemacht. Die haben doch jeden Trump-Tweet mit dem Hinweis versehen. Achtung, Fake News.
Da würde ich sagen, ist die letzte Anhörung, wo es um die Marktwirtschaft ging, ein bisschen erfolgsversprechender, weil sich da auch die Republikaner trotz geänderter Machtverhältnisse darauf einlassen können, zu sagen, wir haben es hier mit einem Innovation Death Valley zu tun oder Death Zone oder wie das da benannt wurde von den Demokraten. Weil bei diesem Punkt hier, das scheint mir so ein typisches, sie haben jetzt verloren und sind sauer. Aber dass es da zu großen Regulierungen kommt, das wird dann so ein bisschen schwierig. Jetzt als nächster Clip anschließend an alle Unklarheiten, die wir bis jetzt thematisiert haben. Ich habe damals in Redaktionsschluss schon darüber geschrieben, dass Mark Zuckerberg oder Facebook ja diesen I voted Sticker aufs eigene Facebook Profil angeboten haben, weil sie gesehen haben, damit können wir die Wahlbeteiligung steigern. Und jetzt fragt man sich so ein bisschen, ob die Wahlbeteiligung steigern. Da kommt man ja als Wahlkämpfer schon auf die Idee, Facebook zu fragen, könntest du mal nur unser Wahlvolk so ein bisschen animieren? Nicht alle, sondern nur unsere. Ja, lässt sich das nicht für die Partei ausbeuten, je nachdem, welche man nimmt. Und ich war ein bisschen überrascht, dass jetzt zu hören, dass er gar nichts gelernt hat aus diesem Vorwurf, den man hinterher machen kann, denn er sagt tatsächlich jetzt im November 2020 folgendes.
Wir haben die größte Voterinformation-Kampagne in der Geschichte eröffnet. 140 Millionen Menschen haben unser Voting-Information-Zentrum besucht, mit mehr als 33 Millionen Menschen. Wir schätzen, dass wir mehr als 4, 5 Millionen Menschen überwiesen haben.
Also wir haben vielen geholfen, bei der Wahl teilzunehmen und wir haben viel abgehalten, was die Wahl manipuliert. Das heißt auch nun wirklich im Sinne von Yuval Noah Harari, also formuliere den Wunsch und Mark Zuckerberg kann ihn dir eigentlich erfüllen. Er wird natürlich nicht wollen, weil und so, aber es ist alles möglich. Er kann die Wahlbeteiligung hoch und runter.
Vertragen wir das dann mal auf Europa, wenn du jetzt willst, dass bei einer Europawahl viele Wellen gehen, aber doch so eine, sagen wir, Mitte-Regierung dann am Ende dabei entstehen soll. Und du musst jetzt Leute aktivieren über die sozialen Medien, dass das cool ist, wählen zu gehen. Aber sollen die richtigen Leute wählen gehen? Ich könnte mir zum Beispiel etwas vorstellen. Man könnte eine Kampagne machen, die sehr klar ist, insofern als sie nicht als Propaganda zu erkennen ist, in irgendeiner Richtung. Also natürlich kann jetzt niemand sagen, und geht mal bitte die linken Wellen oder so was, sondern man macht einfach eine Wahl, die ganz stark mit dem EU-Logo verbunden ist, mit diesem Blau und so. Du weißt, dass davon eine gewisse Gruppe von Menschen angesprochen wird, und die kann man auch dazu aktivieren, zur Wahl zu gehen. Da kann man ein paar Prozent mehr erreichen, die dann zur Wahl gehen. Und das ist ja dann auf Europa gesehen, sind das viele Millionen. Du weißt aber dann zugleich, dass du mit diesen Sternchen und dem Blau momentan die AfD sowieso nicht erreichst. Du erreichst aber auch damit nicht Linke, die die ganze Zeit kritisieren, was die EU da macht mit der Grenze, wie dort Flüchtlinge im Meer ersaufen. Die sagen nicht, ich hänge mir jetzt mal den bunten EU-Poli, den blauen EU-Poli über und laufe mit dem Fernseher durch die Gegend. Das heißt, diese lässt man damit auch außen vor. Und so hat man ganz geschickt, wenn man das jetzt wollte als Plattform dafür gesorgt, dass eher so diese Mitteleute wählen gehen. Und schon hat man eine Manipulation hergestellt.
Genau, du kannst alles machen. Und ich würde sagen, wir haben ja ganz am Anfang übers Nichtstun, übers Dulden, das Aushalten, das Nichtreagieren, einfach sozusagen passiv sein. Das wichtigste Moment ist Demobilisierung. Du kannst auf Facebook ganz wunderbar den einen, deine eigene Zielgruppe sagen, das ist die wichtigste Wahl aller Zeiten. Und den anderen kannst du sagen, in China ist schon wieder ein Panda geboren worden, der hat diesmal zwei schwarze Flecken auf dem Kopf. Und dann gibt es übrigens noch eine Wahl, aber ist nicht so wichtig. Also du kannst die Leute wunderbar demobilisieren durch alle anderen Themen. Und ich glaube, wenn man eine Strategie entwickeln wollte, müsste man sich eigentlich nicht so sehr mit der eigene Wählerschaft befassen, sondern auch mit der anderen unter der Maßgabe, sie zu demobilisieren. Das haben die Republikaner ganz wunderbar gemacht, also wunderbar im Sinne von sehr vielversprechend, mit diesen ganzen institutionellen Ideen. Also straffällige Menschen dürfen nicht. Dann macht man die Wahlkreise irgendwie so, dass alle Schwarzen, die wählen E, dann wählt der eine Wahlkreis zu 99% blau, aber dafür die anderen drei dann mehrheitlich gerade so rot. Das kann man so organisieren. Und so wie man das institutionell machen kann, kann man es, glaube ich, auch ideell machen. Also die Leute einfach wirklich rauskegeln aus so einer Diskussion, die da vorher stattfindet. Ihen zeigen, das ist alles viel zu wirr und es ist egal. Irgendwie die ganze Zeit vom Bürgermeister erzählen, wer eine Präsidentenwahl ist und was der so alles macht, damit man den Präsident eher aus dem Blick verliert. Und da kann man natürlich krass mega steuern. Facebook hat ja all die Erfahrungen gemacht. Die hatten ja damals so ein Engagement-Loch, als sie nämlich zuerst festgestellt haben, auf Facebook wird nur Müll gepostet. Wir brauchen hier mal ein bisschen ordentlichen Content. Also sind sie an die Medienhäuser gegangen und haben sich deren Material geholt und haben dann als allererster im Newsfeed, als allererster Eintrag, war immer irgendwas von einem Medienhaus, bis sie dann festgestellt haben, die Leute verwechseln das jetzt hier als Nachrichtenseite. Die sollen doch eigentlich mit ihren Freunden integrieren. Also haben sie die wieder rausgenommen und haben die Freunde wieder reingepackt. Das war dann sozusagen der halbe Tod für ein paar Medienhäuser. Und sie haben aber, diese Effekte spüren sie ja dann. Wenn du Facebook aufmachst und du siehst zuallererst das Kindergesicht von, keine Ahnung, dem Kumpel, des Kind und so, dann bist du da halt engagiert. Wenn du erst mal drei Nachrichten von Spiegel online liest, die ja alle fünf Minuten da reinbuttern, ist es halt anders. Und diese Effekte kann er alle wunderbar aufschlüsseln. Er weiß ganz genau, um wie viel Prozent hoch und runter die jeweiligen Organisationen des Newsfeed gehen. Und da es bei Wahlen ja am Ende immer nur um ein paar Prozente Unterschied geht, ist das, glaube ich, komplett in seiner Kontrolle. Also er könnte, wenn er wollte, tatsächlich im Sinne von Harari, sich die Regierung da zusammen basteln irgendwie. Aber er hält sich noch zurück. Mal gucken, wie lange noch. Tristan Harris beschreibt hier mal eins der Probleme, indem er die kostenlose Kultur auf der einen Seite führte, dann zu, naja, Kosten fallen ja trotzdem an.
Wie viel kostet das unsere Gesellschaft? Wir haben gesagt, dass das die teuerste Geschäftsmodell, die wir je kreiert haben.
Ja, und könnte man das vielleicht mal durchkalkulieren? Wie viel Geld haben die Leute gespart, dadurch, dass Facebook nicht im Jahr 50 Dollar kostet? Oder 500 als Abholzeitungsgebühr, keine Ahnung. Und zu welchen aufsummierten Kosten hat es eigentlich gesellschaftlich geführt, so vier Jahre Trump?
Also, dass es noch mal ein bisschen umgedreht der Vorschlag, den ja John Lanier gemacht hat, dass man eigentlich Geld verlangen müsste als User von den Plattformen. Denn wir stellen ja unsere Daten zur Verfügung. Und das ist aber noch mal die ganze Sache sehr schön umgedreht. Also welche Kosten hat das einfach produziert?
Und derzeit bleibt alles kostenlos. Wir sind als digitale Zombies ökonomisch am meisten wert.
Es gibt Antifruss-Scheine, aber man bezahlt Geld in die App-Store. die Lernprogramme, die Schulen, die Khan Academy, und so weiter, fliegt mehr Geld in die Richtung, in die die Leute diese Werte bekommen. Und die Revenuesplitze zwischen Apple und den App-Developern geht mehr an Dinge, die Leute helfen, als Dinge, die nur für die Anerkennung und Monatisierung gut sind. Einer meiner Lieblingsfragen in dem Film ist Justin Rosenstein vom Like-Button, der sagt, so lange wie ein Wälder ist mehr tot als lebendig, und ein Baum ist mehr wert als Lübber und 2x4s als lebendiges Baum, jetzt sind wir die Wälder, wir sind das Baum. Wir sind mehr wert als lebendige, wachsende Zivilisten oder wachsende Kinder, die spielen mit ihren Freunden.
Der Staat könnte ein Budget schaffen, um einen anderen Benefit zu machen, als nur wenn die Werbebranche Geld verteilt. Dass man da wirbt, wo es ein Engagement am höchsten ist, also wo die Leute am meisten durchdrehen. Das klingt natürlich immer wie so eine Träumerei. Wer hat das möglich? Kann man sich das vorstellen? Sollte man jetzt irgendwie so an öffentlich-rechtliche Budgets denken, sodass man dann irgendwie sagt, Facebook, gestalte mal den und den Newsfeed, den man dann auch anklicken kann. Der wird aber nicht von der Werbung finanziert, sondern von uns. Und wir machen dann so einen Fernseherat und entscheiden darüber, was denn da drin und was nicht und so. Das ist ja schon alles ziemlich abgespacet. Tristan Harris berichtet hier noch mal von einer taiwanesischen Lösung, die unerwarteten Konsens in sozialen Netzwerken betont. Also nicht die Ränder jeweils, sodass die da im Blick gegenüberstehen, sondern unerwarteter Konsens wird da algorithmisch herausgearbeitet.
Audrey Tang, sie ist das digitale Minister von Taiwan, und sie haben ein System gebaut, das unerwartete Konsens ist.
Würde mich ehrlich gesagt auch interessieren, inhaltlich.
Aber ist das möglich? Also wir haben jetzt zum Einstieg gehört, dass jemand, weil er ein paar Zeilen aus einem Rap-Song zitiert, gebannt wird, weil die zu doof sind, das zu erkennen. Und der weiß jetzt der Algorithmus, was Stefan Schulz und Wolfgang M. Schmidt miteinander verbindet, was sie trennt, wo sie miteinander in den Dialog treten können. Ist nicht auch vielleicht eine Einübung im Umgang mit Social Media das Entscheidende? Also ich sag mal so, alle Hörerinnen und Hörer unseres Podcasts, das behaupte ich jetzt mal, sind in der Lage, einen Monat lang die Bildzeitung zu lesen, ohne dass sie dadurch schlimm beeinflusst werden. Sie haben die mediale und intellektuelle Kompetenz, können diese Zeitung lesen, werden nicht danach sagen, schlimm nur noch Clankriminalität und hoffentlich kommen nicht noch mehr Flüchtlinge, sondern sie werden weiterhin aufgeklärte Bürger sein. Das muss doch auch möglich sein in Bezug auf die sozialen Medien. Also ich weiß, wir haben jetzt die Corona-Leugner vor Augen. Das ist auch sicherlich eine sehr extreme Gruppe. Aber das muss doch auch zu schaffen sein, dass man eine Gelassenheit dazu entwickelt, auch weniger Zeit dort verbringt. Ich war ganz erschrocken darüber. Und das war, glaube ich, ernst gemeint, dass Jan Böhmermann sagte, er verbringe sechs Stunden täglich bei Twitter, was ja richtig, richtig viel Zeit ist. Also das frage ich mich dann, ob das nicht dann auch... Also sicherlich müssen diese ganzen... Muss reguliert werden und, und, und. Also das will ich jetzt gar nicht abschreiten. Ich will jetzt nicht auf das Individuum packen. Aber ich glaube, man muss auch, glaube ich, ganz stark dafür sorgen, dass eine Kompetenz dann wirklich eintritt, dass man sagen kann, ja, das gibt es zwar. Und ich kann das sogar schon mal genießen. Also ich bin ja auch schon mal bei Bild.de und lache über die Post von Franz Josef Wagner. Aber ich sage ja nicht, ach ja, so ist es. Wie gut, dass da jemand ist, der noch die Wahrheit schreibt. Das würde mir jetzt nicht einfallen.
Also es gibt unter Millennials so eine Idee über sich selbst, dass man nämlich für Werbung nicht empfänglich sei. Werbung ist etwas, was die Babyboomer verführt, aber nicht uns. Wir sind doch die aufgeklärten und so weiter. Und in Studien hat man danach gewiesen, ja klar, Millennials gucken die Werbung für Babyboomer und denken dann, was soll ich mit so einem scheiß Auto? Wenn man aber auf Instagram entsprechend Werbung macht, dann fallen die alle in die Falle rein. Deswegen würde ich diese Idee von, also bei der Bild, klar, das ist dieses ganz extreme Beispiel, von der lassen wir uns nicht mehr überzeugen. Von unseren Timelines allerdings schon. Also die, die, die, die Verführung sind dann doch schon scharf. Und wir sehen auch nicht, was uns nicht angezeigt wird, was ausgeblendet wird. Und diese Idee hier von Tristan Harris aus Taiwan, das ist wahrscheinlich auch noch so eine kleine App oder so, ja, die jetzt gar nicht so in eine mega Rolle spielt, aber so als Idee, dass man sagt, wir haben deinen, also wir wissen ja, wem du auf Twitter folgst und auf Facebook. Und wir verbinden da und wir gucken da mal, wo es echte Überschneidung gibt. Dann finde ich, kann man, ich glaube, da liegt ein gewisses Potenzial drin, weil mein persönliches Interesse ist auch relativ hoch an solchen Stories. Ich folge zum Beispiel so einen Twitter-Account, der twittert immer, was in der rechten Blase gerade an Texten kursieren. Und ich finde das hochinteressant, weil manchmal sind so Texte dabei, wo ich denke, ja, klar, die sind aus anderen Gründen am Datenschutz interessiert und so weiter, ja. Aber irgendwo gibt es dann doch Überschneidungen, wo man mal so ein paar Diskussionen auch mal inhaltlich führen möchte. Ohne, dass man dann immer gleich mit expliziert und übrigens, du bist ja noch so ein halber Rassist so nebenbei, ja. Ich finde, das könnte man so ab und zu dann doch mal links liegen lassen. Man darf es nie vergessen, man sollte es dann auch wieder aufgreifen. Aber so ein paar Diskussionen, ich meine, im Alltag gibt es ja auch viele Diskussionen, die man so führt mit seinen Nachbarn oder so, ohne dass man weiß, wie die wirklich drüber denken, was Merkel 2015 gemacht hat. Und dann irgendwann später fällt es einem auf und dann denkt man, mit dem rede ich nie wieder, und zwar über gar kein Thema. Und genau das ist ja dann der falsche Impuls. Das sollte man irgendwie umdrehen. Und ich könnte mir schon vorstellen, dass es da technische Möglichkeiten gibt, die allerdings dann auch ganz transparent damit umgehen. Also das, wo dann wirklich einfach dasteht. Nicht nur wir glauben, das ist jetzt der interessanteste Text für dich, sondern wir glauben, hier liegt so ein Match vor unter der Maßgabe, das ist eigentlich nicht so ein Typ für dich, aber der hat hier was geschrieben und so. Wer weiß. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie man das testen sollte und wie man sowas als Produkt einführt in so einem Medienmarkt. Also da... Ich würde mir jetzt nicht noch eine zweite Twitter-App, die das so als Experiment macht, installieren. Da wäre ich dann ein bisschen zu...
Dafür ist man dann wieder zu faul. Das darf man auch nicht unterstützen, die Bequemlichkeit des Algorithmus.
Genau, in deren Sicht keine Ahnung. Ich würde zum Abschluss ein Clip mal spielen aus This Week in Tech mit Corey Doctorow. Oh, Doctorow, den kennst du bestimmt auch. Großer, also wirklich großer, großer Typ. Und der hat hier mal beschrieben, was und wie die Politik jetzt Druck erzeugen kann. Das ist fast wie so eine Impfung gemeint, dass die Unternehmen selbstständig einfach sich eingestehen, hier haben wir Scheiße gebaut. Wir wissen, das ist blöd. Wir kriegen das zwar irgendwie gerechtfertigt vor so einem Kongress, aber eigentlich wissen wir auch, das ist scheiße. Und man muss entsprechend Druck machen mit den politischen Möglichkeiten, die man hat. Das geht jetzt ein bisschen in eine andere Richtung, aber hier geht es um das Kartellrecht und wie es die Chefs unter Druck setzt, wenn beispielsweise Google immer wieder auf die Idee kommt. Wir könnten ja im Google Chrome die Startseite einfach mal auf und so weiter einstellen. Also alle Benefits daraus ziehen, dass man so Märkte einfach dominiert. Und da gibt es doch eine jahrzehntelange Erfahrung damit, wie man diese Unternehmen einfach auch mal zu ressent bringt.
Es wäre ein enormer sozialer Vorteil, egal ob die Spezifiken der Technologieindustrie, eine vigoröse Verschmutzung zu erlangen, dass die Erkundung von Krediten, die Einführung von Monopolien und vertikalen Monopolien nicht ermöglicht werden.
Bill Gates, den Stand zu verbreiten, hat die Qualität in Microsoft verändert.
Aber das war sieben Jahre nach der Antitrust.
Ja, also das Kartellrecht kann hier wirklich für traumatische Erfahrungen sorgen bei Tech-CEOs und soll es auch, sodass sie selber drüber nachdenken, trau ich mir das jetzt ja oder nein, denn die Gefahr ist hier, dass mein Unternehmen zerschlagen wird. Und ehrlich gesagt, sowas wie Facebook, ja, Instagram muss natürlich da wieder rausgelöst werden. Genau. WhatsApp auch, das müssen eigenständige Unternehmen sein. Und bei Google erst recht. Die Googlesuche muss wirklich scharf getrennt werden von der Werbeplatzvermarktung im restlichen Internet. Also unterschiedliche Unternehmen müssen das sein. YouTube muss absolut ein eigenes Unternehmen sein.
Und das kann man ja wirklich regeln, und da sind wir überhaupt nicht in Zensurdebatten, Fake-News-Debatten und wie ist dann Algorithmus gesteuert, sondern damit wäre schon so viel gewonnen. Im Übrigen führt man diese Debatte sogar in China inzwischen, denn dort gibt es ja auch sehr mächtige Plattformen, also nicht nur Alibaba mit den ganzen Töchterfirmen, sondern auch andere wichtige Plattformen, die für die Werbung entscheidend sind, die für auch soziale Medien, Nachrichtendienste und so weiter entscheidend sind. Und auch dort gibt es immer mal wieder jetzt diese Frage, naja, muss da nicht auch der Algorithmus reguliert werden? Ist das nicht alles ein bisschen zu groß? Wir hatten da eigentlich Einfluss. Natürlich ist es in China so, dass wir die KP immer haben, die am Ende entscheidet. Das war ja auch ein wichtiger Fall. Jetzt hier Anfang November war es, glaube ich, ja Anfang November, dass Jack Ma mit dem Börsengang von Ant gestoppt wurde, also so ein Fintech-Unternehmen, das Kredite vergibt, bei dem man jetzt gesagt hat, nee, nee, ihr müsst aber schon auch so reguliert werden wie Banken. Und dann war erst mal dieser große Börsengang gestoppt. Man wird sehen, wie das weitergeht. Aber da ist man auch wohl erst noch am Anfang, was Algorithmen und sowas angeht. Das heißt, das ist eigentlich eine internationale Debatte. Ich weiß nicht, wie es in Russland aussieht. Die haben auch eigene Plattformen, ob es da auch schon diese Diskussionen gibt. Also eigentlich merken alle Regierungen gerade, dass diese Firmen eigene Staaten im Staat sind und dass das für sie gefährlich werden könnte. Also selbstverständlich hat auch eine KP ein Interesse daran, dass nicht plötzlich jemand anders sie regiert.
Ja, ganz genau. Also in deren Sicht, das werden noch interessante Neun Jahre.
Ja, wir gehen zum Konsum über und es gab ja ein...
Was kaufen wir denn?
Ja, hast du was gekauft? Das muss ich erst mal fragen. Black Friday, hast du das ausgekostet?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, da habe ich nichts.
Ich auch gar nicht. Ich merke überhaupt, dass ich sehr, sehr wenig kaufe. Ich fahre nochmal nach Düsseldorf, mal schauen, was es da gibt, aber die Städte sind auch ziemlich viel.
Das ist ganz große Angst, dass das Vorweihnachtsgeschäft wird. Nicht funktionieren diese.
40 Prozent Einbruch im November, sagt der Einzelhandel. Es gab etwas Neues zu berichten, aber was sicherlich den Konsum in den asiatischen Ländern verändern wird, also ein neues Handelsabkommen, RCEP. Aber wir hören jetzt erst nochmal Merkel im Oktober. Da gab es eine Asien-Pazifik-Konferenz und da hat sie ein kurzes Grußwort an diese Konferenz gerichtet und sagt da etwas, was sich jetzt natürlich fast ironisch anhört, wenn man mal bedenkt, was dafür ein Handelsabkommen geschlossen wurde.
Wir wissen um die weiter wachsende globale Bedeutung der Märkte in der Asien-Pazifik-Region. Und wir sehen, dass sich damit für unseren Außenhandel auch neue Perspektiven eröffnen. Derzeit gehen etwa drei Viertel unserer Asien-Exporte nach Ostasien, die Hälfte allein nach China. Angesichts dessen bieten sich noch viele Möglichkeiten der Diversifizierung und Erschließung weiterer Märkte in der gesamten Asien-Pazifik-Region.
Tja, Asien ist wichtig, aber man würde gerne diversifizieren, nicht nur China. Das heißt, man möchte ein bisschen unabhängiger werden von China, dass nicht der ganze Export daran hängt, aber naja, man hat wohl nicht damit gerechnet, dass wenige Wochen später dieses unglaubliche Handelsabkommen durchgesetzt wurde.
Also ich hatte das auch nirgendwo offenbar da.
Nein, nein, das kam total überraschend.
Das wurde hier nicht thematisiert und gar nichts. Das war dann plötzlich fertig.
Und die verhandelten ja doch schon eine Weile und China ist beteiligt. Es ist Indien ausgestiegen, aber Japan ist dabei, Australien ist sogar dabei, also auch mit Japan, Australien, also Länder, mit denen China durchaus Konflikte hat und viele, viele andere Länder, insgesamt 15. Und wir hören jetzt erstmal eine Einschätzung vom Institut für Weltwirtschaft in Kiel von Rolf Langhammer in der Deutschen Welle dazu.
Es ist ein wichtiges Signal, dass China in der Lage ist, eben jetzt auch nicht nur bilaterale Abkommen zu schließen mit einzelnen Asienstaaten, wie es auch schon beispielsweise nach der Südostasien-Krise Ende der 90er Jahre der Fall war, sondern eben mit einer gesamten Region, einschließlich Japan und einschließlich Südkorea. Und natürlich ist die Einbeziehung Japans besonders wichtig, weil Japan ja das Land war, das nach dem Rückzug der Amerikaner aus dem transpazifischen Abkommen versucht hat, unter den elf verbleibenden Mitgliedern noch ein solches Abkommen hinzuzimmern. Wir haben also überlagerte oder überlappende Mitgliedschaften. Japan wird weiter in der transpazifischen Wirtschaftszone aktiv sein, aber natürlich konnte es sich dem Drängen Chinas und auch der Asiastaaten nicht entziehen. Einfach deswegen, weil nicht nur China, sondern eben auch die Asiastaaten für Japan ein sehr wichtiger Handelspartner sind.
Ja, und überlappend ist ja auch, dass wir ja gar nicht vor allzu langer Zeit erst ein europäisch-japanisches großes Freihandelseinkommen gemacht haben, was ja diese Freihandelszone dann zur größten der Welt machte. Während gerade Brexit passierte und die da ausstieg.
Ja, wir hören einen kurzen Beitrag von Pa Kim Bang. Der ist Teil eines Indo-pazifischen Thinktanks und der äußert sich auch mal dazu, was dieses Abkommen jetzt bedeutet.
Well, first of all, this is only the beginning of the journey, a very complex and difficult journey.
Ja, das ist, glaube ich, etwas, was man jetzt einmal unterscheiden muss von so etwas wie TTIP. TTIP ist nicht gekommen, aber wäre es gekommen, dann wäre das ein Abkommen gewesen, bei dem doch sehr viel mehr festgelegt worden wäre, auch mit Blick auf Klimawandel, mit Blick auf Menschenrechte und und und. Das ist aber jetzt hier nicht vergleichbar. Man muss das ein bisschen anders lesen, dieses Abkommen hier. Das ermöglicht natürlich, dass Zölle abgebaut werden und und und, aber auch gar nicht in einem so drastischen Maße, wie es das Handelsabkommen zwischen USA und China getan hätte. Da war ja auch etwas auf dem Weg. Das hat ja Trump erstmal gestoppt. Wir haben jetzt von beiden gehört, ich werde hier also schnell kein Handelsabkommen machen. Wir müssen jetzt erst mal selbst gucken, wo wir stehen. Und deswegen gibt es da eher eine politische Dimension, nicht, dass da politisches drin steht, aber eine politische, geopolitische Dimension, die Gareth Leather anspricht von Capital Economics.
Es lässt sich auch in Asien ihre Influence erhöhen und die Rolle der USA übernehmen. Es ist also sehr viel eine politische Sache, die wir nicht in die Wirtschaftsrechte oder.
Arbeitsrechte und so weiter. Das ist erst mal nur Absatzmarktfindung China irgendwie so ersten.
Was sagt Michael Hüther dazu vom Deutschen Institut der Wirtschaft? Der spricht hier nochmal über die Produktionsketten. Wir haben ja im Zuge der Corona-Krise immer wieder gehört, naja, jetzt kommt die große Deglobalisierung. Naja, nicht so ganz.
Aber es setzt dort an, wo die Globalisierung unserer Zeit ihre Dynamik gewinnt, nämlich in der Globalisierung der Wertschöpfungskettengrenze überschreitend. Das heißt, wir differenzieren unsere Produktionsweisen und wir haben Vorleistungsbezüge. Wenn man das in der Region einfacher macht, wird das eine wirtschaftliche Dynamik nochmal zusätzlich bringen.
Das kann ich sagen. Ja, das ist, wir haben da gleich nochmal einen Ausschnitt von Langhammer dazu. Ich habe ja wirklich jetzt, das waren jetzt auch schon diese englischsprachigen Beiträge daher, soweit ich das recht erinnere. Ich habe einmal überlegt, ich muss doch mal ein bisschen aus der Filterbubble raus. Wir haben ja drüber gesprochen gerade und habe deswegen chinesisches Fernsehen mir angesehen. Also jetzt kann ich ja kein Chinesisch, aber es gibt ja einen englischsprachigen Sender, also vergleichbar vielleicht mit Russia Today gibt es auch für China CGTN. Natürlich wird da unten auch eingeblendet, wird vom Staat finanziert. Ich kann den Sender sehr empfehlen. Man kann bei YouTube da extrem viel sehen, denn die haben sehr viele Wirtschaftsexperten zu Gast oder auch Diplomaten aus den USA, aus Europa. Also es ist jetzt keineswegs so, dass dort permanent das hohe Lied auf Präsident Xi gesungen wird. Also sie machen zum Teil sehr, sehr interessante Sendungen. Man erfährt sehr viel über Dinge, die dort im Land geschehen, die man sonst vielleicht nicht so mitbekommt oder welche Debatten dort geführt sind. Und da gibt es jetzt auch eine Einschätzung von Surabh Gupta, der Indien-Experte wiederum ist, über Indiens Rückzug aus diesem Abkommen. Denn eigentlich sollte Indien ja dabei sein und ist ja auch nicht eine ganz unbedeutende Volkswirtschaft.
Indien ist nicht in der light manufacturing Supply Chain und ihr Produktionssektor ist aufgrund seiner E-Station-Payers nicht kompetitiv. Wenn Indien in RCEP teilnehmen würde, würde Indien bereits eine große Bilateral-Trade-Deficit mit China haben. Die Modi-Germany hat sich seit 2014 auf die Trade-Polizei nach hinten gegangen.
Ich bin immer hin und hergerissen bei Indien, man weiß immer nicht so genau. Ja, sie sind irgendwie mutig genug und schmeißen Facebook raus. Aber dann stellt man irgendwie fest, ne, so richtig kriegen sie es doch nicht hin und so, es sind doch noch zu viele Defizite, also dann doch noch so ein Dritter Weltland. Dann hört man jetzt wieder, ja, das große Ziel ist natürlich, eine Exportnation zu werden, die intern erstmal einen ordentlichen Arbeitsmarkt gestaltet. Gleichzeitig sieht man dann, wie sie jetzt unter Corona leiden und es ist wirklich gruselig, wie viel, also wie viel die wirtschaftliche Tätigkeit einfach da niederliegt gerade. Man kann im Grunde immer nur für Glück wünschen, wenn man das so hört, dass es dann auch irgendwann mal hinhaut, aber der Weg scheint schlimm zu sein.
Man hat es mit einer sehr rechten Regierung zu tun. Diese neue Abschottung, die dann auch aus so einem Nationalismus herauskommt, das soll dann vielleicht der große zukünftige Partner für die EU werden. Da wird ja auch gemunkelt, aber da muss man ja auch sagen, gut, wir können nicht zum einen sagen, China mit den Menschenrechtsverletzungen und dann jetzt anfangen, Indien zu umarmen. Da würde uns ja auch das eine oder andere einfallen. Also sehr, sehr heikel. Man sieht auch, je mehr man sich damit beschäftigt, insofern ist es auch ganz gut, so einen chinesischen Sender mal zu abonnieren. Dass es immer weniger eine Frage von Schuld und Unschuld oder so sich stellt. Also alles ist extrem miteinander verwickelt. Wir haben ja auch schon gezeigt, wie das Silicon Valley sich mit Indien verbündet hat. Eine Weile im Frühjahr war das. Australien spielt jetzt auch noch mal so eine Sonderrolle. Also wir wissen zum einen, die Bundeswehr will ein bisschen Australien im sogenannten südchinesischen Meer zur Seite stehen, um dort auch ja Macht zu demonstrieren. Zugleich ist aber jetzt auch Australien wieder involviert in dieses neue Handelsabkommen. Und da hören wir nochmal was von der Deutschen Welle zu.
Abgesehen davon könnte das Abkommen im angespannten Verhältnis von China und Australien helfen. Beide Länder liegen im Konflikt, seit Australien mit Blick auf China eine gründliche Untersuchung der Herkunft des Coronavirus forderte. Peking hat deswegen Importer aus Australien beschränkt. Der australische Handelsminister Simon Birmingham lobt die Bereitschaft von beiden Seiten, am jahrelangen Schöpfungsprozess der RCEP weiter mitzuarbeiten. Ja, es gibt momentan Schwierigkeiten, und ich bin besorgt darüber, dass Chinas Strafaktionen den Handelsfluss gestört haben. Ich bitte alle Mitglieder der RCEP, dem Abkommen nicht nur den Buchstaben, sondern auch dem Geiste nachzufolgen.
Ich meine, Australien hatte mal China zurückgeschlagen, das habe ich auch schon mal erzählt, weil die dann herausgefunden haben, ach, die wollten ein Prozent unserer Landmasse kaufen für Landwirtschaft und so weiter. Da wollte China Australien so richtig austricksen einfach. Und jetzt machen die so ein Handelsabkommen, während sie gleichzeitig da im Wasser so...
Es ist undurchschaubar. Die Frage ist, wie stellt sich die EU dazu?
Während die EU selber mit Nordafrika in manchen Ländern da Freihandelsverträge macht, während unklar ist, darf man das überhaupt, weil es da um annektierte Landflächen geht, für die das dann mit gilt, dieser Freihandel und so weiter. Also West Sahara ist das Stichwort da.
Nun gibt es so eine neue Rhetorik bei den Freihandelsverfechtern. Seht doch mal her, was die da machen. Jetzt müssen wir aber auch, und ihr, die ihr mal mit den Menschenrechten kommt, mit ihr TTIP-Gegner, jetzt fasst euch mal an die eigene Nase. Und das halte ich für sehr fatal. Also jetzt versucht man wieder zu sagen, gut, die machen das jetzt. Da müssen wir uns aber auch mal von unseren Standards, oder man könnte auch sagen von unserem Universalismus trennen. Und da wird dann so ein bisschen getan, als seien all die, die sich gegen TTIP gestellt haben oder es kritisiert haben, auch die Art, wie es überhaupt lanciert wird, jetzt werden die als die großen Blockierer dargestellt. Und da hören wir jetzt mal drei Beispiele. Einmal nochmal Rolf Langhammer.
Und die EU setzt sich selber fesseln, indem sie ihre Abkommen verbindet mit politischen Zielen bzw. einem politischen Dialog. Sie setzt auch weitergehende Ziele wie Nachhaltigkeit, eben Schutz der Zivilgesellschaft, Förderung kleiner mittelständischer Unternehmen. Und das versucht sie in Abkommen wie zum Beispiel mit dem Mercosur-Partnern in Südamerika eben zustande zu bringen. Das ist in Asien, in Ostasien sehr schwierig. Einfach deswegen, weil dort Menschenrechte nicht gerade im Mittelpunkt des Interesses stehen. Zum Beispiel ist es bisher nicht möglich gewesen, dass die EU mit den Asiankörptern ein Abkommen schließt, weil eben Länder wie Thailand mit einem Militärregime oder auch Myanmar mit der Behandlung der Rojindas eben nicht den Kriterien entsprechen bei den Menschenrechten, die die EU als absolut zwingend ansieht. Das heißt, was Europa zurzeit gegenüber Ostasien vorzubringen hat, ist ein zwei sehr wichtiger Abkommen. Auf der einen Seite mit Südkorea und mit Japan und auf der anderen Seite eben der Versuch mit China über ein bilaterales Investitionsschutzabkommen Verhandlungen zu Ende zu führen, die ja bereits seit sieben Jahren laufen und die letztlich in diesem Jahr unter der EU-Präsidentschaft Deutschland eben abgeschlossen werden sollten und eben nicht zustande gekommen. Das heißt, die EU wird sich wohl bewegen müssen. Entweder sie nimmt Abstand von ihren strikten Vorgaben bezüglich eines politischen Dialogs und politischer Kooperation oder sie wird gegenüber asiatischen Ländern ins Hintertreffen geraten, was den Abschluss von Abkommen anlangt.
Was hier als ein schönes Entweder-oder aufgetan wird, ist ja gar keins. Also er sagt ja jetzt nicht, entweder man hält sich an dieses strikten Abkommen oder man macht nochmal eine Neuauslegung eines universalistischen Prinzipes. Sondern hier ist ja eigentlich nur entweder mal Hälter und Fester, verliert man. Oder halt wir passen uns diesen Standards dort an und sagen, Menschenrechte sind gar nicht so wichtig. Jetzt gucken wir erst mal, was der Handel so bringt. Aber der Einstieg… Das finde ich sehr fatal.
Der Einstieg in das Gespräch, also klar, der kann das so sachlich durchargumentieren, aber dass er dann gleich von ja, wir legen uns da selbst in Fesseln. Das ist ja schon ein klarer Werturteil irgendwie, ne? Das finde ich auch ein bisschen überdeutlich vielleicht.
Bei Michael Hüther wird das jetzt auch nicht besser.
Sie haben den Arbeitsschutz genannt als einen Punkt, der immer wieder kontrovers ist. Die sozialen Standards, wenn wir es so formulieren wollen, spielen ja aus der europäischen Sicht immer eine große mitentscheidende Rolle. Damit haben die Asiaten weniger zu tun. Wird es dann noch die Forderung und die Interpretation aus Kreisen der Wirtschaft, der Wirtschaftsexperten, dass weniger Sozialstandards gut ist für die Entwicklung der Wirtschaft?
Nein, Sozialstandards müssen in jeweiligen Kulturräumen verankert sein. Wir können nur nicht davon ausgehen, dass unsere sozialen Arbeitsschutzstandards einfach woanders auch toll gefunden werden. Das ist eine Frage des Entwicklungsniveaus, das ist aber auch eine Frage der kulturellen Einbettung. Und das kann man nicht isoliert auf einzelne Sozialstandards sehen, sondern wenn er in einer Gesellschaft anders abgesichert wird, dann ist das auch in Ordnung. Da muss man von wegkommen, seinen eigenen Standard zum Standard der Welt zu machen, aber zu fragen, was ist fair?
Das war aber immer die Idee des Universalismus gewesen, oder die Idee der Menschenrechte ist das überhaupt. Die Idee der Menschenrechte bedeutet nicht, die einen verstehen das unter Menschenrechte, wir diesem und die anderen jenes, sondern die Menschenrechte werden als universell angesehen und deswegen müssen sie auch universell eingehalten werden. Und da gibt es nicht das, was hier vorgeschlagen wird. Und das ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen böse, dass ich das mache, aber ich will es trotzdem tun. Ist eigentlich ein Konzept, wie wir das bei den neuen Rechten in Frankreich inzwischen, aber auch in ganz Europa finden können, nämlich das Konzept des Ethnopluralismus. Der Ethnopluralismus sagt, jeder bleibt in seinem Kulturraum, da haben wir so unsere Eigenheiten, da mischen wir uns aber nie ein, wenn die einen sagen, wir verheiraten unsere Frauen mit 14, dann ist das halt so, dann ist das halt eine kulturelle Macke und wir haben eine andere kulturelle Macke und jeder lebt so und wir machen das nicht. Das ist tatsächlich dann das Ende eines solchen Prinzips und man wird sich nicht wundern, dass es solche anti-universalistischen Ideen ganz stark gerade von Staatsphilosophen in China gibt, z.B. Zao, alles unter einem Himmel heißt das Buch, das bei Surgamp erschienen ist vor knapp einem Jahr und dort wird auch so etwas angestrebt. Also das ist schon sehr gefährlich. Da ist man schon fast wieder dankbar, wenn dann so ein Biden doch vielleicht mal poltern sollte und sagt, hier, da lassen wir nicht mit uns reden.
Also die europäische Diskussion zum Thema CETA und TITI war eigentlich ganz klar zu sagen, wir haben von der ILO, der Internationalen Labor Organization, also so eine UN-Gremium, die sich um die Arbeit kümmert, haben wir Arbeitsschutzkriterien. Da gibt es so ILO-Normen und da haben wir halt in Europa so alle acht, es sind glaube ich acht unterzeichnet, in Amerika nur die Hälfte und in Mexiko noch mal weniger und selbst China hat noch mehr als Amerika unterzeichnet. Als es dann hieß, wir machen jetzt CETA und da ja in Amerika auch ein Freihandelsraum mit Mexiko ist, gilt dann plötzlich eine überbandegespielte Freihandelszone mit Mexiko, also Deutschland und Mexiko stehen dann plötzlich im Wettbewerb, aber in Mexiko gelten diese ILO-Standards nicht, also diese eigentlich universalen, menschenrechtlichen und so weiter, sehr gut kodifizierten und von der UN abgesegneten, alle sind da Mitglied und haben das auch irgendwann mal bestätigt, aber dann eben noch nicht national ratifiziert und das war eigentlich ein ganz großer Hinderungsgrund, vielleicht sogar das tragende Argument, warum jetzt selbst die IG Metall da gesagt hat, also da nehmen wir mal von Abstand, das wollen wir so eigentlich nicht, dass solche Standards da gelten, dass die jetzt wieder rausfallen, klar es fällt jetzt auch so was Ich glaube, es gibt auch was wie das Schiedsgericht und so weiter raus. Es sind nicht die Freihandelsverträge neuer Typs, aber es sind halt diese ganz rudimentären Freihandelsverträge, die auch wieder nicht gut sind. Also in deren Sicht finde ich, dass die da aus Deutschland sogar sagen, ja gut, ist halt so. Ethnop pluralismus, also dadurch, dass das in bestimmten Kreisen noch mal extrem auf die Spitze getrieben wird, wie man das auslegen kann. Aber ich würde auch sagen, in die Richtung geht das schon mal. Und wir wollten eigentlich auch mit dem Lieferkettengesetz unsere Standards da exportieren. Das ist eigentlich diese ganze Idee davon.
Ja, sonst kann ich ja sagen, naja, die sind halt anders. Die haben halt, wie sagt der, so schön andere Formen der Absicherung. Nee, da sterben die Leute halt früh oder bekommen keine Medikamente. Und das finde ich dann wirklich auch skandalös, dass man hier Ijoma Mangold, Zeitfelotonist, der sich jetzt für Asien begeistert, dann auch im Deutschlandradio hört, der irgendwie ein bisschen gelangweilt ist vom Westen und jetzt da nochmal sieht, wie toll die Leute optimistisch in die Zukunft sehen. Ich meine, wer kann es ihm verdenken, der beschäftigt sich jetzt seit Jahr und Tag mit Gegenwartshumanen. Da würde ich mich auch nach allem anderen sehnen, aber damit fände ich alles gut. Und dann findet er jetzt nochmal hier so einen ganz kurzen Punkt, dass wir das eigentlich versäumt haben. Und er schiebt das eigentlich jetzt diesen doch sehr, sehr fundierten, wie ich finde, fundiert argumentierten TTIP-Kritikern in die Schuhe. Und da sagt er nämlich Folgendes.
Und Sie sagten jetzt Freihandlung, ich bin auch ein großer Freihändler. Aber unser Freihandelsabkommen in den USA, TTIP, haben wir lange vor Trump. Wir waren Trumpisten lange vor Trump in unserem Protektionismus.
Und so einfach kann man sich nichts machen, denn es war nicht so, dass die TTIP-Gegner wie Tilo Bode und viele, viele andere, oder auch die von Fridays for Future, die damals noch nicht so organisiert waren, aber doch von ökologischen Bewegungen her kamen, dass die jetzt sagen, wir wollen Protektionismus haben. Das war nicht deren Idee. Deren Idee war, dass man mehr Standards einbringen muss. Man kann sehr darüber streiten, ob man generell auf Freihandel verzichtet. Ich glaube, das würde nicht funktionieren in einer globalisierten Welt. Aber jetzt so zu tun, als seien die, die das damals kritisiert haben und gerade dieses durch und durch intransparente Vorgehen, wer da lobbyieren konnte, wer dort die Verträge gesehen hat, wenn nicht, dass man das jetzt die Kritik daran als Trumpismus darstellt. Das ist wirklich ein unsägliches Argument.
Ich finde, da muss man eh aufpassen, wenn man Trump als Maßstab in die Diskussion einbringt, um daran Urteil scharf zu machen. Das ist eh immer so albern auch.
Ja, aber jetzt gehen wir mal von dem ganz großen RCEP weg und schauen mal auf unseren Konsum vor Ort. Wir hören erst mal einen ganz kurzen Beitrag Deutschlandfunk. Es geht hier um unsere Shopping-Wochen im November, denn der November ist der Shopping-Monat. Nicht nur mit Black Friday, mit Cyber Monday und mit Singles Day in China. Es wird wirklich nur geschoppt.
Frankfurts größte Einkaufsmeile, die ZEIL. Deutlich weniger Menschen als sonst sind unterwegs, zumindest wenn man es mit anderen Jahren vergleicht. Keine rosigen Aussichten für den Einzelhandel, sagt Andreas Scheuerle, Konjunkturexperte von der Dekabank.
Wir haben es im Moment mit einer Situation zu tun, wo in vielen Ländern der Einzelhandel komplett geschlossen ist. Und selbst in Deutschland, wo er eigentlich noch offen ist, wird der Einzelhandel unter den Schließungen der Gastronomie, unter der Absage von Weihnachtsmärkten leiden.
Allein im zweiten Quartal ging der Konsum nach Angaben des Statistischen Bundesamts um gut 11 Prozent zurück. In normalen Zeiten ist der private Konsum eine wichtige Stütze der deutschen Wirtschaft und macht mehr als die Hälfte des Bruttoinlandsproduktes aus.
Hätte ich auch nicht gedacht, dass das so wichtig ist. Aber du weißt es, du hast es gelesen, was Peter Altmaier sagte, einkaufen gehen ist eine patriotische Aufgabe. Und da gab es ein sehr schönes Foto. Ich weiß nicht, ob das alle gesehen haben. Man sah Altmaier im Marsanzug mit einem Fahrrad dort stehen, auf dem Gepäckträger ein Adventskranz. Und vorne waren Geschenke auch schon hübsch eingepackt weihnachtlich. Das hat man wirklich wunderbar gestellt. Ja, peinlicher geht es dann kaum noch. Aber was wir auf jeden Fall festhalten müssen, Konsum ist wichtig, es wird weniger konsumiert. Online sieht das Ganze selbstverständlich anders aus. Der Einzelhandel vor Ort, der hat extrem zu kämpfen. Wir hören jetzt erst mal ganz kurz Donata Riedl vom Handelsblatt, die ist auch beim Deutschlandfunk zu Gast.
Aber die Frage, die also gut, es gibt irgendwie vielleicht Rabatte, was aber natürlich mitschwingt, möglicherweise kauft man durch diesen Rausch, der da entsteht und entstehen könnte auch Sachen, die man sonst nie gekauft hätte. Also wie würden Sie das auch so als Wirtschaftsjournalisten beurteilen? Ist das im Prinzip so die ein ganz klassisches Instrument der Bedarfsweckungsgesellschaft? Also da wird nicht bedarfgedeckt, was brauche ich wirklich, sondern mir wird überhaupt erst der Gedanke in den Kopf gesetzt, das müsste ich dringend haben, weil ist es im Moment gerade so günstig?
Ja, gut, klar. Aber das ist ja in einer Konsumgesellschaft letztlich ja auch durchgängig normal, dass man nicht nur den ganz dringenden Bedarf deckt, sondern dass es natürlich auch Lustkäufe gibt und Frustkäufe gibt und dass davon natürlich auch viele Händler und Anbieter von Waren ganz gut leben können.
Auf welcher Spur sind diese hoch investigativen Journalisten da gerade? Das ist ja unglaublich, was sie ans Tageslicht fördern.
Mal eine ganz wichtige Konsumkritik. Und kann das sein, dass wir auch schon mal Dinge kaufen, die wir nicht unbedingt brauchen? Wir haben doch noch zwei Pullover im Schrank liegen. Und so muss es dann jetzt noch der dritte sein. Das ist aber für mich jetzt ganz symptomatisch. Deswegen habe ich es ausgewählt. Ich fand es so schön, dass es dann auch noch mal beim Deutschlandfunk gebracht wurde. Was man dann bei Twitter lesen kann oder das liest man dann noch mal ganz häufig auf Facebook. Ich habe extra noch mal Facebook geguckt. Da sind ja auch viele, die nicht den Schritt in die Moderne zu Twitter geschafft haben. Und dort findest du dann am Black Friday und drum herum noch mal solche konsumkritischen Artikel, die dann auch gepostet werden. Nur ja, man kauft ja jetzt auch Sachen, die man gar nicht wirklich braucht. Als sei es je darum gegangen. Also ja, darum ist es mal gegangen 1951 oder so. Da war das, da musste man mal sehen, dass man wieder den Bestand herstellt. Da war ja viel kaputtgegangen.
Du wirst verführt.
Ja, aber jetzt...
Schaufenster sind dafür da, dich zu verführen. Hättest du es gewusst, ich dachte, das ist ein Informationsfenster.
Ja, wirklich sehr, sehr schön, dass das hier nochmal deutlich gemacht wird. Es war übrigens auch, ich hab ja dieses chinesische Fernsehen gesehen, da haben die auch solche Sätze gesagt. Ganz amüsant. Aber da war dann immer noch jemand da, der noch mehr gesagt hat, ja, und das ist ja gut, dass wir nun endlich wirtschaftlich vorankommen. Jetzt geht es nochmal ganz kurz um Online-Handel. Da war dann auch zu hören, naja, gut, die Innenstädte werden immer leerer. Wie könnte man mit dem Online-Handel umgehen? Donata Riedl spricht das nur ganz kurz an.
Will man eventuell auf online verkaufte Produkte eine Extra-Steuer erheben oder so? Also das ist jetzt nicht völlig undenkbar, aber ich würde es dann nicht über die Mehrwertsteuer machen, sondern dann überlegen, wie man es über eine andere Konsumsteuer, dann eben über eine Online-Steuer eventuell macht. Aber die Frage ist natürlich, wollen wir das tatsächlich? Also da würde ich dann lieber auch nochmal erst mal ein bisschen tiefer und breiter darüber diskutieren wollen.
Das halte ich für unglaublich unmöglich. Richard David Brecht hat die Idee ja auch ein paar Mal vorgeschlagen.
Ich wollte es gerade sagen und der wollte ja dann so eine tolle Umlagefinanzierung. Also wir legen da fünf oder zehn Prozent auf online gekaufte Artikel, Steuer drauf und diese fließen dann in die Verschönerung, Erneuerung der Innenstädte. Ich kann dir mal sagen, was wir hier vor Ort hatten in verschiedenen kleinen Städten. Wir hatten hier jahrelang SPD wie CDU Bürgermeister oder Landräte, die dafür gesorgt haben, dass die Innenstädte und das war alles noch vor der großen Digitalisierung. Also, als wir gerade alle mal so ein Modem zu Hause stehen hatten, die haben dafür gesorgt, dass diese ganzen Innenstädte bald verweist waren, weil sie irgendwelche tollen Shopping-Malls errichten wollten am Stadtrand, weil sie Outlet-Center errichtet haben, weil sie dafür gesorgt haben, dass ja, unbedingt ein Media Markt und ein Saturn in der Innenstadt sein muss, damit auch die drei CD-Geschäfte, die es noch gibt, sich nicht länger mehr als drei Monate halten können. Man hat die Buchhandlung sogar zum Teil und Thalia unterstützt von den Schulen aus, dass die Kinder dort ihre Schulbücher bestellen und nicht in den anderen kleinen Buchhandlungen. Das heißt, zur Verödung der Städte haben diese Lokal- und Regionalpolitiker so entschieden beigetragen. Da musste Amazon gar nicht mehr so viel machen.
Da hat man auf den Track aufgesprungen, dass die Leute eh anders einkaufen wollen. Es ist nun mal sehr unattraktiv, in so ein großes Ding zu fahren. Ich war da schon ewig nicht mehr und fühle mich da auch unwohl. Diese Chance wird immer wieder übersehen, dass wir die Innenstädte jetzt mal attraktiv kriegen. Es war nicht mehr für eine Million Menschen, die am Samstag aus dem Rhein-Main-Gebiet auf die Zeil zu strömen. Das sehen wir in Amerika. Die Malls haben es gut gemacht, die relativ früh auf dieses Erlebnis orientierte. Du gehst da hin, aber du bringst da nichts mit nach Hause, sondern du konsumierst dort, du isst dort, du gehst da in einen Kinofilm gucken, wie auch immer. Dass man einfach so das Erlebnis in den Mittelpunkt stellt, aber dann nicht mehr mit diesen Mega-Umsätzen, sondern einfach mal so, dass es sich halt trägt wirtschaftlich. Es muss ja nicht immer alles gleiche Milliarden-Business sein. Das wird komplett verschlafen, hier in Frankfurt auch. Das ist so unglaublich, dass die Läden alle jammern und man aber null Ideen hat dafür, wie man jetzt mit diesen Städten, selbst die Straßenzüge, die letztes Jahr noch als, das machen wir jetzt mal autofrei, nur für Fahrräder und so weiter, sind wieder zurück, sind wieder Autowege. Während sie jetzt in Berlin wieder feststellen, ach so, wenn wir die Friedrichstraße autofrei machen, gibt es mehr lokalen Umsatz in den Unternehmen. Also es ist ganz komisch.
Ja und man kann ja ohnehin mal darüber nachdenken, dass ein öffentlicher Raum nicht immer nur einer sein muss, an dem es ganz viele Geschäfte gibt. Ein öffentlicher Raum kann ja auch bedeuten, dass dort Kultur, Bildung und all das stattfindet. All das, was man jetzt ja sowieso abgesägt hat durch diese Corona-Maßnahmen und zu wenig Unterstützung, da wäre ja eigentlich ein ganz neues Stadtkonzept erforderlich. Aber es kann doch niemand jetzt behaupten, dass es sozusagen unsere Leitkultur ist, dass wir möglichst viele Ketten irgendwo haben, wo die Leute dann hinpilgern, um dort ein stressiges Einkaufserlebnis zu haben. Und bei vielen Dingen weiß ich auch gar nicht, warum man es nicht online bestellen sollte, wenn ich doch weiß, was ich da habe. Also wenn die Heinzelmännchen nachts kommen würden und würden alles zum Beispiel wieder einräumen, was ich so im Alltag verbrauche, dann wäre das doch wunderbar. Also es kann doch nur, weil manche Leute nicht wissen, was sie tun sollen und gerne in Supermärkte fahren. Also ich habe diese Bedürfnisse nicht. Ich kann sagen, ich kaufe gerne Kleidung ein und das mache ich auch gerne vor Ort, weil ich gerne mal einen Stoff fühle und mal gerade ein paar Dinge anprobiere. Andererseits habe ich aber ganz viele Sachen, die mich nicht reizen würden. Also für mich ist ein Gang in einen Media-Markt, um mir eine Webcam neu zu kaufen, die Hölle. Da frage ich lieber Stefan Schulz, welche sollte ich kaufen? Und Stefan Schulz schickt mir dann schon den Link und ich brauche nur noch auf bestellen klicken.
Bei solchen Sachen, dass man sich wirklich erst im Laden inspirieren lässt von dem Angebot, das jetzt gerade durch Zufall auf diesem drei Metern Regal ist, das verstehe ich sowieso nicht. Also das ist sowieso ganz fern. Ich will natürlich das komplette Angebot weltweit einmal im Überblick haben. Und dann wird das nach Kriterien eingeschränkt und dann wird gekauft. Und also da ist sozusagen, wie soll ich sagen, da ist so ein Kaufhaus nicht nur einfach übrig geblieben in der Geschichte, sondern es ist richtig dysfunktional. Es funktioniert richtig falsch im Sinne von einkaufen. Ich habe einen ganz anderen Anspruch an einkaufen. Da wird nun mal online entsprechend befriedigt. Aber das offline einkaufen in die Stadt fahren ist dazu kein Äquivalent. Und deswegen würde ich es auch nicht verstehen, wenn die jetzt tatsächlich, kriegt man sowieso nicht argumentiert sind, nur so wilde Ideen, aber eine Steuer für online gekaufte Zeug, hieß sie ja eine Subvention für vor Ortskram. Und das wäre sozusagen auch so ein Sündenfall, wenn man dieses Instrument der Steuer nutzt.
Man würde ja vor allem ganz viele Konzernen Geld geben, die da ihre Wetten haben.
Das kommt noch sehr hoch.
Es ist ja gar nicht der kleine Handel nur. Und der kleine Handel wäre, glaube ich, sehr froh. Meine Mutter hat ja auch ein Modegeschäft, und die wäre sehr froh, wenn einfach für die Stadt optisch was getan würde. Wenn da ruhig mal die Kehrmaschine zweimal durchfährt in der Woche. Und wenn man mal sieht, dass man nicht alle Häuser so verfallen lässt und und und. Also das ist eigentlich das, was die Attraktivität einer Stadt ausmacht. Und gerade diese kleinen Geschäfte, die auf eine direkte Beratung abzielen, die haben ja noch eine bessere Überlebenschance, wenn sie in einem guten Umfeld stattfinden. Denn es gibt ja Dinge, die möchte man in einem Beratungsgespräch gerne erst einmal erklärt bekommen, die möchte man kaufen. Du bist jetzt sicherlich noch mal etwas anders da, weil du dich so stark informierst. Aber ich denke, bei einigen findet das noch so statt. Oder gerade wenn es um Klamotten geht, da bist du ja sehr effizient in deiner Kleiderwahl.
Absolut.
Bei mir darf es ja da ein bisschen ausgefallen sein. Und dann finde ich das schon sehr schön, wenn man dort beraten wird und wenn man auch einige Dinge gezeigt bekommt oder noch mal erklärt bekommt, warum das Innenfutter da so ist, dass es nicht geklebt ist. Oder was weiß ich. Das heißt, das sind eigentlich ganz gute Möglichkeiten.
Genau, das müssen dann aber die Verkäufer auch erklären können. Und bei sehr vielen Produkten hast du einfach im Elektronikladen. Also wenn ich in den Elektronikladen gehe und vorher mich über das Produkt informiert habe, bin ich doch besser informiert als den spontan angesprochenen, der da so rumsteht, weißt du, weil der kennt ja in unserem Laden auch nicht. Ich kann das allerdings gut nachvollziehen, was du beschreibst, denn es gibt einen Fall, wo das bei uns auch so gehandhabt wird, und das ist, wenn wir uns um die Brille der 7-Jährigen kümmern. Die kann natürlich nur vor Ort gekauft werden. Also das wäre für mich auch undenkbar, die einfach online so. Nee, die muss natürlich aufgesessen, und da muss auch eine Beratung stattfinden. Da will ich auch wissen, worum es da geht und so.
Beratung ist ein gutes Stichwort, ist auch in China wichtig, ist aber auch jetzt digital verlagert worden. Denn wir ahnen gar nicht, was eigentlich so das wichtigste jetzt für Online-Shopping in China ist. Weißt du das? Nämlich das Streaming.
Streaming? Ich hätte jetzt gesagt, dass das Zeug mal schnell kommt in so einem großen Land.
Nee, das scheinen sie irgendwie anders und gut zu regeln. Live-Streaming ist das Entscheidende für Alibaba und Co. Beim Singles Day, also der Singles Day ist ein Pendant zum Black Friday. Singles Day wurde 2009, glaube ich, ins Leben gerufen von Alibaba schon. Der Singles Day feiert, also den gibt es schon länger, den Singles Day gibt es, glaube ich, seit den 90er Jahren. Damit die vielen Alleinstehenden sollen sich doch Geschenke machen. Und dann hat man doch erkannt, ach, das ist doch eigentlich toll, um so ein großes Shopping-Event daraus zu machen. Und das hat Jack Ma erkannt, das hat Ali Baba erkannt. Und inzwischen sind hier alle auf diesen Zug aufgesprungen. Sogar in Deutschland gibt es ja jetzt auch diesen Singles Day ein bisschen schon zumindest. Man hat auch bei YouTube schon so mancher Shopping-Streamer gefunden oder irgendwelche Typen, die Gamer sind, die sagen, jetzt kann man da irgendeine Spielkonsole billig kaufen und haben dann auch fünf Stunden dazu gestreamt. Ich habe jetzt nichts daraus geschnitten. Ich habe nur mal so reingeguckt, also so langsam kommt das hier an. Ich würde mal sagen, zwei, drei Jahren wird das auch dichter an uns dran sein. Aber ganz entscheidend sind also Streamer, die Stunde um Stunde live streamen. Wir hören hier einmal rein, bei Alibaba hat schon sogar ein Werbevideo für Streaming gemacht und wirbt da, dass das eigentlich eine ganz tolle Sache sei, ob also entweder Streamer werden oder selbst das nutzen.
Also man streamt so eine QVC-Sendung oder wie ist das gemeint?
Also ich hatte vor zwei Jahren ein eigenartiges Erlebnis, das ich aber noch nicht einordnen konnte. Ich war in Düsseldorf beim Breuninger, einem großen Kaufhaus. Und dort stand ich in der Tom Ford-Abteilung, weil Tom Ford sehr schöne Parfums macht. Und dort war eine junge Frau, asiatischer Herkunft. Also sie sprach kein Deutsch, kein Englisch, sprach vielleicht Chinesisch, ich weiß es nicht. Auf jeden Fall hatte sie ihr Smartphone da, also auf einem Stativ und dann schminkte sie sich dort und zeigte Lippenstifte, testete die auch dann auf ihrem Unterarm, weil sie ja nicht alles sich draufschminken kann. Und dann sah ich das und war erst erstaunt und dachte, ach ja, das ist so ein klassisches Influencer-Marketing. Sie machte einfach jetzt so eine kurze Story oder irgendwas. Dann kam ich aber nach ein paar Stunden noch mal da vorbei, weil ich erst noch woanders beschäftigt war und habe dann die Verkäuferin von Tom Ford gefragt, sagen sie, was macht die Dame denn dort? Und dann sagte sie, ja, die streamt das. Die hat sich einen Termin geben lassen, dass sie das machen kann. Also Tom Ford hat dann Interesse daran, dass sie das tut. Und die streamt das. Und ich habe gedacht, komisch, ja, also dann sitzen da Leute und gucken stundenlang, wie sie dort diese Produkte durchtestet. Und ja, das ist tatsächlich das, womit extrem viel Geld verdient wird jetzt. Und hier wird mal bei diesem Alibaba-Spot so ein Beispiel gezeigt, eine Streamerin, die so, ja, ich setze mal so um die 30 ist, die in einem Schuhgeschäft jetzt für ihr Publikum dort Schuhe testet.
Sie versucht so viele Schuhe, tausende Schuhe. Sie fühlt, dass das eine Seite 7 ist, das eine wirkliche Seite 7 ist.
Und es ist fast wie du sie aufprobieren, ohne ihre Wohnzimmer zu verlassen.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich kann es ein bisschen nachvollziehen. Ich gucke mir auch gerne Reviews einfach auf YouTube an. Also das ist für mich der Windowshopping, sagt man ja, wenn man ohne, nur aus Informationsgründen, sich einfach mal Kram anguckt. Das wäre mir allerdings ein bisschen zu spontan, weil man weiß ja nicht genau, was macht sie da jetzt genau. Ich will ja dann schon dieses eine Produkt in so einem Video sehen. Das ist dann wahrscheinlich so richtiges Windowshopping. Also man geht dann mit ihr einkaufen und Alibaba sorgt dann dafür, dass immer der richtige Link mit dem Bild ist, falls man zugreifen möchte oder sich näher informieren möchte.
Genau. Es gibt ja da auch entsprechende Kooperationen jetzt. Also wir können das eigentlich durch die Bank erleben, wie man dieses Streaming jetzt in Deutschland im Westen entdeckt. Es ist so, dass man jetzt schon so eine Kooper... Also Shopify ist ja zum Beispiel ganz wichtig. Also Shopify ist ja, darüber haben wir nur mal kurz gesprochen, eine Plattform, die bietet online Stores an. Das heißt, jeder kann sich einen Online Shop machen. Wir könnten jetzt auch mit Shopify relativ leicht den Neuen Zwanziger Online Shop erstellen. Und die sind ja die großen Krisengewinner jetzt auch durch Covid. Und das ist das am besten bewertete Unternehmen in den USA. Und die kooperieren jetzt auch z.B. mit TikTok und auch mit Streaming-Anbietern wird überlegt, wie man dort zusammenarbeiten kann. Das heißt, wir haben eigentlich so eine ganz enge Verquickung jetzt vom Live-Shopping-Erlebnis und auch so einer direkten Verlinkung zu Shops wieder. Also da spielt Shopee feine Rolle. Und bei Alibaba gibt es dann nochmal andere Möglichkeiten, dass du dann diesen Shoe direkt anklickst und das wird dann über Dropshipping-Verfahren dann dir geliefert, sodass dann auch das Risiko für den Händler in irgendeiner Weise geringer wird. Also ein sehr, sehr komplexes System. Es gibt eine Dokumentation, die kann man, glaube ich, auf Amazon Prime in den USA sehen. Also irgendwie mit so einem Browser, der da alles umgeht, kann man das auch. Man kann sie, glaube ich, auch im Internet finden, so habe ich es zumindest getan. Die heißt People's Republic of Desire. Und dort wird mal dieser Streaming-Wahnsinn gezeigt. Also ich empfehle, das sich 90 Minuten mal anzusehen, denn diese Leute funktionieren, das funktioniert mit diesem Streaming nicht nur so, dass es um Produkte geht, sondern diese Streamer haben auch untereinander Wettbewerbe und man kann für sie voten und jeder vote bringt Geld. Und dann stacheln die sich immer gegenseitig an und die haben dann wöchentliche, monatliche Votes, um dann der Super Seller zu werden. Und hier hören wir jetzt mal in einer Podiumsdiskussion den Regisseur Hao Wu zu People's Republic of Desire, der ganz kurz was dazu sagt zu diesem Voting-Wahnsinn, der da zusätzlich zum Konsumwahnsinn noch stattfindet.
Every live streamer has to have an agency, needs to be managed by an agency. So whatever money the fans spend on buying those digital gifts and give to the live streamer, the platform takes a whopping 50 to 60 percent cut. Of the rest of the money, then 20 percent goes to the agency and the rest goes to the live streamers. So in many ways, the agency bosses, they have the incentive to promote the live streamers they manage. Because if they spend some money buying them gifts or something to make them appear to be popular, then that will in turn attract other fans, other patrons to spend money on them. So on YY, there's weekly competition, monthly competition, and then they have this annual competition. And since YY created this, invented this, all the other live streamers, they all have an annual competition, where it's almost like an orgy to come to see who has the most money and to show off wealth online. That's how they make money.
Unglaublich.
Stefan, ich stelle dich nur noch mit dem Kopf. YY heißt diese Plattform, auf der das geschieht.
Ich kann mir auch die Schnelle jetzt wirklich keinen Reim da aufmachen.
Ja, also man sieht das auch und man versteht das trotzdem nicht. Also man sieht die Dokumentation, also man versteht natürlich, was da vor sich geht, aber man versteht es eigentlich doch gar nicht, wie das überhaupt sein kann, dass Menschen dafür Geld geben und das dann bejubeln, dass dort jemand diese ganzen Tipps bekommt und wenn er auch nicht dann gut genug war, dann entschuldigt er sich bei den Fans. Also es tut mir so leid, dass ich euch enttäuscht habe. Es ist total absurd. Was auffällt jetzt bei diesem Singles Day ist erstmal, dass es wieder neue Rekorde zu verzeichnen gibt, also in einer halben Stunde an diesem Mittwoch im November hat in einer halben Stunde Alibaba 47, 7 Milliarden Euro umgesetzt. Wie viel? Also 47 Milliarden Euro umgesetzt, innerhalb einer halben Stunde. 250.000 Marken sind inzwischen bei diesem Singles Day dabei. Und 2019 waren es noch so, dass 61 Prozent der Marken, die dort verkauft wurden, die waren made in China. Made in China. Und jetzt sind es 66 Prozent. Also China ist gerade dabei, die lokalen Märkte, Firmen zu stärken. Und es findet ja eh so eine Nationalisierung, Renationalisierung statt. Und das bedeutet auch, man investiert mehr in die eigenen Produkte, will die eigenen Produkte unterstützen. Und das macht es dann schwierig für Firmen wie Nivea, WMF, Hugo Boss und und dort weiterhin Fuß zu fassen, wenngleich Alibaba die auch bewirbt und auch die alle da haben möchte. Wir hören jetzt mal den USA-Chef von Alibaba, der sagt jetzt etwas, was sie da für die Unternehmen tun. Michael Evans ist das.
Und ich denke, der wichtigste Message hier für die USA-Branden ist, dass eine China-Strategie und eine digitale Strategie in der postpandemischen Welt kritisch werden.
Ja, wenn es überhaupt. Also diese Abschottung, die kämpfen ja nun bewusst gegen europäische und amerikanische Marken. Es ist ja nicht nur so, dass sie da so unter die Räder geraten, sondern es ist ja schon mit Strategie gemacht. In der Ansicht wird diese Parierung dieser Welt wahrscheinlich doch noch mal zunehmen.
Möglicherweise ja. Also wenn selbst diese großen Konzerne da ins Hintertreffen geraten, dann heißt das ja was. Er betont jetzt noch mal, für die Kleinen ist das so wichtig. Das war dann auch immer wieder dort zu hören bei diesem chinesischen Sender, dass man doch das sehr in Frage stellt, ob das wirklich so den Kleinen so viel hilft. Dann es gibt immer so Erfolgsgeschichten, jetzt auch bei den Livestreamern auch Leute, die ihre Apfelsinen plötzlich im halben Land verkaufen können, weil sie Livestreaming machen. Aber am Ende ist auch da die Herrschaft des Algorithmus eine ganz entscheidende und die sorgt dafür, dass doch die großen Konzerne solche Verdrängungswettbewerbe da in Gang setzen, wie das ja immer ist. Es gibt da keinen Wettbewerb, das ist nicht wie Adam Smith das beschreibt auf dem Markt, wo sich da alle Akteure treffen und auf Augenhöhe begegnen. Und das ist auch ein Thema in China, also das ist nicht nur unsere Sache. Und eines fand ich sehr interessant, denn wir haben ja über Krisengewinner gesprochen. Wir haben darüber gesprochen, wie sehr Online-Händler generell jetzt durch dieses Jahr dazugewonnen haben und welche Erfolge die erzielt haben. Das kann man eigentlich auch schon bei einer anderen Pandemie erleben. Und da wird auch noch mal bei CGTN drüber gesprochen. Damals bei SARS, das hat ja China ganz enorm getroffen und ziemlich so, da beginnt eigentlich der Aufstieg von Alibaba. Wir hören da nochmal rein.
Jedes Lockdown, wir haben, wir haben ja die 2003 SARS-Pandemie in China. In 2003 und 2002, da war ein kleiner privater Unternehmen, die online Shopping und Internet machen, das Unternehmen Alibaba. Und von diesem Tag an, wird Alibaba China-Giants.
Krass.
Kann man mal sehen. Und das war nun wirklich nur eine kleine Sache, Saas, die ausgelogen wird.
Man musste aber irgendwie vertrauen. Man musste vertrauen, jetzt muss ich es halt online bestellen, geht nicht anders. Und das war die Chance.
Vielleicht ist dieses große Misstrauen in China, was man hier wieder dokumentiert sieht. Und dass selbst in China dann so was wie Alibaba eine Chance hat, während die sich ja da wirklich misstrauen in China. War vielleicht auch dann der Kickstart, da gab es ja dann Amazon schon und so weiter, Google, die waren ja alle schon da. Und die haben ja im Grunde nur Vertrauen als Businessmodel. Also vor allem Amazon kommt meine Lieferung wirklich an, selbst wenn ich nicht weiß, wo sie herkommt. Ja, weil Amazon regelt das. Paypal hat das ja auch gemacht für eBay, so dieses, dass er so als Treuhänder dazwischen ist. Und dieses Prinzip hat sich ja dann fortgeschlichen bei Uber. Kann ich diesem Fahrer wirklich vertrauen? Ja, weil Uber sichert sich ab, die wissen, wer da fährt und so. Das ist mir da alles ordentlich geregelt. Airbnb, kann ich die in meine Wohnung lassen? Das sind doch Fremde. Ja, das wird alles geregelt. Also dieses, inwieweit da eigentlich Vertrauen das Produkt ist, was diese Unternehmen herstellen und vertreiben. Das sieht man hier bei Alibaba. Das ist vielleicht sind so Zündmechanismen, wo es diese kluge Leute wie Jeff Bezos kurz hinsetzen, überlegen, worum geht es hier wirklich? Und dann kommen die, ah, Vertrauen. Und dann bauen die genau solche Vertrauensgeneratoren auf. Nicht schlecht. Aber ich bin mal gespannt, wann das hier so ankommt in unsere Rentenrepublik. Wenn ich die ersten Streamer durch die Stadt sehe. Singles haben wir ja genug. Ja, das stimmt, Singles immer genug. Aber vor allem auch viele 75 plus weiblich, ob die noch mal zum Handy greifen, um ihren Einkaufserlebnis zu streamen. Die alten Witwerinnen. Sehr gut. Damit ist ja November, sofern Sachen passiert sind. Da waren doch ganz große Geschichten, muss man nicht mal.
Ich finde schon, ja.
Mal gucken. Also im Dezember machen wir einen kleinen Jahresrückblick.
Ja, wir setzen uns in einen kleinen, großen.
Großen, große, große Event. Die große Jahresshow. Genau, wir übertragen diesen Podcast, die Aufnahme des Podcasts erstmals live. Allerdings natürlich nur für Salon-Mitglieder. Und zwar während alle zu Hause sitzen und Langeweile haben, während sie das härteste Weihnachten ihrer Geschichte überstanden haben. Am 29.12. das ist, wie vorhin schon mal kurz ermittelt, ein Dienstag.
Genau.
10 Uhr sind wir hier verabredet und dann streamen wir, weil wir wollen ja auch streamen. Es wird dadurch, dass wirklich alle zu Hause sitzen und wir uns denken, ich habe jetzt gerade in diesem ganzen Gespräch drei Schnittmarken untergebracht. Also wir können hier ganz solide vorm Hocker sagen, wir können das auch streamen. Das ist dann das fertige Gespräch. Deswegen machen wir das auch am 29.12. und dann gucken wir noch mal zurück auf die großen Geschichten. Wir überlegen uns noch mal jeder vier, fünf Storys, dass man sich noch mal darauf besinnt, was es so bei rumgekommt.
Vielleicht passiert hier auch noch irgendetwas ganz spektakuläres, im Dezember. Wir werden sehen.
Genau, wir machen auf jeden Fall auch einen Dezember.
Der Podcast wird selbstverständlich auch für alle, die uns nicht überrascht, die abonniert haben, dann zu hören sein später. Aber das Live-Event ist dann hinter der Paywall. Und wir haben aber auch noch einen Salon vorher. Also der kommt ja in ein paar Tagen. Und wir haben schon gesagt, der Adrian Daupp hat da ein sehr, sehr gutes Buch über das Silicon Valley geschrieben. Ich stelle noch was noch mal vor zu Bergkarabach, noch mal ein Text. Und dann habe ich ein Buch gelesen über Weltraumrecht. Das ist jetzt neu erschienen. Das ist ein Lehrbuch. Das klingt jetzt alles ein bisschen trocken, ist aber doch interessanter, als man jetzt vielleicht vermutet. Denn dort sind viele Zukunftsfragen, die da verhandelt werden. Und vielleicht auch die Frage, wie eine internationale Gemeinschaft sich da noch mal anders bilden müsste. Davon werde ich auch berichten.
Sehr gut, genau. Adrian Daupp, ich freue mich sehr drauf. Es ist einfach ein Spektakel. Es hat mich wirklich Freude gemacht, das zu lesen. Als zweites Großes, Karl Lauterbach hat, ich meine, er übertreibt häufig, aber er hat mal wieder hingeschrieben, das ist der Text zur mRNA-Technologie. Falls man sich dafür interessiert, sollte man den lesen. Den werde ich mir also noch mal vorknöpfen, um dann einen gesammelten Eindruck und inhaltlich wiederzugeben, was da drin steht. Und die anderen drei werde ich mal noch auswählen. Die Auswahl ist diesmal ein bisschen größer. Ich muss mal ein bisschen sortieren dann, aber das wird bestimmt ein guter Abriss. Dann wollte ich hier noch kurz sagen, Wolfgang hat ein Buch.
Nein, das machen wir noch. Das dauert ja noch. Ja, das machen wir noch. Also es wird ein Buch geben von Ole und mir über Influencer, aber darüber reden wir noch mal an einem anderen.
Im Suhrkamp-Verlag. Ich wollte es ansprechen, um noch einen Clip zu spielen. Ich habe mit Ole auch schon korrespondiert, welche Art von Influencern ihr dann behandelt und welche nicht. Und der Tristan Harris, den wir jetzt ausführlich geguckt haben, der hat bei Joe Rogan auch noch mal kurz über Influencer gesprochen. Du kannst ja die Frage dann offen lassen, kommen diese Art der Influencer bei euch auch vor? Ich glaube nicht, denn ich weiß schon, in welche Richtung es geht. Aber trotzdem so inspirativ, in welche Art der Debatte haben wir denn im März, wenn dann das Influencer Buch da ist, könnte man vielleicht sowas hier dann auch mal mit reinholen.
Wir beginnen beispielsweise, dass eine neue Firma, VC-fundiert, über 125 Millionen Dollar wert ist. Diese sind virtuell Menschen, virtuelles Video, das mehr enttäuschend, interessanter ist und die Fans mehr mögen als echte Menschen. Microsoft schreibt ein Beispiel, das Chatbot, das nach neun Wochen die Menschen zu ihren echten Freunden preferiert haben.
Ja, ich hab mir das auch angesehen oder wir haben uns das angesehen. Es gibt das, glaube ich, sogar von Burger King, also von irgendeiner Fast-Food-Kette, die haben auch so eine Figur kreiert. Es gibt auch eine künstliche Mode-Influencerin, die also dann Instagram-Posts macht. Es gibt auch eine, die, also es gibt welche, die sehr menschlich aussehen oder die nicht mehr zu unterscheiden sind. Es gibt aber auch welche, die als Fantasiefiguren, also so Manga-artig oder so aussehen. Da gibt es eine, die auch posiert mit Rihanna oder Beyoncé oder so. Das ist noch ein recht kleines Feld, würde ich sagen, aber die Tendenz kann in eine solche Richtung gehen.
Ja, die Influencer, die wir haben, sind noch echte Menschen. Das ist ja auch ganz wichtig. Aber es könnte tatsächlich sein, so perspektivisch jetzt mal, dass man sich so sehr an dieses Artifizielle gewöhnt, dass das Artifizielle übernimmt. Also dass man dann wirklich, okay, ich nehme Abstand von der Person dahinter. Dieses ganze Celebrity-Gossip-Zeug lässt man dann irgendwie fallen. Ich sehe es bei Google News immer mal, wie dann doch wieder so die ganzen, was weiß ich, wie geht es jetzt der Laura vom Wendler und so was, ja, solches doch. Funktioniert noch irgendwie, aber diese Attraktivität. Die Neuen Zwanziger. Ich bin jetzt bei Instagram, da ist mir eigentlich egal, ob das jetzt echte Menschen sind oder nicht. Ich hab jetzt einen kleinen Ausschnitt gesehen bei YouTube von Disney. Sie haben ihre neuen Roboter vorgestellt und zwar die Stuntmen. Wenn Menschen so durch die Kante wirbeln, mit Händen, Beinen von sich gestreckt, von Häusern fallen, irgendwo drüber geschleudert werden oder so, wozu Menschen nehmen, wozu Puppen? Da kann man doch einfach Roboter nehmen, die sich dann originalgetreu diese Art der physikalischen, wie nennt man, Simulationen, kennt man vom Bildschirm selbst. Also man kann sehr gut Physik einfach simulieren. Und dann schleudern die da so diese Roboter rum, die dann entsprechende Superman, irgendwie Flugbewegungen entsprechend landen und so weiter. Also es geht jetzt ganz scharf in so eine artificielle Richtung. Wir hatten ja auch schon über dem Mandalorian, da sitzt ja auch der Regisseur, da filmt nur noch so eine LED-Linwand ab mit Schauspielern davor. Da findet ja nichts mehr richtig statt. Es geht wirklich in so eine ganz artificielle Richtung jetzt.
Die Frage ist, ob das dann am Ende funktioniert. Denn was ich ja sehe bei Instagram, und damit meine ich jetzt nicht Influencer, sondern generell Instagram-User ist, dass man so unglaublich gern Alltägliches teilt und auch so eine Fehlerhaftigkeit oder Beiläufigkeit dort thematisiert, was man dort alles einfängt. Das wird sehr schwierig zu programmieren sein. Also das ist dann die Frage, wenngleich man sagen muss, haben wir im Unterhaltungsfernsehen schon eine so starke Automatisierung, wenn du dir diese Protagonisten da ansiehst, wo du denkst, ja, wahrscheinlich könnte der Roboter von Disney dem Ganzen ein bisschen mehr Leben einhauen. Ich habe am Samstag reingeschaltet in die Weihnachtssendung von Florian Silbereisen. Und wenn man sieht, was da passiert, dann muss man sagen, ist jeder Algorithmus am Ende menschlicher. Und das ist so erstaunlich, dass da wirklich gar nichts mehr gemacht wird. Und umso trauriger macht es einen dann, wenn jemand wie Karl Dahl stirbt, den ich irgendwie immer sehr gemocht habe. Das ist vielleicht nicht eins zu eins mein Humor. Ich fand aber doch, dass wenn er in einer Sendung war, man doch noch dachte, da lebt ja einer, da passiert hier noch irgendetwas. Und sei es auch nur so eine Impertinenz, die er dort ausgedrückt hat, einem Roland Kaiser zu sagen, ja, am besten singst du schneller, dann haben wir es hinter uns. Das ist etwas, was eigentlich im Fernsehen nicht mehr stattfindet. Und damit hat man eigentlich dort schon ein Roboterfernsehen. Menschen spielen Roboter. Warum also nicht eher die Roboter Menschen spielen lassen?
Genau so ist es und so fühlen wir es auch. Damit sind wir hier vertagt in den nächsten Salon. Und dann am 29.12. zur großen Jahres-End-Schose. Und wir wünschen euch einen schönen Dezember. Übertreibt es mit Weihnachten nicht so.
Ja, jetzt vernünftig bleiben, damit der Januar nicht zum Desaster wird.
Ja, aber ich glaube, nur die Impfung hilft uns. Und das dauert ja alles noch bis April. Haut rein.